GONNA START TO AT TODAY'S
HEARING. A FEW MEMBERS OF. THIS
IS NOT AN ACTION ITEM HEARING
TODAY IT'S INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ABOUT ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT TOPICS THAT WE HEAR
OUR DISTRICT THAT'S HIGHER
EDUCATION ACCESS CALL IT SAYS.
WHETHER IT'S THE- CSU SYSTEM
THE UC SYSTEM OF THE
COMMUNICABLE SYSTEM IT'S AN
ISSUE THAT WE ALL KNOW VERY
WELL THAT HOME HERE QUITE OFTEN
WE ALSO NOTES AND FOR THE
FUTURE OF OUR ECONOMY. WELL
LOOK AT THE MOMENT TRANSFER
PAST DECADE I TALK WITH ALL THE
SEGMENTS ABOUT HOW CAN BUILD
CAPACITY THAT ARE CALLED THE
UNIVERSITIES NEXT DECADE. WE DO
NOT WE TALK ABOUT THE HEARING
FEW WEEKS AGO THAT WE NEED TO
ANY. NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS OF
BACHELOR'S DEGREES CALIFORNIA.
AT ACCORDING TO PP I SEE WE
NEED TO ENROLL ABOUT TEN
THOUSAND MORE STUDENTS EACH
YEAR AT OUR YES YOU SYSTEM. AND
ABOUT THOUSAND MORE THE UC JUST
THE END OF THE TWENTY TO TWENTY
THIRTY WORKFORCE A PROJECTIONS
HELLO ACTOR THEM GOOD. COMBAT
IS THAT MY CALIFORNIANS I YOU.
HAVE A SHIP THEIR PARENTS SEAT
THEY ONE THEIR KIDS TO GET A
DEGREE. AND ALSO MORE THAN HALF
OF CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS NOW DO. THE WORK THING
HE BECOMING IMPOSSIBLE FOR UC
AND CSU ESPECIALLY THROUGH AS A
THREE G. REQUIREMENTS. AND DOT
WITH THIS CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATE ROME AT UC AND
CSU HAS BEEN GROWING. WITH
ABOUT EIGHTY THOUSAND MORE
STUDENTS- AT YES DO. AND FOR
MORE. DENSE AT TO SEE. DECADE
YOURSELF. HOWEVER WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THE YOU SEE WE'VE HAD AN
ISSUE WITH FEWER CALIFORNIANS
FRANKLY GAINING ACCESS WE'VE
SEEN NON RESIDENT ENROLLMENT
ACTUALLY INCREASE WE HAVE A
TABLE AND PARENTS AND STRIKING
NUMBERS THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA TUDENTS IN UP CLOSE
OUT THING THAT WE KNOW WE NEED.
THE BAD NEWS FOR THE CS WITH
EVERY YEAR. QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS APPLY AND ARE TURNED
AWAY SO DEMAND IS FAR OUT
PACING SUPPLY- WE TRIED TO
ADDRESS THIS IN MANY WAYS WE
HAD I THINK A FAIR POLICY-
CREATING A FORMULA NICK FOR
NOT. ROMAN YOU SEE OUR
IMPLEMENTING NEW POLICIES IT
CSU DIRECT STUDENTS TO
SECONDARY CAMPUS OF THEY'LL GET
THE CAMPUS THEIR FIRST CHOICE
AND WE'RE DOING THINGS THAT THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE LIKE HE
INCREASING FINANCIAL LET.
MAKING COMMUNICORP FOR INSTANCE
FOR THE FIRST TWO YEARS SO
WE'RE DOING OUR PART WE'RE
TRYING OUR BEST WE KNOW THERE'S
A LOT MORE TO BE DONE. WE ALSO
LOOK AT THE ISSUE OF OUR CAMPUS
YOU KNOW WE HAVEN'T WE'VE ONLY
BUILT ON WHO KNEW. YOU SEE IN
CSU CAMPUS IN THE PAST TWENTY
YEARS WE BOUGHT YOU KNOW DOES
IT COUPLE DOESN'T STATE PRISONS.
ARE READY FOR USE HE IS HE SAYS
I'LL KNOW THAT'S THE MOST
APPROVING A DO WE DO NOW WE CAN
BETTER GET A LOT. CAN'T ENTER
OFF CAMPUS CENTER. THERE FOR.
INCREASE ACCESS FOR A CALL. OF
WE'RE GONNA BE TALKING ABOUT
THE CRATER WAYS TO ACTS THROUGH
OUR- HIGHER ED SEC SEGMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY WE ALSO KNOW
THAT PART OF THE PUZZLE TO. IS
ARE ON PRIVATE BECAUSE YOU
NEVER HEAR FROM THEM. A LATER
AS WELL. AS WITH THAT. WE'RE
GOOD AT. THE CALL. LETTERS
FOUNDATION. STARTED OFF THE
MORNING AND A GIVE A
PRESENTATION ON ADDRESSING
CAPACITY SHORTFALLS AT OUR
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN RDSP MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RE YES AND
KEPT A BOT AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY AT
THE COLLEGE FEATURES FOUNDATION
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY TO SPEAK ABOUT BUILDING
HIGHER EDUCATION CAPACITY FOR
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE SENSE TO
AGREED. TO WHICH THE DREAMS AND
STRENGTH ECONOMY AND SOCIETY
ISSUE OF QUEBEC THE IS VITAL
AND COMPLEX AND STEPS CAN TAKE
YOUR TURN TO ADDRESS IT COLLEGE.
NO A COMPLETE WRONG TIED TO AT.
BILL I WITH EVERY DAY CAPACITY
SHORT ALSO AFFECTS TO INCOME
AND THAT'S WHY WORK WITH ORGAN
AND ACROSS THE STATE TO
CATALYZE SYSTEMIC CHANGE CHRIS
DEGREE COMPLETION AND CLOSE
EQUITY GAP A COLLEGE FEATURES
FOUND RECENTLY COMMISSION THE
END WE NEED TO THE POST
SECONDARY CAPACITY IT IS IN THE
STATE. THIS PAST FALL WE ENTIRE.
ROOM FOR SIX ENDS AT OF
CAPACITY AT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AT UC CSU
THE INDEPENDENT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES AND IT ALSO LOOKS
AT CONNECTIONS TO THE WORK
FORCE AND ECONOMY AND WE'LL
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THAT TODAY. AS SO LET'S START
WITH. THE AS YOU MENTIONED YOUR
MCCARTY K. TWELVE AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT GAINS THANKS TO
EFFORTS IN UNDERTAKEN BY THE
STATE AND THE EDUCATION
SEGMENTS IN THE LAST DECADE.
MORE STUDENTS ARE GRADUATING
FROM. THAN EVER BEFORE FOR MORE
OF THEM COMPLETE A THREE
BECAUSE PREP COURSE WERE. AND
FOR IS TWELVE. XIN IS IN
DECLINE NUMBER COLLEGE READY
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES IS
EXPECTED TO CLIMB BY ABOUT 10%
ANNUALLY THREE TWENTY THIRTY.
AND IN ADDITION GROWING NUMBERS
OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
COMPLETE AND FOR PATHWAYS
CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION- AT A
FOUR YEAR INSTITUTION EXPANDED
STUDENT SUPPORT SERVICES AND
IMPROVE NATION WITH ADVERSITIES
HOPE. ARE FOCUSED ON HELPING
THEM AND FOR MORE EASILY. AND
WE CAN'T THAT'S THAT'S CAN YOU
BUT REPAIR HIGHER ED AND TO
SINCE STATE NOT. A PATH. WHAT
IT'LL SHOW YOU IS THAT IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN
SCHOOL YEAR ELIGIBILITY SIR
PASSED CAPACITY BY ABOUT
SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND
QUALIFIED STUDENTS AT
CALIFORNIA FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION. AND IF WE DON'T
ACT THAT NUMBER WILL NEARLY
DOUBLE ANY THIRTY CALIFORNIA
FOR YEARS NOT ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE A- AND FOUR FOUR
THOUSAND POLICY STUDENTS IN.
THE BY THAT THERE. COURSE PLUS
ABOUT. DOESN'T MEAN IT COLLEGES
BUT THAT'S NOT NEARLY ENOUGH TO
MAKE UP THE SHORTFALL. AND THE
COMBAT COLLEGES WHITE IN THE
STATE'S ALREADY DEEP RACIAL
INCOME IN GEOGRAPHIC INEQUITIES
STUDENTS FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR OF COURSE THE MOST TO
GAIN FROM A COLLEGE DEGREE BUT
THEY'RE THE ONES. WHOM THE
COMBAT CRISIS HURTS MOST THE
STUDENT BASIC FIGURES AND THEY
CANNOT AFFORD THE DIVISIONAL
BURKE. INTO PERTINI OUT
REGENERATE OUT OF THIS. AND AS
YOU CAN SEE INSIDE FOR. ACID IS
OUR PARTICULAR YOU IN REGIONS
WITH HIGH PROPORTIONS OF LOW
INCOME FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR FOR EXAMPLE IN BY
TWENTY THIRTY THE INLAND EMPIRE
WILL FACE AN ANNUAL COST CITY
GAP. TWENTY THAT AND SEATS FOR
THESE WHICH IS MORE THAN HALF
OF THE ESTIMATED QUALIFIED STE
SINCE IN THE RE. AT MILLER.
VALLEY WILL IN OKAY GAP OF
FOURTEEN THOUSAND SEATS. IS
SANTA IT SEE IF REGIONAL AND
OKAY THAT'S THE OF SIXTEEN
SEATS- AND OF COURSE THESE ARE
AND BY NO MEANS THE ONLY
REGION'S WITH THIS TROUBLING
TREND CAPACITY IS TRULY A STATE
WIDE TO AN ERROR COMMUNITY CAN
AND DO MORE TO ADDRESS IT AT
COMPOUNDING THIS CAPACITY TAP
HIS ARE CHANGING BONHOMIE AS
PAT APPS TWENTIETH. YOU SING TO
FOR WORK POLITICS AND- NUMBER
THAT BY TWENTY THIRTY THIS
TODAY THE SHORTFALL OF NEARLY
ONE POINT ONE MILLION WORKERS
WITH THE BATCHES IN I KNOW YOU.
YES PROGRESSES BE CLOSING THAT
GAP BUT DEMAND REMAINS HIGH AND
A LOT MORE MUCH MORE NEEDS TO
BE DONE. SO RECOMMEND THREE
CONCRETE STEPS TO ADDRESS
CAPACITY AND DEMAND FOR DEGREES
THAT INVOLVE INNOVATION ACROSS
SECTORS AND SEGMENTS FIRST TO
ACCOMMODATE DEMAND WE NEED TO
IMPROVE THE WAY WE SERVICE. CAN
TO EXPAND THE EGGS. YEAH OUR
TING STUDENT SUCCESS BORN.
STUDENTS EARN THEIR DEGREES
MORE EFFICIENTLY AND AS A
RESULT CREATE ROOM FOR MORE
STUDENTS WE APPLAUD THE STATE
TO LEADERSHIP ON MANY OF THESE
REFORMS WILL ENROLLMENT CLEAR.
WAYS LIMóN EDUCATION FORM AND
NOW IS THE TIME TO LEAN FURTHER
INTO THESE EFFORTS TO ENSURE
MORE STUDENTS ARE BENEFITING UP
FUTURE EFFORT SHOULD BE
GROUNDED IN STUDENT NEEDS AND
ADDRESS A NATIONAL CREDIT THE
BEAR SUCH AS THE FULL COST OF.
COLLEGE ATTENDANCE. THIS WILL
IMPROVE. AND ACCELERATE THE
STUDENT EXPERIENCE AND
SIMULTANEOUSLY INCREASE
CAPACITY. AT SECOND TO EXPAND
OUR SUPPLY WE NEED TO CHANGE
THE WAY WE USE SPACE AND
RESOURCES WE SHOULD LEVERAGE
PHYSICAL SPACE MORE CREATIVELY
SHARING ALL THESE AND OTHER
RESOURCES. EDUCATION INTO
EDUCATION CONSISTENT- I'M- HERE
LITTLE. THAT ESCAPES SHOULD
MAXIMIZE WILL RESET IS OFFER
MARK IS IN THIS IS EVENING AND
WEEKENDS. ADJUSTED BUSINESSES
THE FLEXIBLE AND LOCATION
HIGHER. NEEDS AT YOU THINK
BEYOND THE SMALL ONES AND TO
PASS. FURTHER HELLO CAPACITY OR
FALLS. BE A- THIS IN RURAL.
COLLABORATIVELY TO A EYES.
THIRD AND FINALLY WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON REGIONS WITH THE
GREATEST NEEDS AND REGIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS SHOULD BE KEY
PLAYERS IN THAT WORK CALIFORNIA
IS HOME TO SEVERAL REGION
OPERATIVES THAT WERE PROCESSED
AND EDUCATION SEGMENT DRESSED.
AND WE SHOULD REALLY BRIDGE
DOES EFFORTS DRESS CAN I SET
HAND THE GENERAL PARTNERSHIPS
CAN OFTEN MOVE MORE QUICKLY
THAN THE STATE TO IDENTIFY NEED
SECURE LOCAL SUPPORT. AND
INCREASED THAT MEET LOCAL
DEMAND AND ALSO DEVELOP PROP.
SEC I'M UP OF HIS BETTER. SO
FOR HIGHER READ OUR ECONOMY
NEEDS MORE WORKERS WITH DEGREES
AND WE MUST IMPROVE HIGHER
EDUCATION CITY TO MEET THOSE
DEMANDS THE STATUS QUO IS AND
TEN OF. AND I THINK WE ALL
AGREE THAT STUDENTS WHO ARE
THE- TWO CAN NEITHER HIGHER ED.
I AMONG THE STATE'S BEST ASSETS
WE WORK TO GET TO IN THE
STUDENTS TO FULFILL POTENTIAL
ARE YOU CAN READ THE BACK FITS.
ANY SO THANK YOU FOR THE ANY TO
PRESENT. OUR CAN COME. INTO IF
YOU HAVE THAT OKAY. I QUESTION
FROM. SPEAKER MR MEDINA. WOULD
YOU ABLE TO JUST QUICKLY LET ME
KNOW TELL ME- THE PERCENTAGE OF
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES WHO WHO
DOES TO FILL IN CALIFORNIA THE
A THROUGH G. REQUIREMENTS. THE
PERSON IT'S MORE THAN HALF FOR
SURE I THINK IT'S OF. I CAN'T
TELL YOU THE EXACT NUMBER BUT
IT'S DEFINITELY THE MAJORITY AT
THIS POINT OKAY AND WE SEE MUCH
OF A DECLINE WHEN YOU LOOK AT.
SPECIFIC RACIAL AND ETHNIC
GROUPS. IT KIND OF THE THERE
ISN'T A VERY IS ON THE ON THE
DIMENSIONS THAT YOU MAY THINK A
DEFINITELY ALTHOUGH THERE ARE A
LOT OF GAINES SIMPLY MADE A
LASTING YOU SEEM TO IN ALL OF
THE GROUPS OF ALL THE RACIAL
GROUPS- BUT THERE'S DEFINITELY
GAP BY. I THINK DEVICE AS WELL
AS EACH. AND WHEN WE YOU LOOK
AT ASSN THE IS THERE ANY WAY
FOR US TO KNOW HOW MANY
STUDENTS OF HOW MANY OF OUR
GRADUATES ACTUALLY GO OUTSIDE A
CALIFORNIA TO DO WE HAVE ANY.
OF THAT KIND OF DATA YEAH IT'S
HARD TO PINPOINT EXACTLY WHAT
THAT LOW BECAUSE OF OUR LACK OF
OUR DATA AND THAT KIND OF THE
NEXT ACROSS SEGMENTS IN THAT
WAY. AND WE KNOW THE THERE ARE
AND LEAVING I PERSONALLY. AND
TO WHICH THAT IS BECAUSE WE ARE
WE'RE NOT CONNECTED IN THAT WAY
WITH TWELVE I DO IT. DATE AS AS
WHERE THEY GO IN COLLEGE GIVE
SURE. MISTER REPP HE WAS CHAIR
YOUR SLIDE SHOWS SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND QUALIFIED STUDENTS-
COULDN'T GET IN THE UC OR- SEE
ISSUE IS THAT THEY CAN GET INTO
THE CAMPUS OTHER CHORES FOR THE
PROGRAMMER YEAH SO OUR BURNED
OUT THE DEATH BY LEVELING
DIRECTIONAL IS SO WE DIDN'T
LOOK AT APPLICATIONS AT THE
CAMPUS LEVEL SO IT'S NOT ABOUT
THEIR FIRST CHOICE APPLET THIS
IS ABOUT. STATE THE COMPLETION
OF A THREE G. HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATE. I TRANSFERRED KIND OF
ELIGIBILITY OR ADULTS WHO MADE
A SMALL SHARE ARE ADULTS WHO
MAY WANT TO GO BACK- AND TO
COMPLETE A COLLEGE DEGREE THEY-
HAD NOT COMPLETED SO IT'S NOT
ABOUT APPLICATION TO YOU KNOW.
IT IS A LEAD OR PARTICULAR
CAMPUS IT'S MORE ABOUT THE
BROADER SENSIBILITY BEFORE FOR
A YEAR AND IT ALSO AND PRIVATE
SAYS WELL OKAY FOLLOW UP ON MY
CALLER REMEMBER SIDE SO WE
DON'T KNOW. OF THE SEVENTY
THREE THOUSAND GOT IN SCHOOL
BUT WENT ONCE A MONTH WE DON'T
TRACK THE RIGHT SO WILL BE
ICING TO STATE TRACK THAT. NOT
NOT IN HEALTHY ADULTS BELIEF.
AND THEN YOU ALSO SAY THAT SEE
ISSUES PUT IN A NEW PROCESS
THIS PAST FALL- REDIRECTING
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
AFGHANS WHO DENIED ADMISSION TO
THE CAMPUS OF THEIR CHOICE NINE
HUNDRED WERE ACCEPTED AND AGAIN
DO WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED THERE
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND NOW I MEAN
I THINK THAT'S A LARGE.
QUESTION IN A BIG KIND OF.
TENSION IS NOT HAVING THAT
INFORMATION AND NOT KNOWING
WHERE MANY STUDENTS GO I MEAN I
THINK IN A TOTALLY WE KNOW MANY
GO TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES-
AND RIGHTLY SO AND MANY MANY OF
POSTPONED THEIR- COLLEGE TO
PLANS. UNTIL THEY FIND OUT
WHERE THEY GO WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF. A LOW
INCOME FAMILIES. THESE IN WHICH
KIND OF GOING OUTSIDE OF YOUR
HOME COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY IS
NOT FEASIBLE FOR THEM SO OFTEN
WE KNOW THAT MANY STUDENTS. DO
NOT CONTINUE- AND IF THEY DON'T
HAVE ACCESS AND THEIR LOCAL
STATION- OKAY. MARK THANK YOU
STRUCTURE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THE PRESENTATION. LET'S GET
GOING WITH OUR NEXT PANEL.
WE'RE HAVING FIRST THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE THREE SPEAKERS AND WE- WE
DO HAVE QUITE A LONG LIST OF
PARTICIPANTS TODAY AND WE KNOW
WE HAVE PUBLIC CALM AS WELL
WE'RE GIVING EACH. IT'S SO
YOURSELF ITSELF YOU'RE THE LAST
PERSON NODS THE FIRST PEOPLE TO
GET GOING AS WE GOT TO SET IT
DOWN. THANK YOU. YOUR MCCARTY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY THANK
YOU FOR THE INVITATION TO JOIN
YOU TODAY TO REPRESENT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA MY
NAME IS A LOT I SERVICE VICE
PROVOST FOR DIVERSITY IN
ENGAGEMENT AS WELL AS THE
INTERIM VICE PRESIDENT FOR
STUDENT AFFAIRS THAT YOU SEE I
FIND THAT THE TAPE BY PAMELA
BROWN WHO WAS OUR IN. THAT PLAN
THEY HAVE A CARMEN WHO OUR
SOCIAL DIRECTOR FOR STATE
GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS. AS
BACKGROUND THE NO UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATE
CAMPUSES ARE HOME TO MORE THAN
A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND UNDERGRADUATE FROM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. YOU SEE
STRIVES TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
TOP STUDENTS THROUGH A HOLISTIC
REVIEW OF THEIR APPLICATIONS
AND A ROBUST FINANCIAL AID
POLICY INTENDED TO ALLOW
QUALIFIED STUDENTS TO ATTEND
REGARDLESS OF INCOME. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE PERSON
CALIFORNIA HAS INCREASED
CALIFORNIA UNDER JOINT
ENROLLMENT BY NEED. TWENTY
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED STUDENTS.
THIS GROWTH IN RECENT
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS THIS IS
MADE POSSIBLE BY STATE SUPPORT
BOTH FOR UNDERGRADUATE AND FOR
GRADUATE STUDENTS. FULLY
FUNDING NEW ROMAN AT THE
UNIVERSITY ALLOWS FOR THE
HIRING OF FACULTY AND THE
SUPPORT SERVICES THAT STUDENTS
NEED. AND PRE FUNDING
ENROLLMENT ALLOWS THE
UNIVERSITY TO MAKE IT MISSION
DECISIONS FOR CALIFORNIA
GRADUATE. WITH. TWENTY IT'S
LIKE TO- SOME OF OUR ACCESS
TRENDS OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS. TURNING TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TRANSFER THE UNIVERSITY
ENROLLS APPROXIMATELY SIXTY
SEVEN THOUSAND NEW
UNDERGRADUATES EACH YEAR OF
WHICH NINETEEN THOUSAND HAVE
TRANSFERRED TO THE UNIVERSITY
FROM ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THIS YEAR
THE WRIST. IN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY STUDENTS THIS IS A
FOUR POINT 6% INCREASE OVER
LAST YEAR AND CONTINUES ARE
YOUR TO YOUR BOTH AND TRANSFER
APPLICATIONS. MORE IMPORTANTLY
THIS PAPADEMOS TELL MUCH
STUDENTS VALUE THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA. AS IN PREVIOUS
YEARS OUR CAMPUSES WILL
CONTINUE TO ADMIT EVERY
TRANSFER APPLICANT THAT WE
POSSIBLY CAN. WE'VE ACHIEVED
THE GOAL OF TWO FRESHMEN
STUDENTS FOR EVERY TRANSFER
STUDENTS SYSTEM WIDE AND WE
HAVE DONE SO FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS. THANKS FOR OUTLINED IN
THIS GOWTH AND THE RETENTION
AND COMPLETION FOR TRANSFER
STUDENTS AT THE UC. WE CAN THE
AIM FOR GREATER TRENT ACCESS.
TO SUPPORT ACCESS OR FACULTY
HAVE DEVELOPED NEW UC TRANSFER
PATHWAYS THESE PTHWAYS ARE
COMMON SET OF MAJOR PREPARE
TORY COURSES ACROSS ALL NINE
CAMPUSES. FOR THE MOST SOUGHT
AFTER MAJORS OR TRANSFER
APPLICANTS. THEY'RE CURRENTLY
TWENTY TRANSFER PLEASE OFFER.
JUNE TO COMPLETE THE TRANSFER.
WAY WITH THE STRONG ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE. BE WELL PREPARED
TO ENTER THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA CAMPUS IN THAT MAJOR
AND TO PURSUE A RAP. TO COMPLY
GEN. NOT DIRECT. INTO UPPER TO
JUNK. THAT'S RECALL FOR THE
DEGREE. COLLEGE STUDENTS ALSO
HAVE THE OF SECURING A UC
TRANSFER ADMISSION GUARANTEE A
TAG WHICH IS AN AGREEMENT OF
GUARANTEED ADMISSION TO AN
INDIVIDUAL MAJOR AT ONE OF SIX
OF UC'S CAMPUSES FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS TO
MEET PACIFIC COURSE AND GPA
REQUIREMENTS. STUDENTS TO
PARTICIPATED TAG PROGRAM
RECEIVE AN EARLY REVIEW OF
THEIR ACADEMIC RECORDS CAN RISK
EARLY ADMISSION. AND THEY
RECEIVE SPECIFIC GUIDANCE ABOUT
HOW TO PREPARE FOR THEIR ME AS
WELL GENERAL EDUCATION. THE
CAMP THAT FOR TEN. THIRTY
IRVINE. RIVER BARB. MEN'S NON
BUT- CAMPUS IF THEY'RE ON A
MISSION ELSEWHERE IN THE UC
SYSTEM. MOST RECENTLY IN FALL
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN YOU SEE
LAUNCH PATHWAYS PLUS PATHWAYS
PLUS ISSUE IS NEW TRANSFER
OPTION BASED ON OUR TRANSFER
PATHWAYS MAJORS. COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS COME ONE OF
THE UC TRANSFER PAT BASED AS
WELL AS A TAG IN THE MAJOR BY
COMPLETING THE PATHWAY WELL AS
THE BAG. THE STUDENTS AS
PREPARED FOR COMPACT DIVERT
MISSION ACROSS ALL OF UC'S
UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY SECURING
GUARANTEED ADMISSION TO ONE OF
THE TECH CAMPUSES STUDENTS
ENJOY THE SAME ADVANTAGES
ATTACK BECAUSE THEY RECEIVE THE
ADDED BENEFIT. FOR MULTIPLE
CAMPUSES BY LEADING THE PATHWAY
COURSEWORK WHICH PROMOTES THEIR
PRIME LEAD TO CREATE A TIMELY
DEGREE COMPLETION AFTER TO
SPAR. WITH WANT WAYS PLUS I'M
TO THIS ACADEMIC YEAR WE DON'T
YET HAVE OUT COMES TO SHARE.
HOWEVER WE ARE ENCOURAGED BY
THE INCREASE IN TRANSFER
APPLICANTS WITH TAGS THIS YEAR
WHICH WE REVIEWED PART NEW
ADMIT VIRGINITY. WE ALSO WANT
TO GROW DISCUSS WITH YOU ARE.
OPERATION AND THE CASE
PARTNERSHIPS SAY PAP PROGRAMS
WHICH ARE ALSO A KEY COMPONENT
OF OUR ACCESS STRATEGY SIX IS A
PORTFOLIO PROGRAMS EDUCATIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS AND TOOLS THERE
ARE THIRTEEN IN TOTAL THAT
SPANNED THE EDUCATION PIPELINE
FROM PRE SCHOOL TO GRADUATE
EDUCATION. THEY SERVE THE
STATE'S FIRST GENERATION LOW
INCOME AND UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS AND THE SCHOOLS THEY
IT INTO. THEY PUT PROGRAMS
REACH MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED TEN
THOUSAND K. TWENTY STUDENTS AT
MORE THAN FOURTEEN HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC KATO SCHOOLS
HUNDRED FOURTEEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AS WELL AS OTHER
INSTITUTIONS. SAVE UP ALSO
INCLUDES GRADUATE AND
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOL PROGRAMS
THAT PREPARE OUR HIGH ACHIEVING
FIRST GENERATION LOW INCOME YOU
SEE UNDERGRADUATES FOR CAREERS
AS ACADEMICS RESEARCHERS
PRACTITIONERS AND LEADERS. AND
THREE SAY PEP UC ENGAGES IN
EDUCATIONAL PARTNERSHIPS WITH
SECONDARY SCHOOLS OTHER
EDUCATION SECTORS COMMUNITY A
STORE STATIONS. AS AN INDUSTRY
PARTNERS TO ADDRESS INEQUITIES
AN OPPORTUNITY AND IMPROVE
ACCESS. WE ALSO QUANTITATIVELY
MEASURED THE DEATHS OF THE
PROGRAMS AND WHETHER THEY ARE
IMPROVING STUDENTS CHANCES OF
GETTING INTO COLLEGE AND
SUCCEEDING. ARE ACCOUNTABILITY
WORK IS GUIDED BY AN
ACCOUNTABILITY FRAMEWORK THAT
WAS DEVELOPED BY THE UNIVERSITY
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE
AND FLIGHTS FIVE AND SIX- SHOW
SOME OF THE OUTCOMES OF OUR SAY
PET PROGRAMS. FOR EXAMPLE
PARTICIPANTS HAVE HIGHER RATES
OF ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT COLLEGE
READINESS AND COLLEGE
ENROLLMENT ARE YOU'LL TO
APPLICATION RATES THE
UNIVERSITY FOR SAY PAP ARE
HIGHER THAN THE STATE AVERAGE.
SIMILAR SCENES FROM SAID. AND
BUILD A PLATE THE STUDENTS IN
ROLE IN ALL OF OUR PEPPER. IN
ADDITION TO RECEIVING SUPPORT
TO PREPARE THEMSELVES FOR
GRADUATE AND PROFESSIONAL
SCHOOL YOU SEE STUDENTS PROVIDE
DIRECT SERVICES THAT REACH THE
MOST AT RISK K. TWELVE YOU. AND
HELP THEM ASPIRE TO AND PREPARE
FOR COLLEGE. YOU SEE STUDENTS
ARE INSTRUMENTAL IN RECRUITING
AND YIELDING. OUR OUR STUDENTS
BY SUPPLYING THEM WITH PURE
PERSPECTIVE OF UNIVERSITY LIFE
AND PROVIDING THE ONGOING
SUPPORT THAT PROMOTES
ENGAGEMENT AMARA. STATE TAPE UP
HAS REMAINED CONSTANT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN TWELVE AT
TWENTY FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION-
AS A CONSEQUENCE THE SCOPE OF
STATE PET PROGRAM. BROKE BROKE
RAMMING HAS NOT GROWN
SIGNIFICANTLY IN RECENT YEARS.
THE UNIVERSE YES CHALLENGED IN
SERVING A NA UNDER RESOURCE
SCHOOLS AN IMP ING WITH THE
GROWING NMBER TWELVE COULD
CHARTER SCHOOLS. EDUCATE LARGE
NUMBERS OF STUDENTS FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS. SAVE
UP. REPRESENTS ONE OF THE
GUARANTEES OF THE UNIVERSITY
ONE OF ITS ITS ITS PRINCIPLES-
WE'VE HOW LONG DELIVERED HIGH
QUALITY PROGRAMS WE HAVE STRONG
OUTCOMES THESE PROGRAMS OPEN
DOORS AND CHANGE LIVES AND THEY
REPRESENT ONE OF THE CRITICAL
WAYS THAT YOU SEE SO. THOSE WHO
LIVE HERE. AND LEAD HE- AND WE
WILL WAS BY THANKING YOU FOR
YOUR PAST SUPPORT TO HELP US TO
STAY IN OUR FUNDING FOR THESE
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS I'LL NOW
TURN TO VICE PRESIDENT BROWN
WHO WILL DISCUSS OUR STRATEGIES
FOR INCREASING ENROLLMENT.
THANKS VERY MUCH. I REFER TO
THE INFORMATION SLIDE SEVEN UP
WHICH TALKS ABOUT ARE YOU SEE
TWENTY THIRTY GOALS. FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
MAJORITY OF OUR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS ARE PELL FIRST
GENERATION AND UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS. AND THE UC TWENTY
THIRD FRAMEWORK A PORTION OF
THAT IS FOCUSING ON INSURANCE
THE STUDENTS SUCCEED AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. OUR
FIRST GOAL IS- TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND MORE DEGREES BY TWENTY
THIRTY THAT'S A HUNDRED DEVELOP
UNDER. PLEASE FOR THE GRAD. IS
AND ON TOP ONE MILLION TREES
ALREADY HAD. ACTED UP SOME OF
THAT THROUGH IN ROMAN. CLEARLY
IT BAD WITH. ON A PUZZLE ON A
BECAUSE TAKE A LOOK STATE WERE.
NEEDS CONSIDERING GRADUATE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH IS IMPORTANT-
THAT CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT HAS
IDENTIFIED FEELS THAT WILL
REQUIRE GRADUATE DEGREES
PARTICULARLY IN HEALTH CARE AND
TECHNOLOGY. AND MARK. FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURES FOUNDATION
THEIR REPORT HAS ALSO
IDENTIFIED IN XIN GRADUATE
SEATS AND SO THAT'S AN AREA
WHERE WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT. OUR SECOND
GOAL IS FOCUSED ON ENSURING
NINE OF TEN UNDERGRADUATE
SCHOOL WANTED TO GET A DEGREE.
OF THE BIGGEST. OKAY THIS ONE
IS DURING TIME TUITION FOR PELL
FOR GENERATION. AND UNDER READ
IT'S DO THAT'S OUR NEW CHEN
STUDENTS WITH TO ENSURE THAT
THEY GRADUATE IN A TIMELY
MANNER WE ALSO WANT TO ADDRESS
GRADUATE DEGREE ATTAINMENT APPS
FOR THOSE ON SUSAN'S. AND IT
GIVES AN OPPORTUNITY AND A
FOCUS TO DIVERSIFY THE
EDUCATIONAL PIPELINE WITHIN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA- THE
TWO GRAPHS THAT WE SHOW AT THE
TOP HIGHLIGHT THE IMPACT THESE
STUDENTS NOT GRADUATE IN A
TIMELY MANNER. IT'S FOR STATE
THAT GREG MADE AND FOUR YEAR
THE BLUE A IN. FOR THOSE THAT
BRITAIN'S. WHICH IS IN RED THEY
AND TO LEAVE WAS FIVE HUNT MORE
IN DEBT. UP AND OVER THE FIRST
DECADE THEY WILL HAVE LAW
EARNINGS THAT AMOUNT TO ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND.
THERE'S A PERSONAL ECONOMIC
IMPACT TO THE STUDENTS TO NOT
GRADUATE IN A TIMELY MANNER AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE EMPHASIZING
THAT. AS BEING CRITICAL FOR US
WITH THE TWENTY TO GO ANOTHER
THING IT IS INSCRIBED IN SIX
YEARS COMPARED TO THEIR LESS
LIKELY TO GO ON TO GRADUATE
SCHOOL. AS WE WERE TO. THE PATH
TO GET. A DEGREE ALSO TO
IMPROVE DIVERSITY. TORY ING
ABLE TO ADVANCE PATH IN THE
PLANE IS EMPTY. SO THAT'S A
AREA OF FOCUS. NUMBER DO YOU
THINK. BY DID. ONE OF THE KEY
THING FIRST TO BE ABLE TO
GRADUATE IN A TIMELY MANNER IS
TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
SUFFICIENT COURSES TO BE ABLE
TO TAKENTO INCREASE THAT AND
IN FOR THE THIRD GOAL TO GROW-
ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
FACULTY OVER THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS. NOT ONLY THAT BUS
INCREASED NUMBER OF COURSE IS
THAT WERE OFFERING IT'LL ALSO
HELP ENSURE THAT STUDENTS ABLE
TO GET INTO THE MAJOR OF THEIR
CHOICE WHERE THAT IS LESS
LIKELY TO THAN IT WAS A DECADE
AGO. IT SCHOOL OR IN. OF IT'S
BEEN HIGHLIGHT THAT. HURTING TO
SEE A DECLINE IN FIRST YEAR
RETENTION RATES PARTICULARLY
AGAIN FOR A PELL FIRST
GENERATION UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS- AND WITHOUT
INVESTMENT WE NOT ONLY LOSE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. ADDRESS A THIS
GENERATIONAL OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE THESE IS A IMPROVEMENTS
IT'LL ALSO. DECREASE ARE LIKELY
HAD TO REACH THE DEGREE
ATTAINMENT GOALS. I'M TURNING
TO SLIDE EIGHT. THIS IS
FOCUSING ON- SOME OF THE
CURRICULAR STRATEGIES AND
ENROLLMENT GOALS THAT WE HAVE A
FIRST- OUR FOCUS IS ON SHARING
THAT STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO PASS
THE COURSE THAT THEY TAKE FIRST
TIME THAT THEY DO. A AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE WAYS THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS CAPACITY SHOES. WE ARE
LOOKING AT SOME LARGEST GATEWAY
COURSES THE MAJORITY OF OUR
UNDERGRADUATE STEAK AT WORKING
WITH THE FACULTY IN THOSE
COURSES THREE DOES AND THE
CURRICULA TO RE. THINK HOW
THEY'RE DELIVERING COURSES AT
AND TO PROVIDE WHAT IS TO I'D
IT FOR THEMSELVES THIS IS SO.
IN IN. IN. TWO NINETY TO MAKE A
CHANGE BEFORE THE END OF THE
COURSE OF VICE PROVOST GLAD HAD
TALKED ABOUT THE GROWTH THAT
WE'VE HAD WITH TRANSFERS WE ARE
EXPANDING OUR OPPORTUNITIES. TO
ON BOARD AND PROVIDE THEM
SUPPORT OVER THE SUMMER SO THAT
THEY HAVE A SMOOTH INTRODUCTION
AND PARTICULARLY GET EARLY
INFORMATION ABOUT.
OPPORTUNITIES AT OUR CHURCH
UNIVERSE INCLUDING RESEARCH. ON
IT AS WITH THEIR SHORTER TO
MONKEY. OF THE THIRD THING IS
TO ADVANCE OR PHOENICIAN FOR
STRATEGIES- THE BEACH A
TRADITIONAL. ADVICE OF IF YOU
WANT TO GET ON TO THE CAMPUS.
ARTS SLOW. AND ACCLIMATE TO THE
CAMPUS RECENT RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN THAT TAKING A FULL LOAD
IS JUST AS IMPORTANT TO AND IT
IS THE WAY TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE MOVING IN ON A
TIMELY MANNER SO. STRATEGIES
FOR ADVISING OR CHANGING A AND
WE'RE CHANGING SOME OF THE
POLICIES TO PUSH. A LARGE.
UNITS AT STUDENTS KING AND THEN
ACT ADVISING TO MEET THOSE
GOALS. I WE WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE SUMMER SUPPORT THAT WE
RECEIVE THE FINANCIAL AID- THAT
WE'VE GOTTEN THE CHART SHOWS
GROWTH THAT WE'VE SEEN AND HAD
QUE ROMANS OVER THE PERIOD JUST
IN THE LAST YEAR WE'VE HAD
ALMOST THREE. MORE AS IN ROUTE
SUMMER. AND AT THAT CONTINUE
FOR THE PORT IN IN ADDITION TO
THE SUMMER PAL IS HELPFUL FOR
US IN MEETING THOSE GOALS OF
GETTING OUR PAL FIRST CHEN AN
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS TO
GRADUATE IN. TIMELY MANNER.
GIVING MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN SUMMER BUT ALONG
WITH EXPANDING OUR
OPPORTUNITIES WITH SUMMER
BRIDGE AND TRANSFER IT AS
PERSONAL. FRIENDS THAT- GETS
SENT BILL THING THAT I WANT TO
TALK. IS A YOU SEE IS LAW THE
ONE TIME. THAT WE RECEIVED FROM
THE STATE TO EXPAND DEGREE AND
WORKFORCE CERTIFICATE
ATTAINMENT. OF THREE UNIVERSITY
EXTENSION- WE SENT OUT AN R. F.
P. WE'VE RECEIVED SEVEN
PROPOSALS FROM CAMPUSES THAT
BOTH WOULD- PROVIDE WORKFORCE
CREDENTIALS THAT ARE ON
CRITICAL TO. THE ECONOMY OF AND
ALSO BRING STUDENTS BACK WHO
ARE CLOSE TO BUT HAVE NOT
FINISHED A DEGREE WERE INTHE
PROCESS OF REVIEWING THOSE-
AND- WILL PASS IT NOW OVER TO A
COLLEAGUE TAKE. THANK YOU PANEL
UP I'M SAY EVER CANNON OF I
WANTED TO START OUT BY THINKING
THIS THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR FOR. OF PLACING
PROP THIRTEEN ON THE BALLOT
UNFORTUNATELY THE GEO BOND DID
NOT PASS BUT THE UNIVERSITY HAS
IDENTIFIED OVER TEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN CAPITAL OUT PROJECTS
THAT WOULD HELP US. A INCREASED
EDUCATION COMPOSITE ON OUR
CAMPUSES AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. AND FIVE
FINDING WAYS THAT WE CAN FIND
SOME OF THE PROJECTS AND
CONTINUE TO. LOOK FORWARD TO
THE FUTURE TO INCREASE PASADENA
CAMPUS. THANK YOU. OKAY THERE
WE GO. DESPERATE QUESTIONS I
HAVE A FEW BUT REACH OUT TO
OTHERS FIRST. OKAY MR MEDINA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR UP IN IN
OUR HAND OUT ON PAGE FIVE WE
HAVE- THE CHART GRAPH OF THE
ADMISSION RATE AT THE DIFFERENT
CAMPUSES OF UC. AND. AS YOU
GUYS KNOW I REPRESENT RIVERSIDE
VERY PROUD THAT UC RIVERSIDE
HAS AMONG THE HIGHEST-
DIVERSITY OF THE UC'S AS I LOOK
AT THE CHART ON PAGE FIVE AND
LOOK AT THE ADMISSION RATE AT
WHICH VARIES. FROM CAMPUS TO
CAMPUS IN OUR I. AS WE KNOW
UCLA AND BERKELEY BUT THESE
THESE FIGURES ARE ARE TELLING
WHICH HAVE THE LOWEST ADMISSION
RATE. ALSO ON PAGE FIVE OF MY
HAND OUT. THE MY AGENDA. SO
YEAH. THANK YOU FRONT PAGE FIVE
OF THE AGENDA. WE SEE THE
ADMISSION RATES ACT OF THE- OF
STUDENTS TO APPLY TO THE
DIFFERENT CAMPUSES. RIGHT I
BERKELEY 17% IF I'M READING IT
CORRECTLY OF FRESHMAN
APPLICANTS ARE ARE ACCEPTED.
RIGHT 26% OF TRANSFERS YOU UCLA
12% OF APPLICANTS ACCEPTED
RIVERSIDE UC RIVERSIDE GOES UP
IS. 57% UC MERCED WHICH IS ALSO
VERY DIVERSE 75% OF ADMITS ARE
ACCEPTED SO MY QUESTION IS TO
THE TO THE- GOAL OF DIVERSITY
AT THE OTHER CAMPUSES
SPECIFICALLY BURKE AND UCLA
WHAT ARE THOSE TWO CAMPUSES
DOING TO INCREASE THE DIVERSITY
OF LATINO AND AFRICAN AMERICANS
DO. AT WAS TO CAMP. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION BOB. WE WILL
BERKELEY HAS EMBARKED ON- TO
AYE IMPORTANT INITIATIVES I
THINK HERE ONE IS THEIR AFRICAN
AMERICAN INITIATIVE WHICH IS-
BACK BY SOME SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING TO CLOSE THE NATURAL
GAP THAT STUDENTS UP PERCEIVE
THAT THEY WILL EXPERIENCE IN
ACCEPTING YOU SEE OFFER OF UCLA
ALL OF THE CAMPUSES HAVE DONE
EXTENSIVE OUTREACH TO
COMMUNITIES EITHER THROUGH
FAITH BASED ORGANIZATIONS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS-
THROUGH OUR STUDENT INITIATED
OUTREACH PROGRAMS TO REACH.
COMMUNITIES AND HELP STUDENTS
HERE FOR AN UP TO THE IN. OF
UTAH UT. WE ARE ALSO SUING FOR
THE IS BEEN VERY INTENTIONAL
ABOUT PURSUING IT STATUS AS A
HISPANIC SERVING INSTITUTION
WHICH HAS EGGS ALLOW THEM TO
LOOK MORE CLOSELY AT WHERE
THERE ARE PERHAPS INEQUITIES AN
OPPORTUNITY. THAT UP FOR THAT
ARE BEING EXACERBATED BY BY
CERTAIN PRACTICES AND OF COURSE
WE'RE ALWAYS LOOKING OUR
HOLISTIC REVIEW PROCESS OUR
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW PROCESS TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT IS PROVIDE
THE MOST OPPORTUNITY FOR CAL OF
YOUR STUDENTS THAT BE SAID. BUT
BURKE IS A HIGH COLLECTIVE YOU.
IT'S A LOT OF APPLE AND SO WE
HAVE TO WE HAVE TO LOOK VERY
CAREFULLY HOLISTIC AND
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW IS ONE OF
THOSE STRATEGIES THAT WE CAN WE
CAN EMPLOY ALONG WITH- WERE
MORE- SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE
THROUGH- NEW INITIATIVES. AND
INTENTIONAL PURSUIT OF STATUS
LIKE AGES SITE WHICH OFFERS
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO THE
UNIVERSITY FOR FEDERAL FUNDS
HELP IMPROVE TEACHING AND
LEARNING- TO HELP IMPROVE
PRACTICE FOR THE UNIVERSITY.
SHOULD BE AN H. ASIDE IN
TUITION IT IT'S 30% I BELIEVE
RIGHT OF THE OF THE STUDENTS. A
30% 30% TWENTY. TWENTY FIVE.
RIGHT. PERCENT OF THIS. I HAVE
TO BE IN. I HAVE QUITE A TO GO
BUT THEY ARE INTENTIONAL ABOUT
ATTEMPT WHERE WHERE MIGHT THEY
BE NOW. I THINK THEY MIGHT BE
AT. FIFTEEN PERCENT. THE
PROJECT WILL CHECK OKAY BUT
THEY HAVE A QUITE A WAYS TO GO
RIGHT AND THEY HAVE AND THEY
HAVE A PLAN. IT'S GOOD TO HEAR
HER THANK YOU. QUESTIONS MISTER
GALLAGHER. YES ONE QUESTION I
HAD WAS WHAT ARE WE DOING TO
KIND OF CONNECT ACCESS
EXPANSION AND WORK FORCE NEEDS
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES. SO
MAYBE ARE WE ADDRESSING
ENROLLMENT GROWTH IN IN AND
INCREASED ACCESS BASED ON ANY
CORRELATION WITH STATEWIDE OR
REGIONAL MARKET DEMANDS FOR
WORKFORCE NEEDS YEAH THAT'S A
GOOD QUESTION- YOU WE CAN LOOK
AT SOME OF THE FIELDS THAT WE
HAVE THAT ARE GROWING THAT OUR
FOLKS DâN ON. A STATE
WORKFORCE NEEDS PARTICULARLY IN
HEALTH CARE AND IN TECHNOLOGY-
THOSE ARE TWO PLACES WHERE WHEN
WE LOOK AT ACADEMIC PROGRAM
GROWTH THAT IS BEING PROPOSED.
THAT WE'VE SEEN MORE PROPOSALS
AND A SPECIFIC INTENTION ON
MEETING- THE NEEDS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- IN ADDITION TO
THAT THE UNIVERSITY EXTENSION-
THEY ARE VERY. FOCUSED ON THE
LOCAL MARKET WHAT IS REQUIRED-
AND THIS A NEW PARTNERSHIP TO
THINK ABOUT- DECREE ATTAIN MY
GOALS BEING ABLE TO BRING
STUDENTS BACK THAT HAVE STARTED
BUT NOT YET COME. THREE AND
ALSO LOOKING AT WORKFORCE
CREDENTIALS- WHEN WE START TO
TAKE A AN INITIAL VIEW WITH THE
SEVEN PROPOSALS THAT COME IN.
WE CAN SEE THE INTENT IDEA OF
LOOKING AT WHAT NEEDED BOTH THE
PRO AND CONSIDER BACK WITH A
DEGREE THAT WOULD HELP THEM GET
INTO THE WORKFORCE AND IMPROVE
IN ADDITION TO SPECIFICS OF.
THAT NEED SO WE LOOK THAT YEAH.
BUILDING HAVE BEEN ON ON THE
CAMPUS AS IF MILLION AND ONE
FOR GIVES A NOT TO JUMP UP SOME
OF THAT WORK AND IN PARTICULAR
FOCUS IN AREAS OF BACK UP
BRINGING STUDENTS BACK SO THAT
THEY CAN COMPLETED CAREER BE A
COMPLETION PROGRAMS AND YOU
KNOW YOU BROUGHT UP HERE AND I
KNOW SPECIFICALLY IN MY REGION
SO REPRESENT THE NORTHERN
SACRAMENTO VALLEY. COUNTY AND-
MORE THAN CAL GENERALLY LOOKING
AT TRYING TO GET RESIDENTS PRO
AND CURRENTLY WITH UC DAVIS-
BEYOND THAT FRONT IS THAT
SOMETHING. THAT MIGHT FIT INTO
THIS WHAT WE'RE DESCRIBING HERE
YEAH AND YOU'RE DOING ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE COULD SHARE
WITH YOU IS THAT WITHIN THE
INFORMATION SENT WE HAVE-
STATED THAT. ALLOWS US TO TAKE
A LOOK AT BOTH RESIDENTS AND
THOSE THAT HAVE GONE ON TO GET
A MEDICAL DEGREE TO SEE
THROUGHOUT THE- FORM SO THAT WE
CAN SEE WE HAVE DOCTORS VETS
NUR. BOB IN THE TRAIN NOW WORK
IN THE LOWER COMMUNITY AND HOW
THAT HAS GROWN OVER TIME. OUR
INTENTION IS TO CONTINUE TO
SPEAK SPANISH LOOKING FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO SO OKAY MY
DEFINITELY LIKE THE- YOU KNOW
MARIN AND GET MORE INFORMATION
AND CERTAINLY WORK MORE. ON AND
IN MY MAIL ALASKA. THIS COULD
YOU GIVE SOME BACKGROUND ON
WHERE THE. YOU KNOW THAT THE
ENROLLMENT ROWTH AT THE STATE
HAS FUNDED OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS WHERE HAS THAT
MONEY BEEN ALLOCATED AND MAY
YOU PER PARTICULARLY I AM
INTERESTED IN- THE CAMPUSES
WERE THE HIGHEST DEMAND- AND
THE HIGHEST NON RESIDENT.
ENROLLMENT ARE THEY BEING
ALLOCATED A PROPORTIONAL AMOUNT
OF THE MOMENT GROWTH TO SERVE
CALIFORNIA'S RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS. OF
THANK YOU SIR THE NEW STATE
FUNDS THAT WE RECEIVE ARE
ALLOCATED THE CAMPUS BASED ON
SOMETHING WE CALLED THE REAP
BENCHING FORMULA WHICH IS
WAITED FOR STUDENT- WHERE
UNDERGRADUATES ARE WAITED A ONE
GRADUATE STUDENTS ARE LIKE A
TWO POINT FIVE FOR MEDICAL
STUDENTS ARE FIVE. THE FUNDING
FLOWS OUT THE BASED ON THE
TOTALNUMBER OF ENROLLMENT ON
EACH CAMPUS. A RESIDENT
ENROLLMENT ON EACH CAMPUS. BUT
WHEN WE LOOK AT- THE GROWTH
THAT WE'VE HAD OVER TIME SOME
OF THE CAMPUSES THAT HAVE GROWN
SIGNIFICANTLY ARE THE BURKE
CAMP SAN DIEGO LOS ANGELES THE
CAMPUSES ARE IN HIGH DEMAND
WE'VE SEEN A SIG GROWTH IN CAL
YOU READ STUDENT I'M I'M- I'M
NOT A VERY TRYING. IT UP
QUICKLY CAN YOU INFORMATION
THAT. YEAH AND THAT WOULD BE
GOOD I'D LIKE DEFINITE THINK
THE COMMITTEE WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN THAT. BUT WHAT I
HEARD THERE IS IT SEEMS LIKE A
LITTLE BIT. SOUND LIKE YOU'RE
OF DOING IT BASED ON WHERE YOU
HAVE RESIDENTS RIGHT NOW AND I
THINK. OUR CONCERN IS THAT
THERE'S MANY CAMPUSES THAT.
DON'T HAVE AS MANY RESIDENT
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS SO SHOULD
THEY BE MAYBE GETTING. THE MORE
MONEY TOWARDS INCREASING THE
AMOUNT OF THE ROMAN GROSS
THEY'RE BAD FOR RESIDENTS IN
PARTICULAR. DOES THAT MAKE
SENSE EARLY. IT SOUNDS LIKE
MAYBE THAT'S NOT HOW IT'S BEING
ALLOCATED THE FUNDS ARE ARE
ALLOCATED BASED ON ENROLLMENT
ON THE CAMPUSES IN THE NEW NEW
ENROLLMENT GROWTH THAT ACTUALLY
TAKE ON. OF AND THERE ARE SOME
CAMPUSES THAT ARE ABLE TO TAKE
ON FAR LESS OF SO EACH YEAR THE
CAMPUSES EVALUATE MANY. BUT YOU
KNEW. I THINK AND ACCOMMODATE
BASED ON THE HIRING THAT HAS
TAKEN PLACE AND THE FUNDING
THEY THINK THEY WILL HAVE FROM
ALL SOURCES. AND BASED ON THAT
THEY COME UP WITH OF A TARGET
OF WORK WITH YOU CO PIECE THAT
UP WITH THE TARGET AND ROLLED.
UP IF YOU HIT THAT GET THEM.
THE FUNDING. THEY THEY RISK.
DON REVENUE STUDENTS THAT THEY
IN RAW BUT THERE TO GO THAT
TARA OKAY WHO'S HERE THERE TARA.
RIGHT AND WHO'S BEEN THERE FOR
A MORE THAT FUNDING. OF YOU SAY
THAT. A LOT MORE THE RECENT
GROWTH HAS BEEN UP THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF GROWTH IN SAN DIEGO
FOR OUR SIDE. OF THEIR GET THE
GOTTEN SOME MORE OF THE FUNDING
MORE. BUT WE ALL HAVE A LOT OF
ON STUDENTS STUFF WE'VE TAKEN
ON IN THE LAST FEW YEARS WHERE
THE STATE HAS PROVIDED US WITH
GENEROUS AMOUNTS OF NEW FUNDING
FOR. STUDENTS BUT ACTUALLY OVER
AND ROLLED BEYOND THAT. AND SO
OUR CAMPUSES HAVEN'T BEEN
GETTING ALL THE FUNDING FOR
STUDENT THAT THEY ACTUALLY
NEED. SO WHERE WE OVER EMERALD.
OF AS A SYSTEM WHERE OVER AND
ROLLED BY ABOUT SEVEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS- AND- WHAT
CAMPUSES WELL WE DISTRIBUTE THE
NEW FUNDING BASE WE REDUCE THE
pTHROUGH BUT AT THE CAMPUS SAYS
BECAUSE IT'S A FORMULA THAT
DIVIDES AL THE DOLLARS ACROSS
THE NEW STUDENT. SO IT'S JUST
THAT ALL CAMPUSES HAVE BEEN
RECEIVING A LITTLE BIT LESS
THAN WHAT THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
GET. OKAY BUT IF FOR. STUDENTS
WHO MAY BE ABLE TO SEE WHAT
CAMPUSES SIR. I GUESS WE ARE
DOING A BETTER JOB OF ENROLLING
P. AND IF THERE IF THERE ARE
OVER AND ROLLED. THERE'S
CAMPUSES THAT ARE EXPERIENCING
MORE OVER AND ALL I GUESS WE
WOULD WANT TO KNOW THAT TO. ALL
RIGHT YEAH I CAN GET TO THE
RECENT A ROMAN NUMBERS BY
CAMPUS TO SEE WHERE WHERE
THERE'S BEEN BOTH OVER IN ROME
IT WHERE YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE
NOT GETTING FUNDED FOR THAT AND
THE- WHERE THAT. ALLOCATED TO
ACTUAL ENROLLED FUNDED STUDENTS
SAY GUESSES THAT ACCENTS I
THINK SENSE KNOCKER THANK YOU
SIR. THANK YOU I THINK JUST TO
PUT IN PERSPECTIVE I KNOW
YOU'RE ON THIS ISSUE TO MISTER
GALLAGHER IT DOES SAY WERE OVER
I KNOW THAT YOU SEE CLAIMS WERE
OVER AND ROLLED SEVEN BUT I
WOULD SAY WERE DRAMATIC. UNDER
AND WILL FORGET GRADS GET THE
CHART ON PAGE FOUR IN OUR
AGENDA I THINK THIS IS THE MOST
ELIMINATING IS THAT IF YOU LOOK.
IF YOU LOOK AT. THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WE'VE
INCREASED BY 10% IN THE LAST
DECADE ROUGHLY AND FOR NON
RESIDENTS WE'VE INCREASED BY
210082% SO. CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
ARE TAKING NOTICE OF THIS AND
NOW MISTER MARTZ REACHES BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS AS WELL SO
THE NOTION THAT WERE ROLLED
THAT I DON'T. BUY THAT THE-
SAYS CALIFORNIANS. FOR TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED AND THREE SINCE
THE LAST I THINK SIX YEARS ON
AVERAGE AND YOU SEE GROW BY A
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN THAT SO
THANK YOU TO THE USE BEAR STILL
NOT. MEETING THE NEEDS.
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES BUT MIGHT MIGHT TWO
QUESTIONS ARE- ONE I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE POSITIVE
NEWS THAT. THAT UC. BERKELEY
AND DAVIS AND I RECENTLY MET
WITH UCLA TALKING ABOUT THIS IS.
AS FAR AS- PASSAGE HE ON THEIR
CAMPUSES THERE'S NOT ALWAYS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GROW RIGHT THERE
BUT THERE ARE OFF CAMPUS ALL
THESE I KNOW AT UC BERKELEY
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT TAKING
OVER MIL. PRIVATE SCHOOL-
FORMALLY AT ALL WOMEN'S
COLLEGES HAVING. SOME STRUGGLES
WITH ENROLLMENT AND
SUSTAINABILITY AND SO BERKELEY
MAKE TAKE OVER THAT CAMPUS WITH
THINGS A FABULOUS IDEA I KNOW
THEY HAVE SOME. OF THE LAND OF.
A I THINK ON MY- OLD I KNOW
HERE AT UC DAVIS. WE HAVE THIS
AGGIE SQUARE CAMPUS AT OUR MED
CENTER HERE IN. IN THE
OUTSKIRTS OF SACRAMENTO. WE ARE
HAVE THE MED SCHOOL NURSING
SCHOOL THERE POTENTIALLY BRING
OUT PROGRAMS THERE AND I KNOW
THAT THE UCLA CHANCER WE MET ON
FRIDAY TALKING ABOUT HIS IDEAS
FOR THE I JUST THINK THAT'S-
WHAT WE BELIEVE THE- KING OUT
IN SOME. THIS CAN I THINK WE
WOULD. PRE WAR AND FOCUS ON HOW
WE INVEST IN THAT WE GET A
COUPLE YEARS AGO. AGGIE SQUARE
BUT I THINK THAT POTENTIAL IS
THE FUTURE BECAUSE WE NEED TO
EXPAND. AND I KNOW THE GET
SANTA
THINKING WITH THESE OFF CAMPUS
CENTERS RATHER PLACE TO ENROLL
STUDENTS YEAH WELL I THINK THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT YOU'VE BEEN
HAVING THAT CHANCELLORS HAVE
BEEN ENGAGING IN THAT MORE THEY
WORK START TO GET SOME
ENROLLMENT PLAN. THINGS LOOK
LIKE OVER THE YEARS IN ADDITION
THAT- THEY ARE LOOKING AT OTHER
STRATEGIES TO PARTNER WITH A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND- PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS LIKE THE MILLS
EXAMPLE THAT YOU IDENTIFIED
THAT MIGHT. HAVE EXISTING
CAPITAL WHERE THERE MAY BE
OPPORTUNITIES TO THOSE SO I
THINK THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
WORK THAT IS- ON GOING IN THE
NEXT- FEW MONTHS TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT THOSE OPPORTUNITIES ARE.
OKAY SITES THAT CAMPUS OF OTHER
EXAMPLES WERE YOU LOOKING AT
YOU SEE WHY WELL I MEAN EVEN AT
SANTA CRUZ THEY HAD A FIGHT A
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS A
PLACE WHERE THERE MAY BE SOME
OPPORTUNITIES TO PARTNER- THE-
I KNOW THE IRVINE CAMPUS WHEN
THEY HAD SOME OVER ENROLLMENT I
BELIEVE THEY PARTNERED WITH
THEIR LOCAL BECAUSE THIS. ADD-IT THERE GET THAT WRONG
COLLEGES BUT IT ANTI A PROGRAM
WHERE THEY WERE. BUT IS A- SO.
NUMBER PULLS BUT CAMPUSES ARE
LOOKING AT WHAT IS POSSIBLE
WITH WITH EXISTING- EDUCATIONAL
ENTITIES THAT ARE ARE NEARBY OR
AROUND THE CAMPUS OKAY WHAT
COULD THE STATE DUE TO HELP IN
THIS IN THIS. LIKE MAYBE WE
COULD SEE THE OPPORTUNITIES ARE
TO- TO SUPPORT THAT- AND THE
STUDENTS THAT ARE THERE I MEAN.
YOU KNOW WE'RE LOOKING AT
STRATEGIES ON OUR CAMPUSES TO
TRY TO GET STUDENTS THROUGH
TIMELY MANNER AND PARTICULARLY
OUR OUR HEALTH FIRST CHEN AND
UNDER REPRESENTED WE SEE THAT
AS A- SIGNIFICANT OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE. SOME OF GROWTH AND
SUPPORT STUDENTS ON OUR
CAMPUSES AND THEN WE CAN LOOK
AT OTHER OPTIONS- THERE WE
THINK IT'S JUST AS IMPORTANT AS
THE ENROLLMENT IS ENSURING
STUDENTS LEAVE FOR THE DEGREE
AND- SO. I TIMELY MANNER. BOTH
IMPORT. MORE SHE WAS GET TO
THEM IN A BET SO IF YOU'RE A
LAWMAKER WITHOUT AT A CSU IN
YOUR DISTRICT YOU WOULD LIKE
NOTHING MORE TO DELIVER A NEW
CAMPUS TO YOUR DISTRICT BUT IS
THAT THE MOST IF NOT THE THING
TO DO CALIFORNIA I DON'T KNOW
AND I THAT WE GOT OUR- PLEASE
THIRTY. CAMPUS YOU SEE YES YOU.
AND SEE HOW WE CAN EXPAND THOSE
AND GROW OFF CAMPUS CENTERS I
THINK THAT THAT'S- MORE
SUSTAINABLE AND THOSE RESOURCES
FOR THAT SO. WHATEVER WE CAN DO
TO SUPPORT THAT. I'M I'M IN
FULL SUPPORT YEAH I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S IMPORTANT AND I
THINK AGAIN IT THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT EFFORTS TO GET
STUDENTS TO GRADUATE SOONER.
THAT TO WOULD GIVE. A POSITIVE
OUTCOME TO STUDENTS- AS WELL
AS- SOME OPPORTUNITIES TO
ENROLL MORE. AND THEN MY LAST
QUESTION IS ABOUT THE
GRADUATING SOONER- THAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE RIGHT ON SO FAR AS THE
THAT THEY NEED TO DO SO AND
THAT THAT. THAT AMOUNT OF
STUDENT DATA YOU GET FROM THAT
TO FIT YEAR SPEAKS FOR ITSELF.
NO THEY'RE NOT FACT WHY. THAT
THAT HAPPENS THEN. YOU'D HAVE
TO WORK MUCH THE WE'RE LOOKING
TO EXPAND FINANCIAL AID. READ
MISTER MEDINA TO MAKE SURE THE
STUDENTS CAN CAN FOCUS ON THEIR
ON THEIR STUDIES AND NOT HAVE
TO. WORK SO MUCH AND GO PART
TIME BUT ONE OF THAT THE-
PROMISING FOR THINGS WE'VE BEEN
DOING THIS SUMMER EXPANSION.
AND WE DID THAT A COUPLE YEARS
AGO OUR CHANGE THE CAL GRANT
POLICY SO. IS THAT IS THAT IS
THAT ENOUGH OR DO WE NEED.
THING ELSE TO FOCUS ON. SUMMER
BECAUSE THAT AREA YOU CAN PICK
UP THE- GRADUATE. THESE TO
EXPAND SUMMER SUPPORT- WE
RECEIVED THAT TOWARDS THE END
OF THE YEAR- AND CAMPUSES
QUICKLY WHAT WHAT WENT INTO
ACTION TO RIGHTS. OF PROVIDE
OUTREACH AND GET STUDENTS TO BE
ABLE TO BE INCLUDED- IN THOSE
PROGRAMS. THEIR EFFORTS ON
GOING TO EXPERIENCE SUMMER
STARTS SUMMER BRIDGE TRANSFER
EDGE THOSE. FOR TERM PROGRAMS
TO BE ABLE TO GET STUDENTS IN
SO SUPPORT FOR OUT. MISS THEM
AND THAT EFFORT. THE AND- IT IT
IS ONE OF THE AREAS FOR. DO
TRACK WE GET A FOR ALSO AT THE
SOFT LINING AID IS A COMPONENT
TO MAKE SUMMER POSSIBILITY OKAY
THANK YOU STRATEGY. THANK YOU
YOU KNOW I I'D LIKE TO. YEAH
STEP BACK I APPRECIATE ALL THE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE YOU
KNOW THE CREATE PARTNERSHIPS
AND- JUST TRYING TO YOU KNOW
TRYING TO INCREASE OUR OUR OUR
OUR- THANK YOU PROGRAMS MORE
EFFICIENT BYE BYE GRADUATING
PEOPLE ON TIME TO CREATE MORE
SPACE. YOU KNOW I AND I ALWAYS
BACK TO YOU KNOW MY POINT OF
REFERENCE A LOT OF TIMES WHEN
I'M TALKING TO MY CONSTITUENTS
YOU KNOW. THEY THEY THEY TALK
ABOUT HOW YOU KNOW IN THE
SIXTIES AND THE SEVENTIES THEY
ONLY PAID YOU KNOW A COUPLE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A TICKET CALL
OR- NO. THE AM THEY WOULD BE A
LABOR- AND THEN REALLY START
STUDYING- IN APPLYING
THEMSELVES UNIT BUT THE SOMEHOW
THEY'RE ABLE TO GET INTO THE-
TO THE UC'S- YOU KNOW WITH. A
GROUP TONIGHT I CONSIDER EVEN.
TO BERKELEY IN THE EIGHT SECOND.
I SAW UP A PART OF THAT. THAT
GENERATION WORRY WAS MUCH
EASIER FOR MEDIOCRE STUDENTS
LIKE MYSELF TO GET INTO
BERKELEY AT THE TIME. BT BUT
NOW IT'S LIKE YOU KNOW WHEN I
WHEN IT'S- THE- INCIDENT.
PLEASE OPEN IS JUST. MAKING
LIKE DIFFICULT A IS TO INTO TO
THE USE AND ESPECIALLY TO. NEAR
THE MOST MOST COMPETITIVE
CAMPUSES OF A BERKELEY UCLA AND
SAN DIEGO AND- IT ENDS SO WHEN
I WHEN I TRY TO LOOK BACK TO
CAPACITY QUESTIONS I THINK
ABOUT. YOU KNOW HOW THE INTO
THE STATE'S POP. A BILL OUR
STATE POPULATION WAS A TWENTY
TWO MAY. BACK IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY AND TODAY WE'RE
APPROACHING FORTY MILLION IT
DIDN'T DO YOU HAVE THE NUMBERS
IN TERMS OF THE USE ON RATHER
CAPACITY IN IN A VERSE TODAY.
AND IF NOT CAN I YES YOU CAN. I
WILL SAY I DO I HAVE IT. YOU
ABOUT WHAT NEED TO DO THEY GET
INTO COLLEGE AND MORE CHEN THAN
IT WAS ME WHEN I WAS A STUDENT
I WILL SAY ONE OF THE THINGS
AND AGAIN WHY THIS YOU SEE TO.
IS IMPORTANT IS. SING
OPPORTUNITIES ACROSS ALL OF OUR
CAMPUSES SO ENSURING THAT NINE
OF TEN STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO
GRADUATE NOT JUST AT BERKELEY
OR AT UCLA BUT IT EVEN AS AND
IRVINE AND SANTA CRUZ AND OTHER
PLACES. AND I THINK ARE ABLE TO
ACCEPT THE OPPORTUNITY. TO MAKE
STUDENTS MORE AWARE ABOUT WHAT
IS POSSIBLE ACROSS ALL OF THE-
UC CAMPUSES- THERE ARE
DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITIES THAT
THAT COME THEIR THEIR THEIR
EACH- AMAZING PLACE TO GO. AND
BEING ABLE TO ENSURE THAT THERE
IS LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GRADUATE
AND DO SO IN A TIMELY I IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. OF STATE
PARENTS STUDENTS. OKAY AND I
PRE. HELLO UNIVERSITY OF THIS
TRY TO RECREATE TO- THEY'VE
BECOME MORE EFFICIENT TO BE
ABLE TO SQUEEZE OUT MORE
OPPORTUNITIES- MINERAL LIMITED
SOURCES ON BUT IT. IN A MOVIE
IT HAS THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA EVER CONDUCTED LIKE
A- LIKE A LONG TERM ANALYSIS IN
TERMS OF LIKE YOU KNOW HOW HOW
MUCH. THE INVESTMENTS WERE MADE.
A SAY IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
IN TERMS OF THE OVERALL CAMPUS
CAPACITIES AND WHETHER THAT AS
MATCH THE DOUBLING OVER STATE'S
POPULATION AND WHAT IT WILL
TAKE IN TERMS OF THAT THE COST
TO BE ABLE TO A COMEDY THAT
DOUBLING OF THE STATE POP HAS
THE CALIFORNIA STEP BACK IN.
TELL ALL RIGHT SO KIND OF THOSE
KIND OF A QUOTE YOU ARE PRIOR
THE STUDIES BATH THE LOOK AT
THOSE AND ROOM FOR I'VE- I
DON'T KNOW OFF THE TOP. THAT'S
FOR SIMPLE MINDS LIKE MYSELF I
MEAN IT'S EASY TO LOOK AT HOW
THE STATE. STE POPULATION
DOUBLED IN THE LAST. FORTY
YEARS AND- AND IN- HOW I HOW
MUCH IT HAS THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA'S CAPACITY INCREASED
AND- AND TO WHAT EXTENT IT IS
THAT A REFLECTION OF WHY IT'S
SO DID. TO GET INTO THE- YEAH
YEAH YEAH- UP YOU KNOW. ALONG
THE LINES OF HOW DIFFICULT IT
IS TO GET INTO- ESPECIALLY ARE-
MOST- IT COMPETITIVE CAMPUSES
IS COURSE THE ISSUE OF THE
ADVANCE VERSUS NON RESIDENTS.
WHEN C. V. THE CAPS THAT- THAT
WERE ADOPTED FOR THE NON
RESIDENT AND RALPH AND BERKELEY
25% IT'S STILL A 23% SAN DIEGO
2% I MEAN BASICALLY. I'M OUT OF.
ROGER IT SPOT ARE. IN TWO NINE
CAL KIDS AND SO YOU KNOW A WENT
WHEN I WHEN I CAN'T. YOU KNOW
TALK ABOUT BUILDING NEW
CAMPUSES OR WE ARE DRAMATICALLY
EXPANDING BERKELEY AND UCLA
THEN THAT'S WHERE I LOOK TO
NEXT YOU KNOW HOW DO WE MAKE IT
EASIER FOR OUR KIDS TO BE ABLE
TO GO TO BERKELEY SALE. ISN'T
THAT THAT THAT'S A 25% OF YOU
KNOW. REDUCTION IN
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIA
KIDS RIGHT NOW I UNDERSTAND TO.
THAT YOU KNOW WE IT IS WE I
JUST HAD A CONVERSATION WITH
WITH THAT MS VERDON IN
YESTERDAY YOU KNOW IT'S A
REFLECTION OF THE DRAMATIC
DECLINE IN THE STATE FUNDING
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF POIGNANT
CAMPS THE MAKE UP. WITH ALL THE
COMING. DAYS STUDENTS. ARE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT. HOW TO GET THE
UNIVERSITY COUNTY CALIFORNIA
BACK TO WHERE WE WERE JUST AS
RECENTLY AS TEN YEARS AGO WHEN
THE WHEN THE STATE AND WRONG
LESSON PERCENT YEAH. AND IT I
MEAN IT'S-IN NEW ONE HANDED
WELL I MEAN THEY CAN'T COMING
MORE RELIANT ANOTHER FUNDS
SOURCES AND NON RESIDENT
TUITION IS A CRITICAL COMPONENT
OF IT I'M- SOME OF THE DECLINE
THINGS THAT WERE STILL AND
FIRST YEAR. TURNING TO ME. FOR
THAT. WE WANT TO STEM. AND WHEN
WE START TO LOOK AT A STUDENT'S
ABILITY TO GET IN THE COURSES
THAT THEY WANT TO THE MAJORS
THAT THEY WILL INTERESTED IN
COMING BACK THE UNIVERSE. AFTER
KNOWING WHAT THEY KNOW THOSE
RATES ARE DECLINING SO I WORRY
ABOUT- NOT JUST ACCESS BUT THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND THE
EXPERIENCES THAT STUDENTS ARE
HAVING ON THE CAMPUS AND I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THOSE FIGURES
SHOW AND I KNOW THAT THE-
VISIT. OUR LYING ON THOSE
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THE
STUDENTS THAT ARE THERE OKAY-
AND- I MEAN I KNOW THAT- AND
THEN MS VERDON HAS A TOUGH JOB
IN A SHE'S ALWAYS COMING BACK
LIKE ASKING. FOR MORE MONEY YOU
KNOW EVEN AS A GOVERNOR
PROPOSING A 5% INCREASE AND-
AND I APPRECIATE THAT I. THEY
ARE ALL PROUD OF BEING HOME TO
THE INNER TO CALIFORNIA AND YET
YOU KNOW I WAS TELLING HER NEED
YESTERDAY. FOR ME IT EXCITED
YOU TEACH YOU NEVER CALIFORNIA.
HE OR THESE GRASS ON THE BOARD
ON. STUDENT I WANTED TO. IN A
REITERATE WHAT THAT'S HIGH. THE
ON ON ON PAGE FOUR OF OUR OF
OUR AGENDA- THE CHART AT THE
VERY BOTTOM THERE MEANWHILE
WHILE YOU TALK ABOUT HOW YOU
KNOW YOU WE GO CALVET HAS WE
HAVE A SIX DID IN IT BASING THE
UNDERGRADUATE. THE CALIFORNIA.
UNDER THE PRESSURE. I MEAN WE
SEE WHERE YOU YOU KNOW WHO WAS
WHERE THE DRAMATIC DIFFERENCE
IT IS I MEAN 10% INCREASE IN
RESIDENT ROMAN IN LAST TEN U.
VERSE IS A 21002% INCREASE IN
NON RESIDENT ROMAN MINUTES. HOW
AYE AYE GO TO SIT IN CHAMPION
MORE FUNDING FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA WHEN SUCH A
START. AND DRAMATIC DIFFERENCE
AND YOU KNOW THE OPPORTUNITIES
ARE GOING TO THE NON RESIDENT
NON CALIFORNIA NON CONSTITUENT
KIDS. AND THAT'S WHAT MAKES YOU
KNOW SO DIFFICULT FOR ME TO YOU
BUT IT DID TO DO CHMPION- MORE
FUNDING FOR THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA WHEN THAT WORD IS
OUT THAT YOU KNOW IT'S JUST
IT'S JUST GOING TO BENEFIT THE
IS IT A STATE IS NOT AN ART. WE
SAW. THOSE TWO. ARE BRING IT
WITH CUT BACK BUT OF NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS WITHOUT
SUPPORT TO BE ABLE TO- TO
REPLICATE WHAT THEY'RE PROVIDE
THING IT MEANS THAT ALL THE
STUDENTS THE CAMPUS AND THE PAT.
VIRGINITY AND WHAT THEY DO
TODAY. I MEAN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE PERCENTAGES AND IT'S
RIGHT IT'S FROM THE NUMBERS
THAT YOU'VE GOT HERE THIRTY
THOUSAND MORE ON RESIDENTS OVER
THAT PERIOD. TEAM AND MORE IN
STATE STUDENTS. BUT THERE THERE
HAVE BEEN- CHANGES IN THE
GROWTH- AND THOSE RESOURCES ARE
GOING INTO TO SUPPORTING THE
STUDENTS BETTER THAT SO I WORRY
ABOUT ACCESS BUT AGAIN I A LOT
ABOUT. IT'S A- TO GET STUDENTS.
TO THE GRASS IN THE PARK I GET
REALLY REALLY. IMPROVEMENTS AND
GRADUATION RATES WE ARE TRYING
TO FOCUS ON ELIMINATING THE
GRADUATION CAP SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO DO AND
IF WE'RE ABLE TO DO THAT AND
INCREASE THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OUR PAL OUR FIRST JAN. UNDER IT
WILL ONLY. THE DEGREE GO ON THE
SCHOOL AND EVENTUALLY GET INTO
THE PROFESSORIAL WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BETTER REFLECT
THE STATE AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WAS REALLY CRITICAL AS
WELL WELL I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE- CONCERN. I
CA EXPERIENCE YOU KNOW. I
KNOW THIS REPEAT I'LL BE HERE
FROM A GOOD NUMBER OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT HOW CROWDED CAMP ARE. AND
HOW WE HAVE A REAL ISSUE. I
FEEL LIKE FIRST. AT LEAST THE
KIDS THERE THAT A CONTEST FOR
TODAY THEY HAVE A CHANCE TO
ATTEND THERE ARE SO MANY KIDS
OUT THERE THAT DON'T EVEN HAVE
A CHANCE TO ATTEND THE SCHOOL.%
AND THAT'S WRONG. LAST YOU KNOW
I KNOW. CHARGING AN INSURER
CARD. THE HAVE CALLED FOR AND
WAS A STUDY IN TERMS OF HOW
MUCH IT WOULD COST TO BASICALLY
BITE DOWN THE YOU KNOW TO
REPLACE THE REVENUES THAT
YOU'RE GETTING THE NOT IS
NERVOUS. WHEN A CONTINUE TO
SIGN YOU KNOW IF YOU WANT US TO
CHAMPION MORE FUNDING FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IT'S-
BENEFIT CAL KIDS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SO MY
MARYLAND. THANK YOU AND YOU
KNOW THIS IS- WE'VE WE'VE KIND
OF BATTLES- AND- HAD THIS
REALLY HEALTHY I THINK
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS- FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND I THINK
THAT YOU KNOW OF MY WAYS HAVING
WERE. EMPHASIS ALL IS THAT NOT
CLEAR. IDEA JUST EDUCATION THE
LOAN IS WHAT HELPS- C. O. S. A
SUCCESSFUL I THINK OF THE FACT
THAT THEY'RE WORRIED YOU KNOW
TWO THREE. IN THE CAMPUS IS IF
THERE WASN'T I MEAN MENTAL
HEALTH IS AND IT'S NOT LITTLE
THAT IS HUGE HUGE HUGE HUGE ARE
FOR STUDENTS AND SECURITY ANY I
DON'T THOSE THINGS ARE. AND THE
YEAH- THAT WE WILL TRADE UP
SOME OF THESE ELEMENTS THAT ARE
NEEDED- FOR STUDENTS TO
ACCESSIBLE AT WHY IT PULLED AT
THE UNIVERSITY FOR MORE
PATIENCE. I DON'T FAIR I WISH
THAT THAT THE MATTER NUMBER BUT
IT IT I SEE HELLO STUDENTS BACK
BUT NO NOT NUMBER IS AND I
DON'T WANT IT TO BE LOTS EIGHT
IS ALL.FOR TO. IF CONVERSATION
WE WANT MORE STUDENTS I MEAN I
WISH AT YOU WE WOULD SEE THE
IMPACT IMPACTS AND THAT YOU SEE
MORE SAID BUT WE DON'T THE
TRUTH IS THAT CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS AND PARENTS AND
TAXPAYERS TALKING TWO. OF ALL
THE CAMPUS. WHICH IS A THINK IT.
THAT WE HAVE. BECAUSE THE IS IT
HAPPENED SEE FOR ELEVEN YEARS I
DON'T THINK EVERYONE SHOULD GO
TO UCLA OR BERKLEY I THERE ARE
BETTER MEET TO DO THAT
UNIVERSITIES AND I DO MY BY I'M
GOING TELL YOU GO TO YOU SEE
AND A BARBARA IS THERE'S
RESEARCH PROPERTY. NEXT BEING
ON. MAKES THE MOST SENSE IS
UNIQUE IS THE- IF YOU'RE URBAN
CAMP INTO A THAT IT'S THAT IT'S
AN IMPORTANT. BUT I ALSO FEEL
LIKE PART OF OUR JOB IS TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE- ENCOURAGE.
OUR OUR CONSTITUENTS TO THINK
OF THE UC AS A WHOLE THIS IS IT
I MEAN IT ALWAYS COMES DOWN TO
UCLA AND BERKELEY IS REALLY
WHAT WERE HEARING THE MOST TO
US AND I DON'T KNOW I MEAN YES%
I LOVE THE IDEAS THAT FOUND
THOSE CAN'T BE MY PROPER UP BUT
IN THE END IT THAT'S THAT. NOT
GET INTO THE- SO I THINK THAT
KNOWLEDGE THAT. THE MORE HEALTH
STUDENT THERE'S NO DOUBT IN MY
MIND BUT I ALSO THAT IT'S OF
DEL BALANCE ON THE YOU KNOW
IT'S JUST IN THE SENSE THAT UP
SOME SUCCESSFULLY PATRICK FARES
OR IF IT GEN- IS THERE SO YOU I
A PRE RECEIPT FOR IT TO COME
MAYBE ON HOW TO ADDRESS THAT.
QUICK QUESTION. GOING BACK TO
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER MERCER JEEZ
QUESTION DOES THE- UNIVERSITY
HAVE ENROLLMENT TARGETS IN MIND
TEN YEARS FROM NOW OR OR TWENTY
YEARS FROM NOW WHERE THEY WHERE
THEY EXPECT TO BE. NO NOT THAT
FAR OUT WE BUSTED INFORMATION
FROM THE CAMPUSES TO LOOK OVER
THE NEXT FOUR YEAR PERIOD WE'RE
IN THE PROCESS OF COLLECTING
INFORMATION. IN ADDITION TO THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT ENDED UP
HAVING WITH SOME OF THE
CHANCELLOR'S AND THEY HAD WITH
OTHER CHANCELLORS TO ABOUT A TO
DAYS IN THE PROPER OF. THAT IS
THAT YOUR POINT. SURPRISE THAT
ARE AT THIS INFLECTION POINT IN
THE STATE WE HAVEN'T BUILT ANY-
ADDITIONAL CAMPUS THIS WE
OBVIOUSLY DURING THE TIME THE
NUMBER OF US. WERE AT COLLEGE
YOU SEE WAS GOING THROUGH A
GROWTH SPURT YOU SEE WAS
GROWING SO- OF COURSE AS THE
POPULATION WAS GROWING THE
STEVE KEEPING PACE. I THINK
QUESTION IS DIVERSITY TO
RECEIVE. HAD ABILITY TO CAN
TEAM TO KEEP PACE IT SEEMS LIKE.
THINGS HAVE SORT OF FALLEN
BEHIND- IN IN THIS IS NOT JUST
A YOU SEE IT'S ALSO WITH OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM MUCH OF
OUR STATE INFRASTRUCTURE WE
SORT OF HAVE NEGLECTED OVER THE
LAST COUPLE DECADES SO WOULD
YOU SEE NOT. ALONE IN THAT AT
ALL IF YOU WE- THE DOOR. THE
EIGHT YEARS I'VE BEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE BEEN SORT
PLAYING CATCH UP FOR A DECADES
OF NEGLECT IN TERMS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE- ON. I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR. YOU
SEE TO IDENTIFY WHAT TYPE OF A
IN ROLE MEANT- TARGETS THEY CAN
HIT IT EACH OF THE CAMPUS'S IT
IS EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT- I.
YOU KNOW GO GO BACK TO MY FROM
SANTA BARBARA'S COMMENTS I
THINK YOU KNOW SHE SHE IS
RIGHT- THAT WE DO HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO- ADVOCATE FOR THE
OTHER SEVEN EPISODES. I THINK I
THINK THE GOOD THE GOOD NEWS
AND THE BAD NEWS IS I THINK THE
SECRETS OUT I THINK THAT I
THINK ALL SEVEN OF THOSE
CAMPUSES ARE IN HIGH. I MEAN DO
I'M BERKELEY IN USED. THERE IS
A HUGE AMOUNT OF INTEREST AND
ALL SEVEN OF THOSE CAMPUSES- I
THINK THAT'S A GREAT I THINK
IT'S GREAT FOR OR FOR THE STATE
OF. IT'S CLEAR THERE'S STILL
MORE TO MAKE A UC DEGREE
REGARDLESS OF CAMPUS ON THERE
THE- SPOT AT ANY IS REGARDLESS
OF WHAT YOUR IN APP BERKELEY
WHERE I YOU'RE A BURST. SO I
THAT IS THE VERY. I'M I DO
THINK YOU KNOW I'D BELIEVE THAT
YOU CAMPUSES HAVE BECOME
ADDICTED TO OUT OF STATE
ENROLLMENT. I DON'T THINK IT
CONTINUES TO BE A FAIR.
STATEMENT THAT OUT OF STATE IN
ROMAN INCREASES. BECAUSE OF A
LACK OF IN STATE SUPPORT IN
FACT SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH WAS- STARTING
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN OR THE END
OF TWENTY TWELVE. EVERY SINGLE
YOU SEE HAS RECEIVED AN
INCREASE IN INCREASE IN SUPPORT.
YET IF YOU LOOK AT THAT CHART
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN EVERY SINGLE
YEAR WHILE THE STATE INCREASED
THEIR SUPPORT TO THE UNIVERSITY
WHAT HAPPENED. WELL FOR NOT
CURSE IN STATE AROMA WAS FLAT.
INTEL MYSELF AND MR MCCARTY
ACTUALLY NEGOTIATED WITH THE
UNIVERSITY TO GET IN STATE
ENROLLMENT UP THE WAS NOT
BECAUSE UNIVERSE DECIDED TO
THAT IT WAS SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SPECIFICALLY THE
SHADE IN THE BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS BUT- THE CHANCES
ARE VERY WILLING TO CONTINUE TO
GROW. OUT OF STATE MOMENT. SO I
THINK YOU SEE NEEDS TO BREAK
THE ADDICTION OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS. OR THEY NEED TO PAY
THE STATE BACK FOR ALL ITS
BUILDINGS ALL ITS LAND. ALL THE
INVESTMENTS STATE. BECAUSE TO
ME IF THEY'RE NOT PREPARED TO
BREAK THAT ADDICTION TO OUT OF
STATE STUDENTS THERE ARE THERE
HAS TO BE A CHANGE IN THE
RELATIONSHIP. SO TO ME THIS
YEAR I I'VE ALWAYS I THINK YOU
YOU SEE IS ONE OF THE BEST
THINGS THE STATE HAS EVER DONE
AND I CONTINUE TO STAMP. ONE OF
THE REASONS WE HAVE THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IS PROBABLY
MAYBE EVEN THE NUMBER ONE
REASON WE HAVE THE FIFTH
LARGEST CONTINENT. IN THIS
WORLD. IT'S A REASON THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO MAINTAIN TALENT
GROW OUR OWN TALENT INNOVATE-
SO MUCH OF. WHAT HAS. BEEN
INNOVATIVE IN THE STATE HAS
COME OUT OF A UC THIS. I THINK
IT'S ABSOLUTE CREDIBLE BUT- I
MEAN I THINK THAT TWO. TWO
THINGS IS. WE NEED TO ENSURE.
THAT YOU SEE IS PREPARED AND
PLANNING. TO MEET. D. DEMANDS
OF THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA IN
TERMS OF THE DEMANDS FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION AND FRANKLY DEMANDS
FOR A VERY VERY EDUCATED
WORKFORCE WE LIVE IN A VERY
EXPENSIVE STATE. WE COMPETE YOU
KNOW GOV GOVERNOR BROWN TALKED
ABOUT A LOT LIKE WE DON'T
COMPETE. ON PRICE. WE LOSE THAT
COMPETITION. WE COMPETE. BASED
ON GETTING THE SMARTEST PEOPLE
IN THE BRIGHTEST PEOPLE FROM
AROUND THE WORLD TO COME TO
CALIFORNIA THAT'S THAT'S A HUGE
CHUNK OF OUR ECONOMY THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE REAL PIECE OF OUR
COUNTRY THAT YOU SEE IS THE
PART OF THE DIFFUSE CARE
CONTINUE TO. EDUCATE IN KEEPING
MAINTAIN THAT EDUCATION
CALIFORNIA WILL BE ABLE TO
CONTEND IN OF IT. AND I THINK
ALSO IF IT'S- IF IT IS HE
DOESN'T HAVE ROOM FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH THOSE
CALIFORNIA'S SOMEWHERE ELSE TO
GOING TO GO TO TEXAS THEY'RE
GONNA GO TO MASSACHUSETTS
THEY'RE GOING TO GO TO IT
ANNOYED GOING TO. NORTH
CAROLINA. CREATE GEN THEN TACK
IN FLORIDA NOT IN SOUTH SAN
FRANCISCO I THINK THAT'S THAT
THAT TO US I THINK IS EVEN
THOUGH THE LARGER CONCERN- AND
I IF THE UNIVERSITY- DOESN'T
OUT IT UP AGAIN WHERE WHERE I
THINK WE ARE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
WORK- WITH THE UNIVERSITY ON
DEVELOPING A LONG. TERM THEY
TOOK ALL THE BACK THERE WE HAVE
GOTTEN HAS- TO ME NOT
DEMONSTRATE THAT THE UNIVERSITY
SERIOUS ABOUT BREAKING THE
CYCLE AND BREAKING THEIR
ADDICTION- BUT I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE IS VERY INTERESTED
IN THAT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE VERY INTERESTED.
BECAUSE THEY THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE PAYING TAXES KIDS CAN'T
GET IN. TO DO YEAR END INTO THE
UNIVERSITY. SO TO ME- YOU KNOW
IT'S EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT-
THAT THIS SORT OF SORT OF
ENROLLMENT LOOK BE DONE AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE BUT ALSO. IT'S.
YOU'RE HAVING ALSO QUESTION
ABOUT SAY THAT JUST TO STEVEN
THAT THE EIGHTEEN THOUSAND OR
IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
TWENTY EIGHT- THE TWO THOUSAND.
YOU KNOW OUT OF STATE STUDENTS
THOUGH THOSE ARE THOSE ARE
THOSE COULD BE CALIFORNIA'S
LOTS AND AGAIN. WHAT NO NO ONE
POINT OUT IS THE HIGHEST AMOUNT
OF OUT OF STATE A ROLE THAT IS
NOT A U. SEAMERS AT. WHERE WORK
WITH THANK YOU SEE ELECT THAT
UC SAN DIEGO. SO THAT'S WHAT
PEOPLE ARE PISSED OFF. IT'S B.
AS YOU KNOW- IN THIS IS A JOKE
IT'S YOU KNOW YOU'RE BETTER OFF
MOVING TO NEW YORK. WHEN YOU'RE
IN HIGH SCHOOL BEEN TRYING TO
GRADUATE FROM CALIFORNIA TO GET
INTO BERKELEY. IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT YOU WOULD WANT
US TO TELL OUR CONSTITUENTS
MOVE OUT OF STATE. SO YOU CAN
GO TO UC BERKELEY. WITHOUT A
STATE SO YOU CAN GET INTO UCLA.
THAT THAT SOUNDS. LIKE A VERY
POOR WAY TO DO IN ADMISSIONS
PROCESS FOR IN IN STATE. YOU
NEVER. BUT THAT'S SORT OF WHERE
WE ARE AT AT THIS STAGE IT IS
SOMETHING THAT TO ME IS. NOT
ALL. IT'S NOTHING THAT I CAN
TELL MY CONSTITUENTS I CAN'T
GIVE THEM THE ADVICE TO MOVE
OUT OF STATE TO GO TO THE
COLLEGE THAT THEY'D LIKE TO.
BUT THAT TOWARDS CHOICE WOULD
YOU STARTED. LEAVE MANY OF US.
SO AGAIN I THINK IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO. HIGHLIGHT HOW
MUCH EACH OF THE CAMPUS'S CAN
GROW. WHAT THE CAPACITY IS YOU
KNOW NOT JUST A FOR YEARS BUT
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE TALKING
TEN TWENTY YEARS. AND ALSO. HOW
DO WE- HOW DO WE. ABLE TO HAVE-
ADMIT THE GROWTH IN ROLE THE
GROWTH IN IN STATE CALIFORNIA'S
CUSTOMS. YEAH I MEAN I THINK A
LONGER TERM FUNDING PLAN IS A
GOOD IDEA THE PRE FUNDING THAT
WE HAD IN THE LAST PERIOD IS IT
IS VERY HELPFUL- CAMPUSES KEEP
AND TO PATE WHAT THEY ARE GOING
TO HAVE TERMS OF SLOTS AND- UP
ACCORDINGLY IT TOOK OVER A
PERIOD THAT IN TALKING ABOUT.
THE CITY OF FORMULA HAS AND DID
THE TARGET. WHAT WE WERE
GETTING IN TERMS AT STATE. FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS- SO IT
ISN'T AS THOUGH OVER THAT
PERIOD WE DIDN'T ENROLL AS MANY
AS SLOTS AS WE WERE GETTING
PAID FOR BEING ABLE TO THINK
AHEAD ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS-
AND BEING ABLE TO PLAN TOGETHER
AND KNOW THAT THE- RESOURCE
WELL. WILL HELP THE CAN'T. WITH
WITH MEETING DRUNK WHICH WHICH
WHICH HAS BEEN GREAT WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
THE UNIVERSITY- YOU KNOW IT
HERE TO THE AGREEMENT THE BUT
LET'S JUST BE CLEAR THAT
SOMETHING THAT WAS PASSED ON TO
THE UNIVERSE CAME TO US AND
SAID HEY WE HAVE THIS GREAT
PLAN. FOR IN STATE AND WOMEN
AND WE WANT TO INCREASE NUMBER
CALIFORNIANS. NOBODY CAN TO
TALK ABOUT. ALL THE WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT IS HOW CAN WE
INCREASE MORE OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS BECAUSE WE LOVE THE
MONEY. IN FACT IT WAS
COMMITTEE- THAT WE DISCOVERED
THAT. YOU SEE WAS NOT ONLY
ADMITTING HE OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS FOR THE MONEY THEY IN
FACT WERE GIVING SOME OF THEM
SCHOLARSHIPS THESE WERE NOT
ATHLETES WERE TALKING ABOUT.
THEY WERE GIVING. PRESSURES
FINANCIALLY DOLLARS TO OUT OF
STATE STUDENTS. SO THE YOU KNOW
YOU SEE WAS BECOMING THE
UNIVERSITY OF NON CALIFORNIANS
THAT THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA.
BUT IT BECAUSE WE TOOK ACTION
AND WE FORCED YOU SEE BACK TO
ITS MISSION. TO ADMIT
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS THAT A
START DOING THAT. SO AGAIN YOU
KNOW WE WE'VE THIS COMMITTEE'S
BEEN ASKING FOR A ROMAN PLAN I
THINK I DON'T KNOW FOR HOW MANY
YEARS NOW. IT'S BEEN A WHILE.
AND WE ASKING. FOR A PLAN. TO
IN ROLE MORE CALIFORNIA'S TENS
AND WE'VE BEEN ASKING. FOR HOW
MUCH IS GOING TO COST. OUT WE
GOT A PLAN IN TERMS OF INSTEAD
OF BUT THAT TO ME IS NOT
COMPLETELY WE STICK THINK AT
LEAST AS A STARTING POINT. FOR
DISCUSSION GRAVERT PLEASE BY
THE- AGAIN. YOU KNOW THE
UNIVERSITY NEEDS TO GO BACK ANDDUST OFF. IT'S SORT OF FOUNDING
DOCUMENTS AND LOOK BACK AT ITS
MISSION. IN THE MISSION IS TO
FOR THE MISSION WAS TO BE-
THERE'S A LAND GRANT UNIVERSITY
TO DO AMAZING RESEARCH IN AND-
HAS BEEN. CONTINUOUS AND IS TO
EDUCATE. THE GREAT MINDS OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT WAS IT M. IN
MOST OF THIS YEAR PROBABLY MOST
OF US UP HERE I MEAN I'M JUST
LOOKING AT ALL OF US UP HERE
HOW MANY DOES HAVE YOU SEE
DEGREES SURE MANY PEOPLE. YES
ALL. YOU DON'T CAN ANYONE PATH
THIS THIS WILL BE A DIFFERENT
GROUP OF PEOPLE THERE AND WHAT
HE COULD DO WHEN YOU GO TO
OTHER STATES. WHEN YOU GO TO
OTHER LEAD AS THEY DON'T. THEY
DON'T HAVE THE SAME KIND OPTION
AND WHAT'S MADE OUR STATE. RATE
THIS MADE OUR STATE DIFFERENT.
BUT WE ABSOLUTELY THIS IS THIS
IS EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WHAT YOU SEE DOES HAS A
HUGE OPPORTUNITY TO SHAPE THE
FUTURE OF OUR STATE THAT'S WHY
WE'RE HERE BECAUSE IT'S SO
IMPORTANT. POURTANT YOUR WE
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THIS WOULD
YOU SEE DOES SHAPES THE FUTURE
OF OUR STATE AND THAT PEOPLE
CARA. SO MUCH. IT SHAPES
WHETHER PEOPLE CAN STAY IN THE
STATE. THE CHIP BUT PEOPLE COME
WORK IN THE STATE. IS SHAPES
KIND OF INDUSTRY BE IN THIS
STATE. AND THAT'S WHAT'S AT
STAKE. IN AND THAT'S WHAT
LEGISLATURE'S FIGHTING FOR OUR
STATE BAR CONSTITUENTS FOR OUR
RESIDENTS FOR FORTY MILLION
RESIDENTS BECAUSE WE- TO ENSURE
THAT YOU SEE DOES NOT FORGET
ABOUT THEM I KNOW THERE ARE
STUDENTS IN OTHER COUNTRIES
THERE'S TEN FORTY NINE OTHER
STATES WHO WOULD LIKE I'M HERE.
THEN WE WELCOME THEM TO COME.
BUT THEY DON'T ALL GET TO COME
TO UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S NOT WHERE THE SYSTEM WAS
SET UP. CELL AND THEN THIS
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A DEPARTURE ON
THE MISSION AND WE WANT TO
ACCOMPLISH WITH THE UNIVERSITY
THE UNIVERSITY NEEDS TO TAKE A
HARD. LOOK IN THE MIRROR. BREAK
ITS ADDICTION TO OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS. AND REMIND ITSELF.
WHAT IT'S HERE TO DO. SO THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU- I CONCUR
WITH 99% OF WHAT YOU JUST SAID
I DON'T WANNA GET. YES OKAY
BACK WHEN WE DID SERVICE YEARS
ON THIS COMMITTEE BEFORE I'M
YOU YOU- WENT ON THIS FOR THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR YOU SEE HERE THAT
YOU KNOW. WE'RE TING AND I WERE
WERE BANG ON TWO THREE FOUR
YEARS AGO AND- NOW THE PRO TEM
OF THE SENATE POSTED IN THE
BUDGET LAST YEAR BY POP. ALL
ACROSS LET. IS SPOKE ON ISSUE I
DO WANT TO FOCUS ON A LITTLE
POSITIVE THING SO WE DO KNOW
THAT. BECAUSE OF THAT. IT'S NOT
NOT CAP I CALLED A FORMULA AND
AS MISTER MARTZ WHICH IS SAD.
DEPENDS ON WHAT CáC. ARE BUT%
USED HYDRO THE- EVERY NON
RESIDENT YOU GET FOUR MORE
CALIFORNIANS AND SO. THAT IF
NOTHING ELSE CHANGES IN THE
NEXT FIVE OR TEN YEARS YOU
WON'T SEE THESE NUMBERS. SEC
DEPRESSING BECAUSE THERE WE ARE
DEPRESSING AND I I'LL CONCUR
THAT YOU KNOW WE HAD TO DO THIS
TO KEEP THE LIGHTS ON DURING
THE RECESSION. AND IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT NINE. IS THAT A
CRAZY TIME IN THE REGION ST
PAUL'S THIS IS A THREE LIKE
IT'S ARE YOU BY THE UC STATE ON
MY STATEMENT BE. SOON FEE
MONEY. THAT CONRAD. STATE IN
NEW STATE MY AN YEAH TOWN AND
YOU GO EACH KILLING INCREASE
TUITION SO MUCH. AND SO WE DID
THIS FOR COUPLE YEARS A LITTLE
KEEP THE LIGHTS ON BUT AFTER WE
STABILIZED AND I'VE BEEN GIVING
MORE THE STATE BUDGET FOR THE
PAST FIVE SIX YEARS WE'VE
DOUBLED AGAIN NUMBER NINE RIGHT
THAT'S WHAT MAKES A MISTER MARK.
SCRATCHER HOW DO YOU CAN FOR
MORE. SEE MONEY SAYS OKAY. BEEN
GIVEN. WAY MORE MONEY A YEAR
AND ALLOW. SIX SEVEN YEARS WITH
A DOUBLE THE NUMBER. OF NON
RESIDENT. IS CUTTING INTO A
SPOTS AND SO JUST THAT'S- US
AND OUR CONSTITUENTS RIVER. I'M
I WILL SAY TO THAT IF WE HAD A
SUITCASE RIGHT HERE OF EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. WHAT I
THAT. DOWN BACK. NOW I DON'T I
DON'T. EDUCATION FINANCE A LATE
SO I'M NOT CERTAIN THAT EVEN IF
WE HAD THE EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION RIGHT NOW WE WOULD GO
AND BUY BACK. WHERE WE WERE TEN
YEARS AGO TO GO BACK AND
PERCENT I THINK IF WE- HAD
LIMóN UNLIMITED RESOURCE YEAH
BUT I THINK YOU TO EVALUATE-
OPPORTUNITY COST AT BUT I KNOW
WE HAVE. JANET TODAY AND THIS.
ONE OF ANY ISSUES THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO GRAPPLE WITH HERE SO
OF MISTER MEDINA. YOU KNOW I
EIGHT. THE GREE WITH SOME OF-
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA
IN MY DISTRICT. WHICH HAS THE
LOWEST PERCENTAGE OF COLLEGE
GOING RATE ALONG PROBABLY WITH
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN
CALIFORNIA- WE HAVE THE LOWEST
PERCENTAGE OF A- BACHELOR
DEGREE IN POPULATION. I'VE I
REALLY DO NOT HERE A CLAMOR.
FROM MY CONSTITUENTS THAT THEY
FELT SO STRONGLY THAT THEY MAY
NOT HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED TO UCLA.
CAL BERKELEY I WAS A HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER FOR TWENTY SOME
YEARS. AND I SAW WERE STUDENTS
UP WENT TO COLLEGE IN EVERY
YEAR OF A GRADUATING CLASS
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS I
THINK THE GRADUATING CLASS OF
POLY HIGH SCHOOL IN RIVERSIDE
WHERE I TAUGHT. WITH ONE TO
COLLEGE. YOU KNOW AND IF I
REMEMBER CORRECTLY YOU KNOW
FIVE OR SIX. MAY GO TO UCLA.
YOU KNOW MAYBE TWO OR THREE THE
CALIBER GLEE. OF ONE OR TWO
WOULD GO THE IVY LEAGUE
COLLEGES- BUT I DON'T HEAR I DO
NOT HEAR FROM MY CONSTITUENTS.
THAT IS SO IMPORTANT TO THEM. I
THINK MORE IN TO THEM IS THAT
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY BECAUSE I
HEAR FROM MOTHERS WHO COME TO
MY OFFICE AND TELL ME YOU KNOW
THEY DON'T WANT THEIR KIDS ONLY
TO WAREHOUSE WORK. NO THEY- A
COLLEGE TO GO TO HAVE A BETTER
FUTURE. BUT IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE AT UCLA
OR OR CAL BERKELEY. BUT I VERY
MUCH SUPPORT THE IDEA THAT THE
UC SHOULD BE YOU KNOW FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. I ASKED
THE QUESTION THAT THAT THE SORT
OF WAS RAISED AND YOU KNOW
WHERE WAS CALIFORNIA IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SO I WANT TO
ASK THE QUESTION DO YOU SEE. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY OR PICK ANOTHER
DECK. BEFORE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF UC'S BUDGET
WAS PART FUNDED BY THE STATE IT
CALIFORNIA. THAT SHIFTED. THE
PERCENTAGE OF THE UC BUDGET
THAT WAS PARKED THE FUNDED BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HOW IS
THAT CHANGE OVER TIME. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION MISTER
MEDINA IN NINETEEN EIGHTY- I
THINK WAS CLOSE 280% OF THE
UC'S BUDGET WAS COMING FROM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AT THAT
POINT IF EVEN OR ODD DO THE
EXACT NUMBER. IF I COULD A
MENTAL BUT ON THE COST
PRESSURES THAT WE ARE FEELING
LATELY- AS A SYSTEM WE HAVE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT BEEN
RECEIVING A LOT OF. MONEY FROM
OF. FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA EVERY YEAR SINCE
TWENTY TWELVE YOU BE GIVING US
INCREASES. BUT ONE. THAT WE
HAVE. FOR MANY ON A SINCE THEN
IS ARE RICH. PROGRAM IN THE TWO
AN EIGHT NOT BASH ARE. PROGRAM
COLA STE AND WE HAVE HAD TO
START PUTTING TRUMP. THE MONEY
INTO IT EVER YEAR THAT ACTUALLY
GO PROVIDE ANY NEW SERVICES ON
THE CAMPUSES. YOUR PROGRAM AND
REALLY IF WE WANT TO DEAL WITH
FUNDING AND CAPACITY ISSUES ON
THE CAMPUSES WE WOULD FIND A
WAY TO DEAL WITH OUR- TOWARDS
US. WOULD HAVE TO PUT IT LESS
MONEY EARLY AND WE COULD USE
THOSE FUN INSTEAD FOR
CALIFORNIA ACCESS. WHAT WHAT
WHAT AN AGE OF THE UC'S BUDGET
TODAY IS- STATE FUNDED. A TODAY
WHERE THE 42% STATE FUNDED
PARKOUR CAMPUS OPERATIONS 42%
ASTRID. OVER THAT WAY THE
DIVISIONAL AMOUNT OF MONEY OF
ALMOST NINE HUNDRED. THAT THE
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS RIGHT.
YES THANK YOU CONTINUE MR
MEDINA I ACTUALLY GET A JUST ON
THAT POINT THE- SO IF YOU
INCLUDE FINANCIALLY WHAT WOULD
BE THE PERCENTAGE OF STATE
FUNDING THAT THAT SUPPORT
SERVICE OF TWENTY STUDENTS. I
DON'T HAVE NUMBER IN FRONT OF
ME I'M SORRY. WHAT WHAT'S THE
WHAT'S THE NUMBER THEM- IF THE
ISSUE IS HOW MANY COMING
BILLION IN THE CORE. A NUMBER
OF THE ABOUT OF. ALMOST FOUR
POINT NINE BILLION OKAY SO.
THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY SO ONE
BILLION MORE. 20% MORE. BUT TO
THE TO THE COMMITTEE WHERE IS
THREE OF US TO TELL BUT THE
BATHROOM O THE TO THE CAN WORK
OR DO TO OUR- YOU YOU CAN SEE
THE PERCENTAGE OF THE BUDGET
HAS DECREASED. OF SUPPORT. UC
RIGHT IT IS. DRAMATICALLY YEAH
YEAH AS A PERCENTAGE OF THE
OVERALL GENERAL FUND BUDGET
YEAH ABSOLUTELY LOOK AT HOW
MUCH WE'VE BEEN SPENDING ON
CORRECTIONS SINCE THE LATE
EIGHTIES STRONG CORRELATION
RIGHT THERE RIGHT BUT I AND I
MEAN THE PERCENTAGE STATE BOARD.
TO OUR FOR OF BUDGET BUT-
PERCENTAGE OF THE BY THAT IS BY
THIS BY THE IPHONE WOULD SAY
IT'S NOT. PERCENT AGAIN WE NEED.
SIR CRISTINA GARCIA THE MATH
PROFESSOR HELP US BUT I WOULD
SAY IT'S WELL OVER 50% IF YOU
LOOK AT THE STATE MONEY
BECAUSE- BACK. TO THE STUDIO
COMMISSION THEY WRITE A CHECK
TO THE UC FOR ABOUT A BILLION.
TO SAY THAT'S NOT ME I THINK IT
BEING INTELLECTUALLY DISHONEST
AND SO WE NEED COULD COUPLE ALL
THE MONEY FROM THE FUND THE GO.
THE UNIT. WE HAVE. QUITE A FEW
MORE SO. I WANT TO GET A THANK
YOU. YOU KNOW CAL. WE TO HEAR
NOW FOR OUR SEE YOU.
GOOD
MORNING I AM DOCTOR APRIL GROW
MOLD DIRECTOR FOR ENROLLMENT
MANAGEMENT SERVICES AND THE
DIVISION OF ACADEMIC AND
STUDENT AFFAIRS AT THE CSU
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. THIS ONE TO
THE PAS. YES TO ENROLLMENT
GRADUATION TRANSFER AND THE
RESULTS OVER FALL TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN SYSTEM WIDE
REDIRECTION PROCESS. AS THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
ACADEMIC YEAR BEGAN OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND
STUDENTS WERE ENROLLED ACROSS
THE TWENTY THREE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY CAMPUS. THAT
NUMBER REPRESENTS THE FIFTH
YEAR OF RECORD STUDENT MOMENT
FCS. OUR UNDERGRADUATE
POPULATION CONSISTS OF 49% OF
UNDER REPRESENTED BACKGROUNDS
AND 55% ARE THE FIRST IN THEIR
FAMILY TO PURSUE A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE. SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN TEAM THE CSU HAS
INCREASED RESIDENT ENROLLMENT
CAPACITY BY MORE THAN FORTY ONE
THOUSAND FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
GEN. THAT IS ESSENTIALLY
CREATING TWO NEW CSU CAMPUSES
THE SIZE OF SACRAMENTO STATE
AND CAL POLY POMONA. CSU BUT
TARGET FOR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY WAS SET AT JUST
OVER THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FOUR THOUSAND F. T. E.'S
PULMONARY PROJECTIONS INDICATE
THAT THE YES YOU WILL EXCEED
THE ENROLLMENT TARGET BY
APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN THOUSAND
TWENTY. DE BOB WHAT THREW OFF
BRING NEED MISSION TO TRY UNITS
AND CONTINUING STRINGS TO
HIGHER LOW. WITH INCREASED
STATE FUNDING THE CO HOW BEEN
ABLE TO CONTINUE CAN TO ADVANCE
THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THESE FUNDS
HAVE AUGMENTED INSTRUCTION IN
RESPONSE TO STUDENT DEMAND AS
WELL AS PROVIDED THE CO
CURRICULAR SUPPORT AND HIGH
IMPACT PROGRAMS OF A LOT. TO
REDUCE TIME 2 DEGREES BOTH
RETENTION ROGER RATES. AS THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA NOTED RECENTLY THE
SIX YEAR FRESHMAN GRADUATION
RATES FOR CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
HAVE INCREASED BY 10% FOR THE
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN COHORT AS
COMPARED TO THE TWO THOUSAND
NINE CO. CAL COMMUNITY LET'S
TRANSFER SO YOU HAVE ALSO BEEN
GRADUATING IN INCREASED RATES
WITH AN ALMOST 9% FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE INCREASE ROM
200-092-2000 FIFTEEN COHORT.
THE IN THING AND CONTINUE
GRADUATIONS. BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH HIGHLY EDUCATED
WORKERS IN THE FIELDS WHERE WE
KNOW MORE SKILLED PROFESSIONALS
ARE WE NEED IT WE CONTINUE TO
BE THE LARGEST PROVIDER OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHERS. WELL THE CSU HAS BEEN
LASER FOCUSED ON IMPROVING
DEGREE COMPLETION AND REDUCING
TIME TO. WITH SO MANY. SAYS ON
OUR MISSION HAVING THE AXLE BY
WE FOLK ON BOTH ACCESS ANSWER
THAT'S- WHILE THE WOMAN IS A-
ON CON OF THE ADMISSION AND
MATRICULATING. I OF A MANAGED
SERVING TEN EWING'S SINCE AS
FOR THE CA THEY COMPRISE
APPROXIMATELY 70% OF OUR
ENROLLMENT. FOR FALL TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OVER TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS APPLIED
FOR ADMISSION TO THE YES YOU AS
A FRESHMAN OR TRANSFER STUDENT.
EIGHTIES TIME BELIEVE MINUTE
ONE OF THE CS USE THEY APPLIED.
THREE DIRECTIONS THE OTHER 13%
WERE ADMITTED SEE CAMPUS THAT
HAD PASSED IT TOOK. ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS. HER NEW STUDENT ROMAN
AND ALMOST TEN THOUSAND MORE
NEW STUDENTS FOR THE FALL TERM
IN JUST TWO YEARS AGO. THE
STATE WAS ALSO YOU DOES THE
GROWTH AND THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS COMING TO US WITH THE
SOCIAL. FOR TRANSFERS WHICH
WHAT IT THE BILL TEAM FORTY
INTO THE TEN. IN FALL TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN ALMOST THIRTY
EIGHT THOUSAND NEW TRANSFER
STUDENT FROM CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES APPLIED TO
THE CSU WITH AN ASSOCIATE
DEGREE IT'S FOR. ALSO YES TO
ALL OF. THREE MINUTES. THIS
NUMBER IS AN INCREASE OF OVER
TEN THOUSAND NEW STUDENTS WHO
EARNED IN AT T. PRIOR TO
TRANSFER COMPARED TO FALL TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. THIS IS AN
IMPORT FRIENDS BECAUSE TRIPS
FOR STUDENTS WHO EARNED IN AT
T. ENTER THE CSU BETTER
PREPARE. HAVING THE COURSE WORK
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE THAT
SATISFIES AT LEAST HALF THEIR
SEAT. THREE REQUIREMENTS. AT WE
ARE LOOKING TO IMPROVE. ROSS
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. WHY IS EXPANDING OUR
ON OUT FOR ADMISSION TO AND A
TRAY PLANNER THAT WILL ALLOW
CALIBER NEW COLLEGE STUDENTS TO
TRACK THEM PLAN THEIR INTO THE
SEATS YOU. WHAT WE CONTINUE. A
LOT YEAH ONE ROMAN ACTS AND
SURE WHERE ALSO WORKING MEET
READ AND- WORKFORCE NEEDS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THIS IS
YOU CAP IS ON THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFF. OUR IS OUR WORKING WERE
ACCESS NEEDS OF THE DIFFERENT
REGIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN THE SPRING TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE ISSUE OF
MEETING TO DISCUSS REGIONAL
SPECIFIC NEEDS AND PLAN. THE
MEETINGS INCLUDED OR GENERAL
POPULAR. HEIGHTS I DO WE CAN
READ AND READ. AND IN ADDITION
THE CSU CAMPUS. THE KID MUCH OF
THEIR G. THOUSAND NINE MEETING
TO DISCUSSING ENROLLMENT MEANS.
HELLO DONALD FROM THE COLLEGE
FUTURES FOUNDATION ALSO
PROVIDED CONTACTS AT THAT
MEETING. I'D LIKE SOME OF THE
ONE THING IN THE CSU TO MEET
THESE NEEDS LET ME JUST A FEW
PROGRAMS AND INITIATIVES AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY FIRST BILL
KAULITZ SOUTHWEST IS NOW OPEN
ON THE STATE. CAMPUS TEMPORARY
ROOMS UNIVERSITY SET COMPLETE.
DID YOU ARE WORKING TO PROMOTE
A FINISHER OR FOR. AND WORK
JOINTLY TRUTH TRANSITIONS FROM
RENEGADES TO ROAD RUNNER. CSU
FULLERTON YES YOU SAN
BERNARDINO HAVE PARTNERED WITH
RIVERSIDE CITY COLLEGE TO OFFER
A CONCURRENT ENROLLMENT NURSING
PROGRAM. AND HUMBOLDT WILL
LAUNCH A HYBRID ASSOCIATES
DEGREE FOR NURSING TO BSN
PROGRAM AND FALL TWENTY TWENTY
THIS PROGRAM WILL ATTRACT ADN
STUDENTS WHO. LOSE DEGREE AND
HAVE HAD LIMITED AVENUES TO.
PURSUE A BACHELOR'S OF SCIENCE
IN NURSING. NOW LET ME TURN MY
COMMENTS DIRECTION PROCESS FOR
FALL TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. AS
REQUIRED THE CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES PASSED A POLICY ON RE
DIRECTION IN MARCH OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE FIRST
FULL REDIRECTION TERM WAS. TWO
THOUSAND NINE. TO FALL OF
NINETEEN IN THIS. THREE FOR
TRANSFER APPLE THAT SEEING A
LEGIBLE BUT NOT ADMITTED TO ANY
CAMPUS THE APPLIED REQUIRE BY
SB FOURTEEN FORTY. THE NEW ROOF
RACKS POLICY THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR REDIRECTION TO FIRST TIME
FRESHMAN AND TRANSFER
APPLICANTS AS WELL AS THE- FOR
TRANS CSU I'LL- BUT NOT
ADMITTED TO AND CAMPUS THEM I'D-
START APRIL. NINETEEN WE
STARTED MEETING WITH APPLICANTS
THAT THEY WERE STE THEY STILL
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO ATTACK
CSU COP CAMPUS THAT STILL HAD.
A CITY WE CONSERVE PARTLY ME
FIVE THOUSAND APPLICANTS BE
EATEN UP TAX MATH THIS. NOT CSU
THIS STILL HAVE AVAILABLE. WE
SENT ME MESSAGES TO THIS GROUP
OF APPLICANTS AND PROVIDED TO
CSU WEBSITE THAT ALLOWED THEM
TO EXPLORE THE NINE CAMPUS I.
OF THE FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS
THAT WERE INITIALLY ELIGIBLE
FOR REDIRECTION EIGHT HUNDRED
NINETY TWO APPLICANTS
ULTIMATELY ENROLLED AT A CA. ES
THIS EQUATED TO APPROXIMATELY
FOUR AND A HALF PERCENT YIELD
OVERALL. YIELD FOR TRANSFER
STUDENTS WITH POINT 2% COMPARED
TO ONE POINT EIGHT. PERCENT
FROM PRESS. ACTUALLY THAT'S
WHAT HE DID THE CSU CHANCES ARE.
PROCESS WITH CAMPUSES AND
INTERNAL STOP TO DETERMINE BEST
PRACTICES AND WAYS TO IMPROVE
THE PROCESS. AS THIS PROCESS
NEW FOR CSU FOR TIME FRESHMAN
APPLICANTS AND THEIR COUNSELORS
AND FAMILIES WILL BE INCREASING
OUR COMMUNICATION AND EDUCATION
EFFORTS FOR THIS POPULATION.
THIS IS ALSO FOUND THAT
PROVIDING DEBT WEBSITES AND A
PRIMARY POINT OF CONTACT FOR
WAS IMPORTANT TO CONNECT THESE
STUDENTS TO SPECIFIC AREAS ON
CAMPUS SUCH AS FINANCIALLY AND
HOUSING. INCLUDE THE CSU WAS
WORKING TO PROVIDE ACCESS AND
MEET THE REGIONAL NEEDS OF THE
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES THAT I'VE
TAKEN ALL THE RIGHT STUFF TO
PREPARE RECALL IT. IN TWO. IT
WAS FUND AND ROMAN GROWTH BROAD
TUITION OFFERED IS ALLOWING THE
CSU TO MEET CALIFORNIA'S NEED
FOR AN EDUCATED WORKFORCE AND
TO REMAIN COMPETITIVE THE US
AND GLOBALLY WE WILL CONTINUE
TO NEED RESOURCES FOR THAT WE
CAN CALIFORNIA. AT THE- THANK
YOU EIGHT PROPERTY WITH YOU
THIS MORNING. THANK YOU I'M
RAIN STORM ALSO FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE OF THE
ASSISTANT VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
BUDGET NOT JUST HERE TO HELP
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS HAVE.
THANK YOU FOR THE RIGHT. BACK
ON TRACK HERE. ONCE AGAIN YOU
SEE IN ALL OF THE TENSION. I
DON'T SEE AS YOU THAT AT TIMES
RIGHT. YES EXCEPT OVER DOLING
OUT THE BUDGET ALLOCATION.
WHAT'S YOUR FAIR SHARE TO SELL
ALL START OFF WITH THE- THE
QUESTION I ASKED WITH YOU SEE
ABOUT. OFF CAMPUS AND- WELL I
THINK THOSE ARE VERY TO
PROMISING IDEAS DEALING WITH.
ACCESS AND THEM LOOKING TO
EXPAND ASSIST EXCESS ABILITY
FOR CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
GRADUATES- START WITH THE
SUMMER. WHAT ELSE COULD WE BE
DOING TO HELP MAKE THAT A
REALITY DEAL WITH THAT.
SITUATION IS DEPENDENT AND
AGREE I'M TO GET DOWN TO FOUR
YEARS. FOR SUMMER TWO WE WILL
BE OFF. NINE CAMPUSES
APPROXIMATELY SIX DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT OUR SCHOOL SO THEY
SHOULD HELP SUPPORT THOSE
STUDENTS ARE INTERESTED IN
TAKING A CLOSER. ALSO SOME OF.
EXPLORING XP CSU FULLY ONLINE
TO SUMMER THAT WOULD ALLOW
STUDENTS TO TAKE ONLINE CLASSES
DURING THE SUMMER SO. WE HAVE
NINE CAMPUSES BE SUPPORTING
FINANCIAL AID AND STATE SIDE
SUMMER COURSES THIS YEAR. YOUR
THING TOO IS THAT WITH THE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH THAT WE
RECEIVE SINCE THE END OF THE
GREAT RECESSION WE'VE HAD FORTY
ONE THOUSAND SPOTS THAT HAVE
BEEN CREATED BY YOU OVER THE
YEARS- CAMPUSES WHAT WE DO WE
ALLOCATE THAT. THOSE ENROLLMENT
TARGETS ARE THOSE NEW SLOTS TO
CAMPUSES THEN AS YOU SEE IT
THERE IS A- CITY FOR DO SUMMER
COURSE OFF. THEY WILL LAUNCH
THOSE OVER ON THAT SO WE DON'T
DIRECT THEM FROM THAT FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AT THIS
POINT TO DO SO. BUT IT'S REALLY
KIND OF A THE GRASS ROOTS OF.
ARMS OF IF THEY IDENTIFY
PARTICULAR PER ROOM THAT MAKES
SENSE TO THEM THAT THEY'LL
WATCH THAT WITH THERE ARE SOME
RUMBLINGS OF PARTICULAR
CAMPUSES THAT ARE KICKING THE
TOP. LEAVE A STATE SUPPORT.
PROGRAM ISN'T CASE FOR NUMBER
OF YEARS. SO AS ROAMING GROWS
WE ARE- SEEING THAT THERE'S
MORE OF AN APPETITE- FOR CAMPUS
IS TO SHIFT. SOME OTHER
ENROLLMENT TO THE SUMMER WHICH
IS GOOD FOR. YOU KNOW.
ADDRESSING CAPACITY NEEDS AND
THAT SORT OF THING SO I THINK
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION I THINK
YOU HAVE THE FINANCIAL. PIECE
YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL ROAMING
GROW. IN ACTIVITY CAMPUSES I
THINK I THAT'S THAT'S A US IN
PUTTING IS THE WRITER OKAY HOW
ABOUT THE OFF CAMPUS. CENTER
DISCUSSION. THROUGH ANOTHER
THERE IS TALK ABOUT A NEW CSU
STOCKED IN AND I THINK SANDRA
DINO YOU KNOW GET UNLIMITED
RESOURCES THAT WOULD BE NICE
BUT- IF THAT'S- THE BEST THING
WE SHOULD DO OUR BIGGEST BANK
BACK WITH LIMITED RESOURCES AND
SO I THINK. WE'LL FOCUSING
EVERYTHING SOON THROUGH. BUT WE
HAVE SOME OF THESE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND- YOUR TALK ABOUT
THAT. TWO ONE. SURE OKAY NOT AT
THIS TIME THE CENTERS IT'S
ACTUALLY MORE EXPENSIVE FROM AN
ACT TO EAT PERSPECTIVE TO
EXPECT AND CENTERS THAT IT IS
EXPANDING EXISTING EMPHASIS SO
CENTER BEING USED ALERT MEANS
SPIT. ALSO IT WHAT I JUST READ
SPECIFIC PART OFFERED OUTS BUT
ON. CAMPUS LOOK TO OUR PARTNER
WITH OTHER SCHOOLS KIND OF HOW
CAL STATE SAN MARCOS START
STATE SAN MARCOS ACTUALLY
STARTED AS AN UPPER DIVISION
COURSEWORK AND IN. ON LOWERED
OF COURSE WERE TO BECOME A FOR
FULL UNIVERSITY BUT I THINK
CAPACITY ASSESSMENT STUDY WILL
BETTER HELP US UNDERSTAND THE
SPECIFIC NEEDS AND THE- AS-
WHERE THOSE. MIGHT AND I THINK
OVER TIME WHY YOU HAVE THE
CENTERS TO BEGIN WITH IS
BECAUSE THERE HAS BEEN AYE IF I
DEMAND. PARTICULAR CAMPUS
THAT'S IT YOU KNOW LINKED WITH
SAN BERNADINO THEY HAVE A EIGHT
HUNDRED OF ALL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENT OR THAT'S BECAUSE
THERE'S BEEN MORE OF A DEMAND
AND. MORE AGGRESSIVELY PERHAPS-
BUT THEN ALSO THEY THEY DO
UTILIZE THEM JUST IN GENERAL-
BECAUSE THERE ARE PARTICULAR
NEEDS ON US CAMPUSES. THANK YOU.
IF I UNDERSTOOD CORRECTLY I
THINK YOU GAVE THE FIGURE THAT
ONLY 4% OF THE STUDENTS WHO ARE
RE DIRECTED RESERVE OF
APPLICANTS. AND THE GOAL TO
IT'S WHERE THEY BEEN RE DIRECT
THAT. YES ABOUT FOUR FOUR AND A
HALF PERCENT ULTIMATELY ROLE
EVEN THOUGH ALL TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND WERE ULTIMATELY RE
DIRECT TO A CAMPUS RIGHT SO BUT
ALL 4% OF THE TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS WERE READ
ACTED EVENTUALLY AND- AT WHAT
ISSUE CAN. STATE SO BROWN OF BY
TWO WHERE THEY APPLY SO THAT'S
ACTUALLY NOT EXACTLY THE REASON
WE HAVE A TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS DIDN'T COME UP TO XIN.
OF THE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS WHEN WE LOOK THE
CALIFORNIA REFERENCE THEY WERE
SEVENTY SAID ABOUT 77% OF THEM
ACTUALLY WENT TO ANOTHER
UNIVERSITY OR IF YOUR ARE CAN
YOU CALL IT. SO THE- BUT
STUDENT BUT HE IT LOCALLY ACT
MUCH HIGHER THAN THE NUMBER
STUDENTS THAT ARE AT TEN LOW%
EIGHT SO ALL STE ARE. DOWN WITH
THIS. SO IT WASN'T. BECAUSE
THEY THEY COULDN'T GO TO SOME
OTHER PART OF THE STATE THAN TO
ATTEND. THANK YOU. OKAY YEAH
THE QUESTIONS GALLAGHER
QUESTION YES STRONGER. ALSO THE.
DONE. ONE QUESTION I HAD WAS
AROUND THE AT T. S. IN THAT
PROGRAM NOW THIS YEAR
ESTABLISHING- ASSOCIATE DEGREE
FOR TRANSFERS. RIGHT NOW
IMPACTION OBVIOUSLY IS
AFFECTING UC CAMPUSES BOTH UC
AND CSU CAMPUSES BUT MAY MOST
ESPECIALLY CSU CAMPUSES. AND IT
DEPEND ON WHETHER THE IMPACTION
IS BY CAMPUS OR BY PROGRAM IN
ADDITION TO ANSWERING YOU KNOW
AS YOU HAVE ABOUT THE STATUS OF
THE POLICY TO PROVIDE
ADMISSIONS PRIORITY TO STUDENTS
RESIDE HELLO SERVICER. AND YOU
IF I HOW THESE ACTION POLICIES
ALSO AFFECT EIGHTY TEAS-
THEY'RE TRYING TO TRANSFER INTO
THE CSU SYSTEM TO THEIR LOCAL
CAMPUS. FIRST SO EIGHTY TWO
USED ACTUALLY GET TWO BOMBS AT
THEY ARE LOCAL AND APPLYING TO
WIN IMPACTED PROGRAM SO THAT A
TRANSFER STATE THAT HAS AN
EIGHTY E. THAT IS A- ONE EIGHT
PROGRAM. MILLER SO THE MEANS I
HAVE SEEN COLLEGE COMMUNITY
CALL AND I CLIMBED A PSYCH PRO
AT THE CAL STATE THEY ARE
RECEIVE UP. THE EIGHT AS WELL
AS THE PRIORITY BUT- THEY WERE
APPLYING TO A SIMILARPATHWAY
AND APPLYING TO THEIR LOCAL CSU
OKAY SO THAT GIVES A MAYBE AN
ADDITIONAL PRIORITY IS ANOTHER
WE'RE- YEAH IF THEY HAVE AN
EIGHTY T. AND THEN ALSO WITH
THE AT T. PROGRAM IF THEY'RE
APPLYING ON THE SIMILAR
PATHWAY. THEY COME IN WHICH
YOU'RE STANDING AND THEY ONLY
HAVE SIXTY UNITS TO FINISH
THEIR DEGREE. OKAY. AND I
MISSPOKE GRAND OF UC DOESN'T
HAVE INTERACTION AND SEE AS HE
THAT DOES IMPACTION RIGHT. BUT
I SEE THAT CONTINUES TO BE KIND
OF A TOUGH ISSUE FOR PEOPLE
TRYING TO GET IN- YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU GUYS DECLARE AN IMPACTION
EITHER ON THE CAMPUS OR- IN A
PROGRAM. YOU KNOW THERE THERE'S
IT KIND OF PUTS A STRANGLEHOLD
OBVIOUSLY ON PEOPLE BE ABLE TO
GET IN. YOU GUYS ARE DOING
RIGHT NOW TO KIND OF ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES SURE SO.
CAPTION PROCESS IS ACTUALLY-
STATE MANDATED FINALLY- ADD
CODE EIGHT NINE ZERO THREE ZERO
POINT FIVE AND SO IT'S REQUIRED
THAT EACH CAMPUS TO ANNUAL
REVIEW OF THEIR IMPACTION
PROCESS IF THEY ARE GOING TO
MAKE. AN IMPACT IN CHANGES THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE TO GO PUBLIC.
TRUST SO HE WAS THE WRAPPING UP
THEIR PUBLIC HEARINGS ABOUT NOW
FOR THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
ACADEMIC YEAR. MOST RECENTLY
ACTUALLY THEY GAVE THE TREND
HAS BEEN TO DISCONTINUE
IMPACTION SO FOR EXAMPLE FOR-
FALL TWENTY ONE WHICH IS WHAT
THE- OUR OF. AND LIGHT THROUGH
EIGHT. SO NOT MUCH WILL BE DEBT
IMPACTION FOR FIRST TIME
FRESHMEN HUMBOLDT WILL BE
DISCONTINUING BIOLOGY BOTANY
ZOOLOGY ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE
AND MANAGEMENT. SEND A BAIT.
EWING BUSINESS CAN YOU JIM.
ACTION BY SCIENCES THAT
SACRAMENTO HAS PLAN IN PLACE
THE THREE YEARS FULLY AND- SO
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS WE'VE
ACTUALLY SEEN A LOT OF
DISCONTINUANCE OF IMPACTION IN
THIS IS BASED ON THE ANNUAL
WERE VIEW AND THE PLANS THAT
THE CAMPUSES HAVE TO PROVIDE TO
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. I
WOULD HAVE. THE REASON FOR THAT
IS THAT. THE WITH MANY YEARS IN
A ROW OF SUSTAIN FUNDING TO THE
UNIVERSITY. DESHAWN ROLE THAT
SLIDES THAT GET. IS MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN THE ABILITY
EDUCATE MORE. AND I'M PROGRAM
ALL IMPACTED BECAUSE OF THAT
CRISIS OF THE DAY YOU HAVE A
SITUATION NOW WHERE OVER TIME
BEEN LETTING MORE AND MORE OF
THAT IMPACTS AND THAT'S
TESTAMENT TO YOUR INVESTMENTS
ARE NUTS GET IS EIGHT. TO HEAR
THE AS OUR DRESSINGSHOES AND
CERTAINLY OF HAVE DONE A LOT TO
HELP ADDRESS THE ENROLLMENT
ISSUE. ON THAT SUBJECT HOW THE
GUYS USE YOUR ENROLLMENT
DOLLARS HOUSE THAT BEEN
ALLOCATED. YOU KNOW MORE
SPECIFICALLY TEACH CAMPUS AND
I'M KIND OF INTERESTED
OBVIOUSLY IN THOSE HIGH DEMAND
IS HAVE YOU. AND THAT PURPLE
LOOKING AT YOU DID DO THE MOST
WORK IN OTHER WORDS THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR HAVE YOU DONE
THAT OF YOU TO. THAT I COULD
PREPARE AND LOOK AT MY NOTES ON.
SO WHAT WE DONE. THAT THE BACK
UP OF FOR IS WE'VE AT IT FROM A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT ANGLES AND
IT'S NOT CLEARLY A PERSONAL
ASPECT SO IF WE RE STATE
INCREASED 1% ENROLLMENT
INCREASE NEVER EMPLOYED THAT
ARE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT. ANY
VERY SMALL QUE RIGHT CAN'T DID
SAY IN THAT IT WAS IN THE MID
NINETY I THINK IS SAN MARCOS-
WE ALSO CHANNELIZED SO ONE OF
THINGS WE SAID OKAY FOR ONE OF
THE- IS THAT WE HAVE IS THAT
FOR SMALL THIS IS A SMALL
STUDENT SHINS THANK TO GROW
THEIR CAPACITY. ON THOSE
CAMPUSES- THE OTHER THING TOO
IS WE'VE OBVIOUSLY- LOOKED AT-
DEMAND AT THOSE HIGH- THOSE
HIGHLY DEMANDED CAME THIS RIGHT
SO THERE HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES THE SAN DIEGO.
ALCOHOL THESE THE LONG BEACH IS
THOSE OF ALL I COULD HAVE
RECEIVED INCREASES ALSO UP THE
ONE THING THAT HAS TEMPERED A
LITTLE BIT OF THIS TO IS. AT
THIS BILL MASS. INTER PHYSICAL
PLAN IN ITS INSTANCE WE HAVE
ACT RUN INTO THAT CAPACITY THAT
THAT CAP SO. A MASS AND
PHYSICAL MASTER PLAN IS
DEVELOPED AT THE LOW LEVEL BY
THE CAMPUS. APPROVED BY THE
BOARD PLEASE. HELP IN CONCERT
THE LOCAL YEAH RIGHT. AND SO
I'LL BE YOU WOULD YOU
ANTICIPATE THAT IT CAN. GO FROM
SAY A TEN THOUSAND. CAMPUS TO A
THOUSAND CAMPUS RIGHT BECAUSE
THERE'S- THERE'S TRAFFIC IN
THOSE SORTS OF THINGS. SO IN
SOME IT SAYS ON ON THINKING TO-
CAL POLY AS WELL AS WITH FULLER
TEN. IN CHICO THE SICK AND- IS
A LITTLE LIMITED AMOUNT. AT THE
START. WITH US IS SPACES TO
EDUCATE STUDENTS AS AS WE WOULD
LIKE AND THEN ALSO BE THE
MASTER PLAN SO TO SPEAK SO WE
HAVE TEMPERED IT DOWN AND I
DON'T WANT IT IS A SAYS I A-
IT'S- TAKEN. FOR A THE FRONT.
ADDING A THEIR- IN ANY OTHER
FOR ANOTHER FACTOR THE HAS
KICKED IN IS THAT AND HAS
ACTUALLY A ON A BIT OF A DIP IN
ALASKA HAVE HERE'S- PETER.
CALIFORNIA YEAH IN IN IS SET IN
AT HUMBOLDT AT MARITIME WE HAVE
NOT INCREASED IN ENROLLMENT AT
ALL BECAUSE THIS THOSE
PARTICULAR CAMPUSES ARE
ACTUALLY UNDER THE AND TARGET
SO WE DON'T IT IS WRONG THAT'S
MY NOT. AND THAT THERE IS A
HUGE POPULATION ONLY A FINITE
CAMPUSES AND THOSE CAN'T IS A
RATHER LARGE AS IT IS RIGHT NOW
SO THAT KIND OF UP. PIECES I
MATHEMATICAL EXERCISE A
STRATEGIC PLACEMENT OF NEW
ENROLLMENT TO MEET PARTICULAR
NEEDS ON THOSE CAMPUSES.
ALRIGHT. I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
ON THE FIRST OF ALL I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE- HOW YOU.
STARTED OFF YOUR PRESENTATION.
THE FALL. UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
COVER VERSION WITH. YOU KNOW
YOU TALKED OUT TO EXPAND
DRAMATICALLY INCREASING YOUR
YOUR ENROLLMENT- WHERE IT'S THE
EQUIVALENT OF TWO NEW CSU
CAMPUSES ARM HI I'M LOOKING AT.
ARE A MATERIALS HERE THE CASE
THAT CSU AS- INCREASED ITS
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT BY
NEARLY EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND- IN
THE LAST TEN YEARS IT DOES THAT
SOUND RIGHT. WE'LL TAKE THE-
OKAY ALL RIGHT. WE ARE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION OF ALL THAT
INFORMATION SO OUR RATES GOLDEN.
AND YOU KNOW FOLLOWING ON OUR
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE RESIDENT
VERSUS NON RESIDENT- DO YOU
KNOW THE SYSTEM WIDE WHAT A
PERCENTAGE OF CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY. AS A STUDENTS OR-
FROM OUT OF STATE OR NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS. SO OVERALL
IT 6% I 2% OF WILL AFFECT TAKE
THAT 6% OF 40% OR 2% OF THOSE
ARE DOMESTIC SO THE FROM OTHER
STATES OF THE P. SIX. RED OF
THEM ARE. AND WHAT PAYING THE
EIGHT IN RED STUDENT ENROLLMENT
FROM FAULT TEAM PAUL TWENTY
NINETEEN WE HAVE SEEN A DROP IN.
EIGHT HUNDRED I'M CONVINCED. SO
WENT FROM. HE SAID HOUSE IN A
RANGE THAT TO TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND IN CHANGE. AND YOU THE
DEBT TO CAL STATE HAVE A
SIMILAR- FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO
TRY TO RECRUIT AN INCREASE THE-
THE NUMBER OF OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS NOT PARTICULARLY
THERE'S NOT A LOT THAT COMES IN
TO PLACE AND WE HAVE. SPREAD
OUT OVER TWENTY THREE CAN. SO
NOW THE THINGS THAT WE DO IN
TERMS OF WHEN WE ALLOCATE MONEY
FROM THE STATE AND BALLOTS THAT
WITH TUITION WE NEVER FACTOR IN
NON RESIDENT TUITION BECAUSE AT
THE CSU WE TREATED MORE AS LIKE
THAT THIS IS A GOOD HAVE A WE
HAVE. NOT IT'S IT FLUCTUATES A
LOT FOR EXAMPLE. YOUR WE HAD AN
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS TO.
SOMETHING HAPPEN THE BRISE
ECONOMY ALL OF OUR INSTANCE.
FROM SO IT'S VERY TENUOUS IT
BOUNCES AROUND QUITE A BIT- I
THINK WE ONE OTHER THING THAT'S
BEEN FACTOR IS A SINCE THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION CAME AND
THERE'S BEEN SOME DISTANCE
STUDENTS COMING TO. HAVE AS
POINT SO THAT'S- ATTEMPTING
SORT OF. US AND THEN- AND THEN
YOUR EVERY FROM FALL EIGHTEEN
TO NINETEEN PARTICULAR. MAYBE
MISSION THAT BUT I'M NOT WHY
ARE. IT AS MUCH AS A DAY. BUT
WE'RE NOT WE'RE DEPENDANT ON A
THAT WAY WHY WHAT IT WHAT ARE
TUITION LEVEL DO LARGE COVER
THE COST OF THEIR INSTRUCT.
WELL IT'S FUNNY MAKING AND FOR
THAT POINT SO. HOW MUCH DO YOU
TO. NON RESIDENT STUDENTS SO
WHAT THEY. STUDENT SO THEY PAY
TO PIECES- THEY PAY- FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND SEVEN AND FORTY TWO
FOR THE TUITION PIECE WHAT THAT
EVERYBODY PAYS. AND THEN. WHAT
WE DO IS WE CHARGE NOT REST
IT'S ON A PER UNIT THEY TAKE.
AND MOST OF OUR STE ON
RESIDENTS TO ARE ALL TIME
EQUIVALENTS. SO WHEN YOU ADD IT
ALL UP AND ENDS UP BEING ABOUT
THE- TEAM TO A INTEL'S LIFE
ABOUT A THOUSAND. THAT'S PRETTY
CLOSE TO THE CAUGHT. THE COST
OF IT XIN BUT IT'S CHEN. LINE
WITH THIS OF THAT THE FOR
INSTRUMENTS WE HAVE IN TERMS OF
DETERMINING COST OF INSTRUCTION
SO. BUT SO OF THE RIGHT THIS IS
A YOU GET THE DOLLARS PER. NON
RESIDENT STUDENT MORE THAN A
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT GENERALLY
YES OKAY AND YET WE WILL HAS
BEEN TREND ARE YOU YOU SAID
THAT THE TREND HAS BEEN. CLIENT
ON RESIDENTS IN SAID THAT UP
THE REST YEAH I JUST THIS FALL
OVER FALL WE HAD A HUNDRED. A
FEW STUDENTS ARE THIS IS.
SIMILAR TO THE DIVERSITY CAL
ARE THERE ARE CAMPS IS HAVE A
HIGHER. OF NON BY TO THAN. YES
THERE ARE AS SENATE BILL IN SAN
DIEGO. AND WHAT ARE THE PRISON
OF SANDERS MIGHT BE UP TOO IF
I'M NOT I THINK FROM OFF THE
TOP OF MY HEAD I DON'T HAVE
THAT INFORMATION FROM ME BUT I
THINK TELL. JENS YOUR CLOSE TO
FIFTEEN BUT NOT FIFTEEN THEN
SEND THIS JOSE I MENTION IT BUT
IT'S NEVER GET LOWER THAN THAT.
SENATE SINGLE BIT BUT- MOST
THEIR CAMP. IT'S EVERYONE A
SAFE ARE RUNNING A BUT NOT A
STEW POPULATIONS THAT MANY OF
OUR CAMPUSES ARE. VERY AND IN.
MEETING BURKE. IT'S A THE
COMMENT WAS MADE OR THAT THAT
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY IS THE LAW
PROVIDER OF CAL TEACHERS ISN'T
A ALSO THE FOR OR ENGINEER. I
ON DON'T KNOW OKAY I BELIEVE UP
I HEARD THAT IN IN MY NECK OF
THE WOODS CAL SALE BEACH-
BRAGGING ABOUT HOW TO PAY-
TURNOUT MORE ENGINEER NAY THE
POOL IN AND CAL BUT I- I THINK
THE- A GOOD THEY CAN. I MEAN AS
WERE TO ABOUT THE NEED TO
EDUCATE TO. OUR FEE WORKFORCE
IN A TO- TO HIGHLIGHT HOW.
STATE UNIVERSITY. EDUCATE
CALIFORNIA KIDS TO BE PART OF
OUR FUTURE WORKFORCE THE REASON
WHY I HESITATED REPLYING TO USE
THAT THE FACT THAT WE- PREPARED
AND DESCENT IT MAY BE TWO THREE
FOR YOUR- OKAY. BUT WORD. YOUR
VOLUME AT THE C. ISSUE YOU NAME
THE PROFESSION WERE PROBABLY
THE BIGGEST SERVE THE DEGREES
RIGHT JUST BY. THE SHEER
NUMBERS YEAH BUT WE COULD
DEFINITELY DOES STOP THAT
INFORMATION PROVIDED TO YOU NO
PROBLEM OKAY IT ANY CARE THAT
OVER. YOUR ASSIST WIDE GRADUATE
SINCE OUR FIRST GENERAL TO
THAT'S CORRECT. ALL RIGHT OTHER
OF FOR THIS PANEL SO NINE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE YOU. NEXT
WE'D LIKE TO INVITE THE
COMMUNICATE LET'S WRAP. AND
THAT SO LEASE THAT NEVER AT-
WITH THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE OF
COURSE WELCOME AND SHOW WHY
SUPERINTEND PRESIDENT OF SHIP
COLLEGE. GOOD MORNING AND-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I
FIRST WANT TO THINK AS THE
STAFF FOR A GREAT ANALYSIS AND-
CIVIL AT WHAT WE DOING AND MY
NAME IS THE SENATE. ADVICE IN
COLLEGE MY ABILITIES MANNING AT.
S. ONE PROVIDE IF YOU WERE MARK
THAT I'D AN OVERVIEW OF OUR AND-
WE ARE. ALSO JEMS INCREASE
ACCESS I TO STUDENTS IN THREE
REACH OF CAL FROM BACK AND
PRETTY AN INTENTIONAL FOCUS ON
REACHING. THIS LEAD REV
STUDENTS ARE AS I WE ARE FOR
DISH STEW. WITH MORE THAN TWO
ONE MILLION STUDENTS AT A
HUNDRED FIFTEEN COLLEGES THE
CALIFORNIA COMEY COLLEGE SYSTEM
IS THE LARGEST COUNTRY ONE IN
EVERY FOR. STUDENTS NATION I
THINK HEALTH COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THE COMMITTEE CALLED IT COULD
NUYS THE POSSIBILITY IN UPPER.
OF OUR ACCESS MISS. IT'S A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT IT ROMAN
SPENDS IN ROMAN HAS SHOULD. IN
THE LAST TEN YEARS WITH SOME
COLLEGES SEE STAFF OR DID
ENROLLMENT WELL EXPERIENCING
CONTINUED GROWTH SINCE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT AND AT TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT NINE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES HAVE SEE. SHIFT A AND
M. DEMOGRAPHIC DISK GEN I THIS
SERVICE. ARE WE SAW RUMMAGING.
I ACROSS MANY SECTORS
PARTICULARLY FOR TIME STUDENT
SINCE THE RECESSION RECOVERY
THE NUMBER OF COURSES OFFERED-
ATTIC ME CALL IT HAS JUMPED BY
17% AND ENROLLMENT HAS
INCREASED ON POINT EIGHT CENTS
FOR ALL THE GREATEST CHANGE.
THIRTY THREE THE CENTER PLEASE.
MUCH OF OUR SINCE THE GREAT
RECESSION HAS ALSO BEEN
ATTRIBUTED TO INCREASES IN
ENROLLMENT INTENSITY AND FOCUS
ON IRAQ OUTRAGE TRADITIONAL
STUDENTS BUT WE KNOW AND
RECOGNIZE THAT THEIR
IMPROVEMENTS ARE NEED. MORE
THAN EVER CAMINO COLLEGE. WILL
AFRICA IS A SYSTEMIC REFORMS I
TO INCREASE HIGHER EDUCATION
PARTICIPATION AT ACROSS ARE
UNDER REPRESENTED UNITIES THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE COLLEGES
VISION FOR SUCCESS HAS MULTIPLE
GOALS WHICH INCLUDE PRIEST IN
DEGREE. OUT 20% INCREASING
TRANSFER BY 35% AND REDUCE
JOURNAL I AND ACT YEAH OF
PROSSER SYSTEM. SO FOR. READ
THE UNITS A BY SO AS THEY MAKE
WAY TO A DEGREE OR CORD. PART
OF OUR STRATEGY IS TO FOCUS ALL
OF THESE EFFORTS AROUND GUIDED
PATHWAYS OF I MERRY VIçT. OUR
SIX KEY GOALS FOR IMPROVEMENT
TO PROMOTE EQUITY AND ECONOMIC
MOBILITY. OTHER POLICY OF
REFORM SUCH AS BASIC SKILLS AND
A. B. NINETEEN WHICH ARE ALSO
TIED TO GUIDED PATHWAYS HAVE
ASSISTED IN ARE INTENTIONAL
FOCUS TO ADDRESS NOT JUST
ACCESS BUT TACKLE PERCENT SINCE
AND COMPLETION. SO LET I SHARE
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT- EFFORTS
THAT ARE BOTH DIRECTLY AND
INDIRECTLY INCREASING ACCESS TO
CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATION ZERO ARE
A COLLEGES. AB NINETEEN FOR IT
IN FULL HAS HELP IN MAY WAYS TO
ADDRESS THE DATE WE SAW AN THE
GREAT RECESSION OUR OFFER AND
STUDENTS WE'VE SEEN IT POINT
FOUR PER CHAIN. IN IN ROME. I.
UNDER WE BELIEVE THAT. OUR
ONLINE TO NEW PER POLICY WERE
THAT EMERGED THAT ARE HELPING
TIME FULL TIME STUDENT THESE
PROGRAMS AND FINANCE IT'S A
LINE TO AN CENTER NEXT TO AN
ROLE. OR YOU. I SUCH AS THE
DOESN'T COME GRANT. I AND ALSO
MOMENTO BY THE CALL PROGRAMS
THE PROMISE PRO THROUGH AB NOW.
AND AB. COLLEGES HAVE BEEN THE
GOT A CALL PROMISED AT
OPPORTUNITY TO I AM. AND COULD
COLLEGE CULTURE ISN'T ALL
REGIONS A THIS. AND AB TO
SHOWING AND NUMBER OF FULL TIME
STUDENTS WHICH IS A POSITIVE
TREND TOWARDS IMPROVE
COMPLETION AND REDUCE TIME
2 DEGREES OUR COLLEGES THANKS
TO FUNDING THROUGH THE- AT
THROUGH IP I HAVE SEEN
STRATEGIC ENROLLMENT MANAGEMENT
EFFORTS SUCH AS BLOCK
SCHEDULING ACCELERATED-
PROGRAMS AND DEGREES AS WELL AS
YOUR LONG ENROLLMENT TO THAT
STUDENTS DON'T HAVE TO TACKLE
THERE'S WILL THEN HAVE A DOUBLE
CLASS COURSE. WITH REGARD THIS
420% OF OUR STUDENTS. AND 29%
OF THE SEE. AND 51% OF CS USE
GRADUATE AND STARTED AT A
COMMUNITY STUDENT NEARLY HALF
OF. A STUDENTS EARNING
BACHELORS TO BE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT IN
SITE TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING AND
MATH. AT ONE OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. IN THE LAST DECADE
SEEN MAY IMPROVEMENTS THANKS TO
THE ASSOCIATE OR A FOR TRANSFER
WHICH WAS APPROVED IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND THEN RECENTLY THE
UC TRANCE PATHWAY- PROOF IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. I APPROACHES
HAVE PROVIDED I PROMISING
AFFECTIVE STRATEGY TOWARDS
INCREASING DEGREE PRODUCTION
THEIR TRANSFER. MORE WORK IS
NEEDED- AN RP GROUP HI HAS
FOUND WE'VE SEEN PROMISING
GAINES AROUND- ARE AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND BLACK STUDENTS AND
THEIR TRANSFER BUT WE'VE ALL
SEEN THE SIMILAR IS A IDENTIFY
THAT DIVERSE STUDENTS.
SPECIALLY ARE BY ACCESS AT SOME
OF OUR FOUR YEAR ON PUBLIC. I'M
TO THAT AND THE AND IT IS ALL
IS SEEKING. AND A LINE AND RE.
TO SUPPORT GREATER TRAINS PER
AND IMPROVEMENT AND SEEKING ONE
TIME FUNDS UP TWO POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS. WHAT WE'VE
DONE A LOT OF WHAT THE TO
ADDRESS DEGREE GAPS ACROSS THIS
AND MY COLLEAGUE- PRESIDENT JOE
WISE WILL SHARE MORE ABOUT HIS
PROGRAM. I IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN- AND THE LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNOR BROWN APPROVED A
FIFTEEN PILOT- DEGREE PILOT
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE PROGRAMS
AT OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
BLIGHTED A LIST OF THOSE
PROGRAMS- WELL AS- IN YOUR
KNOWLEDGE THIS THESE DEGREES AT
PASSED CITY AND ABLE. OF TO. IN
REGIONS THAT ARE CAN EDUCATION
DOES OR HAVE WE- I DUE TO. ON
IN IT FOR YOU. WITHIN THE ROUND
LOW DO ENROLLMENT WRONG HAS IN
EFFECT STRATEGY TO LEVERAGE-PARTNERSHIPS BEHIGHS AND
COMMUNITY. TO CREATE SEAMLESS
APPROACHES ARE BOTH COST
EFFECTIVE AND MAXIMIZE THE
STUDENT'S TIME DOING MOMENT
PROVIDE THREE KEY BENEFITS
PRODUCTION OF ATTENDED AGREE
INCREASE ATTAINMENT AND CLOSING
ACHIEVEMENT GAP FOR REPRESENTED
STUDENT. CURRENTLY OVER THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND OF OUR F. T.
ASCOM FROM- IS ATTRIBUTED TO DO
ENROLLMENT THIS IS COMPARED TO
FIFTEEN THOUSAND FIVE YEARS AGO.
WE'VE SEEN THESE POSITIVE GAME-
TO POLICY REFORMS SUCH AS A. B.
EIGHTY EIGHT AND A. B. THIRTY
WERE. CREATED THE COLLEGE
ACCESS AND CAREER PATHWAYS
PROGRAM THAT ENABLES COLLEGES
TO OFFER DO AND ROLL MEANT TO
NOT JUST THOSE THAT WERE
ALREADY PROVING TO BE
ACADEMICALLY ADVANCED. CAR AND
MAY NOT AT THE OPERA. TO
ADVANCE THEIR CLOCK COLLEGE
PATHWAYS. WE'RE ALSO DOING A
LOTS OF WORK TO PROVIDE ACCESS
TO GROUPS THAT NEED ASKS AT
EVERY STAGE IN LIFE. SIMPLE OUR
COLLEGES TO HAVE FORTY SEVEN OF
OUR COLLEGES HAVE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED STUDENT PROGRAMS
AND PROGRAMS FOR JUSTICE
INVOLVED YOU. I AND MY
COLLEAGUE PRESIDENT JOE WISE
WILL SHARE MORE ABOUT SAMPLER
PROGRAM. NOT TOO AND HUMAN WE
DANCED CREATING CARRIED. AND
TAKE INTENTIONAL EFFORT TO
PROVIDE REESE. TO I IN FOR OF
OUR THE OPPORTUNITY THAT LIE
FOR THEM. AND THEN WITHIN WERE.
AS A CAN OF COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND ONE THAT- STAND OUT FROM
OTHER INSTITUTIONS ARE STRONG
WORK I MUST ASK COOL AS-
STRATEGY FOR CREE T<c.cyan></c>
CURRICULUM AND PROGRAM UP.
THERE SHOULD WITH. LAWYERS GET
OUR STUDENTS WERE BASED OP. AND
IN IS AT THE COMPLETION OF CA
SEAS SO THE THEY CAN A LIVING.
BERNIE IS A- WORK TO BUILD IS
THAT WE TAKEN A HEART AS WE
WORK WITH MANY OF OUR- AT THE
READ AND HAVE INTENTION
STRATEGIES TO MONITOR DATA
AROUND I REGION CAN FIT. I
FURTHER ASK. WE ARE AT THE
EQUITY FOR OF OUR OF OUR I.
EQUITY IS AT THE FOREFRONT EVER
MISSION FIRST OF OUR- H. SIZE.
BUT MORE WORK IT CAN BE. AS A
MOST IMPORTANT TO THEM IN THE
HIGHER MD WITH. SEC AND- THE
WILL CONTINUE FOR. AIDING
STUDENTS IN THEIR GOAL THANK.
FOR HIGHLY STE. CAREER ROAD
MAPS AND DEFINED AND EXCESSIVE.
AND AFFORD EDUCATION AND CAREER
OBJECTIVES. THESE REFORMS MUST
INCLUDE GREATER ACCESS TO
INDIVIDUALS AT A LOWER COST
WHICH ALSO INCLUDES FINANCIAL
AID REFORM. AND WE WILL REMOVE
MADE IT TO THE- IS TO BAN AFTER.
PATIENTS ARE OFF TO OFF TO.
I'LL TURN OVER TO CAR JOE WHY
WHO WAS SHARE SOME OF THE PRO.
THAT EXEMPLIFY THIS MESS OF
REACH OUT TO POPPY AND DOING
MORE TO INCREASE IN AND ACCESS
THEM THE OFF TO MARGINALIZED.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME IN
THE IN TO BE HERE PROUD TO COME
DOWN FROM BUT ALL THE SUPER
PART OF CAP FOR FAR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND IN MY HAND TO
YOU CAN SEE A OF BACKGROUND OF
THE- AND THE JUST WE SERVE OVER
TEN THOUSAND MILES TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY TWO AND RATHER. BUT
TWELVE THE. ACCOUNT STUDENTS A
YEAR HE QUIPPED ABOUT THOUSAND
FULL TIME TO. AND COUPLE OF OUR
BIG THAT ARE READ IS ARE A- TWO
FOLD IDEA ATTAIN ABOUT THIRTY
PERCENT OF OUR A HAVE CALLER NO
DEGREE COMPARED ABOUT 22% STATE
WHY. AND THAT CLOSE TO SEE
ISSUES ABOUT FIVE MY SOUTH DOWN
AND SHE- AND ASSIST YOU SEE IS
YOU SEE DAVE ABOUT HER FIFTY SO.
BUT JUST TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF
THE THINGS WE'VE BEEN DOING TO
SERVE OUR OUR AREA BETTER AND
TO BUILD OFF OF WHAT TO MY
COLLEAGUE I SHARED WITH YOU- HI
I HAVE A ONE COLLEGES UPS-
SUMMARIZE FOR YOU UNTIL IN
ROMAN THING YOU CAN SEE THE
GROWTH IN THIS PROGRAM. ALSO IN
OF A- BIRD. WE WERE THAN TWENTY
FIFTEEN IS HELP SUPPORT THE
GROWTH OF THIS PROGRAM. BUT FOR
OUR REGION- WE'VE GONE TO OVER.
THREE THOUSAND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS NOW DO OWN ROLLED IN
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
TAKING FIFTY EIGHT HUNDRED PLUS
COURSES THROUGHOUT THE YEAR-
GIVING THEM A HEAD START IN. A
AND NOT COLLEGE- YOU CAN SEE
THE CHART ON HOW MANY SECTIONS-
WE HAVE BEEN OFFERING. THE
GREAT PART OF HIS PROGRAM AS I
LOOK AT IT IS UP 299% DISTANCE
THROUGH THE VERY FEW STUDENTS
DROP. OF THESE COURSES AND
INTERVIEW THAT TO OUR GREAT
INSTRUCTION AND IN THE TORY
HIGH SCHOOL ATTENDANCE POLICIES.
AND THEN- OVERNIGHT 2% ARE ARE
HAVING SUCCESS IN THEIR COURSES
SO FAR- OVER THAT FIVE YEAR
TIME PERIOD. AND THAT COMPARES
TO AROUND SEVENTY FOUR PERCENT.
OF COLLEGE WIDE OR SUCCESS
RATES- AND SO THAT'S A PRETTY
HIGH. RATE EMPHASIZING LIMIT
MORE ABOUT THE OF PROMISE
PRORAMS AND THE INCREASE-
WE'VE SEEN THERE AND STUDENT
PARTICIPATION- WE START IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN DOING
A LOT OF WORK TO AUTOMATE
FINANCIALLY PROCESSING. MEETING
IN HAND HAND THE WORK AND YOU
CAN SEE WE'VE HAD A- OVER A
COUPLE YEAR PERIOD OF FIVE
POINT 6% INCREASE IN PELL
GRANT. STUDENTS IN ORDER
PROGRAM NOT TWENTY THREE PLUS
PERCENT INCREASE IN CALIFORNIA
PROMISE GRANTS INS- FORMALLY
THE BUG FOR. PROGRAM AND WE
ATTRIBUTE THAT TO OUR COULD
WORK OF OUR FINANCIALLY STAFF
AUTOMATING PROCESSES MAKING IT
EASIER FOR STUDENTS. QUICKLY
HIGHLIGHTING- AND IN THAT SAME
TIME PERIOD ARM ROMAN HAS
REMAINED RELATIVELY FLAT SO
IT'S NOT A GROWTH IN NUMBER OF
STUDENTS- IT'S JUST GETTING
MORE THAN THEIR AID THIRD.
HIGHLIGHT OUR- PROGRAM WE CALL
STEP UP WHICH STANDS FOR SHASTA
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAM
UNITED PARTNERSHIP. LONG NAME-
BUT WE STARTED IN THAT TWENTY
FOUR FIFTEEN WITH A SMALL
PROGRAM. AND THROUGH
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE SHERIFF
AND PROBATION AND SHASTA COUNTY
NOW WE'VE EXPANDED OTHER
PARTNERS LISTED THERE IN YOUR
HAND OUT. WE'VE EXPANDED NOW
TO- HAVING A HUNDRED SIXTY SIX-
FORMAL INCARCERATED STUDENTS IN
THIS PROGRAM- SUCCESS RATES ARE
VERY CLOSE TO OUR DISTRICT WIDE
SUCCESS RATES- AND THE BIG
THING- THAT I'M REALLY PLEASED
TO REPORT ON IS THE RECIDIVISM
RATES IN THE STUDENTS WE- NOW
OVER THROUGH. DESPITE IN THIS.
PRO AND A FIFTY ONE. HAVE
BACKSLIDING I GUESS ALL SAYING
AND OTHERS ONLY THIRTEEN POINT%
4% RECIDIVISM RATE WHICH IS
MUCH LOWER THAN WHAT I'M TOLD-
THE TYPICALLY IS FOR US
STUDENTS IN THIS LIFE SCENARIO.
THE THIS IS A- TO EXPAND THIS
BECAUSE OF ANOTHER INNOVATION
AWARD WE RECEIVED- IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SO- HAVING THAT
SPECIAL FUNDING TO PROVIDE THE
EXTRA SUPPORT THE STUDENTS NEED
TO SPEND A KEY PART OF. OUR
ABILITY TO EXPAND. OUR FOURTH
PROGRAM I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT BRIEFLY IS WE CALL OF
XCELERATED COLLEGE EDUCATION OR
ACE UP ITS CHEST THE COLLEGE.
WE BUILT THIS PROGRAM OUT OF
OUR TWENTY FIFTEEN INNOVATION
AWARD MONIES TO IN IN THIS
EFFORT. AND ACTION YEAH GOT A
TWENTY SEVENTEEN INNOVATION
AWARD. BASED ON THIS SO- KIND
OF FUN TO- TO SEE THAT TO BUILD
ON ITSELF- THE MAIN IDEA HERE
IS A REALLY STRONG GUIDED
PATHWAYS FOR RETURNING ADULTS
LET'S INVITE THEM BACK TO
FINISH THEIR DEGREES BUT NOT TO
THE EXACT SAME EXPERIENCE THEY
HAD. THAT LET PERHAPS LEAVING-
ATTEMPT SO THESE ARE ALL SET UP
TUESDAY THURSDAY IN COURSES
SOME ONLINE COURSES EIGHT WEEK
SESSIONS SO EIGHT WEEK AND FALL
OFF NAY WE GOT YOUR BERMAN WITH
FOR. HIS TWENTY SIX. COURSE
GRADES OVER THE FIRST TWO TWO
AND A HALF YEAR PERIOD AND
THIRTEEN HUNDRED OF THOSE CRAZY
LATELY WERE STUDENTS IN THE ACE
PROGRAM GETTING THE EXTRA
SUPPORT AND BECAUSE WE'RE OPEN
AT THE OTHER HALF PEOPLE JUST
IN. FOR THAT. YOU ME EXT. SEE
MY REVIEW. NINE PERCENT- COURSE
EXCEPT IN THESE COURSES AND FOR
THE BASIC PART OF THIS AND THEN
FOR THE OTHER TWO JUST
HAPPENSTANCE HAPPENED WHEN ROLL
SEVENTY NINE SO- WE ATTRIBUTE
THAT TO THE ORDER. IT'S EVENT
IS. AND YOUR OWN NEEDING THREE
MORE WEEKS COMPLETE A CLASS
RATHER THAN SAY TWELVE YOU'RE
MORE LIKELY TO STICK IT THROUGH
RATHER THAN THAT GIVE UP.
THAT'S ANECDOTAL NOT STUDY ONLY
AT. FROM THE STORIES THE
STUDENTS TELL US THAT WHAT
APPEARS TO BE HAPPENING FIFTH
ITEM ON THE BACK PAGE- JUST
WANTED TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT
OF OUR GROWTH AN ONBOARDING
DEGREES AND- PLEASE THE SHOW.
IF WE WENT EVEN FURTHER A. B.
EVEN. PRESS BUT- YES- AN
INCREASE IN DEGREES BEING
AWARDED. THANKSGIVING AT T. AND
I. WHAT I DIDN'T ADD IN HERE IS
A NEW EFFORT WE STARTED IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WERE COLD.
ABOUT A FIVE PERIOD AND FOUND
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
STUDENTS- WHO HAD SIXTY PLUS
UNITS BUT WERE AWARDED THE
DEGREE. AND WE WENT BACK AND
READ WAITED THEM AND FOUND TO
LEARN THIRTY PLUS OF THEM HAD A
DEGREE THEY JUST NEVER APPLIED
FOR IT. SO IT'S KIND OF. IRONIC
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT
EVERYONE KNOWS TO APPLY TO
COLLEGE. WE HAVE THESE INTERNAL.
BOTHER WITH IT BECAUSE THEY'RE
TRANSFERRING OR WHAT HAVE YOU
AND SO- WE'RE GOING BACK IN
AWARDING THEM THEIR DEGREES
THAT THEY'VE ALREADY EARNED
PROGRAM DEGREES WHEN. FOR A-
AND NOW IT TAKES TO MORSE USING
UC'S THROUGHOUT THE STATE
FINALLY- PARTNERING WITH
INDUSTRY A YOU HAVE A
NEWSLETTER HAND OUT HERE- A
PROGRAM I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT-
BECAUSE OF THE INVESTMENT- THE
STATE IS MAKING AND- ADDRESSING
FORCE MANAGEMENT AND THE
OVERGROWTH IN. VARIOUS AREAS OF
THE STATE- WE'VE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL LANDING NOW- A SUB
GRANTS AND THEN A DIRECT GRANT
UP TOTALING FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO PURCHASE EQUIPMENT
HIRE ADDITIONAL FACULTY- AND-
SUPPORT. EXPANDING OUR
EQUIPMENT GRAHAM INTO- AGS FOR
HEAVY EQUIPMENT. INTO A LOGGING
CERTIFICATE AND BUILDING IN OUR
MENTAL. FOR FROM SPREADING AS
AS- QUICKLY AND HEAVILY. TIED
TO THIS WAS OUR- WORDINGOF A
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR A
STATE GRANT THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA APPRENTICESHIP
INITIATIVE FOR NONTRADITIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS WHERE WERE ABLE
TO- GIVE STUDENTS OF THE
PRACTICAL MORE STUDENTS THE
PRACTICAL EXPERIENCE ACTUALLY.
PAID EXPERIENCE ON THE HEAVY
EQUIPMENT WERE PART PARTNERSHIP
WITH THIS PROGRAM. SO WE'RE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS PROGRAM
WHAT IT MEANS FOR OUR REGION
ESPECIALLY AFTER THOSE
DEVASTATING. FINAL NOTES JUST
MENTIONING- WHERE WE'RE GOING
NEXT TO TRY TO CONTINUE TO
EXPAND- OUR PILOT PARTICIPATION
IN THE BACCALAUREATE-
CALIFORNIA CAL'S BACCALAUREATE
DEGREE IS WERE EXCITED ABOUT- I
SEE THAT AS A POTENTIAL WAY
PROVIDING ACCESS TO MORE
BACCALAUREATE SHOULD WE GET.
EXPAND BUILD REALLY WRONG
PROTECT PROGRAMS IN OUR- ARE-
APPLIED BACCALAUREATE APPROACH
TO UP TO MEET INDUSTRY NEEDS IF
ALLOWED. AND THEN. ALSO WERE-
IN PROCESS FOR DEVELOPING MORE
COMPETENCY BASED OR A CREDIT
FOR PRIOR LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS TO
HELP THEM. GAIN SOME FOR LIKE
FOR EXAMPLE IN THE MILITARY
WHEN THEY HAVE THE BACKGROUND
OF ALL THE TRAINING THEIR
RECOGNIZING THAT CREDIT MORE
READILY- OR DEGREES AT AND WHEN
THEY COME TO US. SO THERE'S A
COUPLE THINGS AND I WOULD BE
RUDE NOT TO MENTION I'M SURE
REDDING WELCOME IN A PENSIONS
FROM YOU SEE YOUR SEATS YOU.
AND THAT'S- WHAT I HAVE FOR YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MR GALLAGHER. YEAH I MEAN JUST
A LOT THERE AND I MEAN SO MANY
DIFFERENT THINGS THERE THAT I
THINK. VERY PROMISING THAT WERE
SEEN AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM AND I THINK YOU KNOW OF
HE SAW A SNAPSHOT HERE SHASTA
COLLEGE IN SOME I THINK SOME
PRETTY AWESOME THINGS THEY'RE
DOING FROM THE STEP UP PROGRAM-
TO ACES. TO THEIR PARTNERING
WITH INDUSTRY- AND YOU HAVE A
NEWSLETTER HERE THAT TALKS
ABOUT SOME PARTNER IN THEIR
DATA SIERRA PACIFIC. INDUSTRIES
AND ALSO THEIR HEAVY EQUIPMENT
OPERATION PROGRAM- SO I JUST
WANT TO BE A REALLY
CONGRATULATE YOU ON THE WORK
THAT YOU GUYS HAVE DONE YOU
KNOW AT SHASTA. YOUR HIGHLIGHTS
SIR TRUCKING A TRUCKING
OBVIOUSLY A BIG A STILL VERY
MUCH A BIG EMPLOYMENT SECTOR
AND AT THE TO HIM THE CAMPUS I
KNOW THAT SOMETHING YOU GUYS OF.
HAVE FOCUSED ON. YOU KNOW AS WE
DISCUSS THE PANELS HERE AT YOU
KNOW AT. MORE MORE I SEE
ACCESS. THAT THE ANSWERED
ACCESS IS THAT THE CSU AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL AND
EXPANDING IS PROGRAMS AT THEIR
DEEP I THINK WE CONTINUE TO BE
DISAPPOINTED BY A WHAT'S GOING
ON AT THE UC LEVEL. AND WE'VE
SEEN THE PROGRESS THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE MAKING.
ARE PAYING MUCH MORE FOR- WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND WITH THE
CSU SYSTEM IN PARTICULAR IS AT
T. L. ONE HIGHLIGHT THAT AGAIN
THE AT T. IS A SEEM TO BE.
WORKING PRETTY WELL I THINK YOU
BY THE OME OF THESE I KNOW
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE. PATHWAYS IN
CHEMISTRY AND PHYSICS BUT
THERE'S OTHER DISCIPLINES RIGHT
NOW THAT YOUR SUPPORT YOUR
LOOKS POINT ALIGNMENT WITH- DO
YOU MAYBE WANT TO TALK ABOUT
SOME OF THOSE AND PARTICULARLY.
I THINK WHERE WE FOCUS ON THE
WORK FORCE WHERE WE HAD THE
DEMAND FOR WORK FORCE EDUCATION.
WHERE WE CAN HIGHLIGHTED WHERE
SOME OF THOSE REGIONAL TRENDS
HERE RECENTLY ONE JUST THAT DAY
COMES TO MIND FOR ME IS WE KNOW
WE NEED TO GET INTO OUR FORCE
YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT FORESTRY MANAGEMENT. BUT
TREE TRIMMING AND- ARBORISTS
THAT WE THEY WERE GONNA NEED TO
HELP CLEAR UTILITY LINES-
ENSURING THE SAFETY OF OUR OF
OUR GRID. I KNOW BUTTE COLLEGES
HAS BEEN SENT ONE BEEN
INTERESTED IN TRYING TO SET UP
A PROGRAM AND THAT RESPECT ANY
A LOT OF PEOPLE TO IN THE- IN
THE- FOR BUT MAYBE IF YOU
HIGHLIGHTED OF. THINGS WERE
YOUR YOU. THE C. THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS TRYING TO. FIND THOSE
PATHWAYS WITH THIS WITH THE
EIGHTIES. WELL I'LL I'LL
BRIEFLY MENTION WE HAVE NOW
OVER TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO TO
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY TEAS-
APPROVED THROUGH OUR PROCESSES
SO THERE ARE. MANY OF THOSE
FIELDS LIKE PHYSICS MATH.
PSYCHOLOGY AND MANY OTHERS- AND
SO- AND THEN THE ON THE WORK
FOR SIDE MY THOUGHTS AND I'M
GOING TO THE STRONG FORCE
INVEST THE STATE'S BEEN MAKING
AND COMMITTEE COLLEGE TO THEM
AND HOW- HELPFUL THAT'S BEEN-
FOR OUR COLLEGE TO IT- DO MORE
AND DO. CRITICS TRAINING SO.
IT'LL OF FOUNDING A- OUR SYSTEM
PROGRAM- AND- WE'VE EXPANDED.
WORK IN THE HEAVY EQUIPMENT
THAT'S BEEN A GOOD PARTNERSHIP
WITH THESE OTHER GRANTS WE PAD-
TO EXPAND OFFERINGS THERE- AND
MANY OTHER FIELDS IN CREEK
TECHNICAL EDUCATION THE SPORT
OUR ADVANCED MANUFACTURING
PROGRAM- IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
INDUSTRY TO TRY TO MEET THE
NEEDS- OUR LOCAL INDUSTRY-
SORTS OF- ARE BUILDING EACH
OTHER- IF YOU WANNA ADD MORE.
YES AND THANK YOU. SOUND LIKE
CHESTER WE'RE SEEING A LOT OF
OUR COLLEGES DO- GREAT WORK
REALLY FOCUSING THEIR PROGRAMS
ON THE NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITIES
AND REGIONALLY ADOPTED- WITH
REGARDS TO EIGHTY TEASE OUT
SOME CHANGES MADE- THAT ARE
ENABLING. MORE AND PATHWAY
APPROACHES ARE ONE- THAT HAD SB
FOUR FORTY WHICH ALLOWED
CAREERS AND- DEGREE CLUSTERS
WHICH MAKE THESE TRANSFER
PATHWAYS MORE ADAPTIVE TO WHAT
MIGHT BE NEEDED I THINK WE'RE
WE'RE STILL FINDING IS THAT-
WHILE THAT'S BEEN HELPFUL- ARE
STRONG WORKFORCE PROBABLY BEEN
MORE RESPONSIVE TO THOSE CUTE
OF WORK FOR. A PROGRAMS THAT
ARE NEEDED IN REGIONS
PARTICULARLY LIKE SHASTA
PROGRAMS LIKE THAT- THE
CALIFORNIA- AT A PRACTICE
SHOULD THEY SHOULD IS FOCUSING
ON NEW AND EMERGING INDUSTRIES-
IT PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY AND
THAT'S AREAS THAT HAS. FOR
ADDITIONAL INVEST IN THAT
BUDGET. SO THOSE ARE OF THE
SPACES WHERE WE'RE SEEING-
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY ADAPT TO
WORKFORCE NEEDS. OKAY THANK YOU.
THIS MUST THE PRESENTATION BUT
SHOW BECAUSE I READ WITH GREAT
I KNOW WHAT I GO BACK TO WATCH
THE VIDEO. OKAY THANK YOU. TO
OUR NEXT PANEL THIS IS. WITH
THE ROLE OF OUR PRIVATE NON
PROFITS IN INCREASING
CALIFORNIA ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION. A GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE TODAY MY NAME'S ALEX
GRAVES- BEHALF OF THE ICC YOU
WHICH REPRESENTS EIGHTY FIVE
INDEPENDENT. NONPROFIT COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES ACROSS THE
STATE WERE AS FAR NORTH AS
READING AS FAR SOUTH AS SAN
DIEGO WE HAVE A BRICK AND
MORTAR INSTITUTIONS ONLINE
PROGRAMS HYBRID PROGRAMS
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN.
COLLECTIVELY WE EDUCATE A
HUNDRED NINETY NINE THOUSAND
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS. OVER
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND OF THOSE
UNDERGRADUATES ARE CAL GRANT
RECIPIENTS AND WE ALSO EDUCATE
OVER TWENTY ONE THOUSAND ADULT
LEARNERS- AS OF OUR LAST
CAPACITY SURVEY A FEW YEARS
AGO. WE ESTIMATE THAT OUR
INSTITUTIONS WERE OPERATING AT
ABOUT 86% CAPACITY WITH AN
ABILITY TO SERVE AN ADDITIONAL
FOURTEEN THOUSAND.
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS. AND I
JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY TOUCH ON
THREE POINTS BEFORE TURNING IT
OVER TO PRESIDENT JOHNSTON MY
RIGHT. FIRST IS THE COLLEGE
FUTURES FOUNDATION REPORT NOTES
AVAILABILITY OF HIGHER
EDUCATION CLOSE TO HOME MAKES
COLLEGE GOING MORE ACCESSIBLE
ESPECIALLY FOR UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS. AND WITH EIGHT FIVE
INSTITUTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WE BELIEVE OUR SECTORS
WELL POSITIONED TO OFFER
STUDENTS THE ABILITY TO STAY
CLOSE TO HOME. WHETHER THE
ANNUAL STRAIGHT OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL WELL THROUGH A TRANSFER
PATHWAY. OR READ HIGHER. IN THE
DES. IN OUR INSTITUTE OFF
NUMBER TRANSFER PATHWAYS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
LAST YEAR WE ENROLLED OVER
SEVEN THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
NEW CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TRANSFER STUDENTS. IN
JULY TWENTY EIGHTEEN A I SEE
SEE YOU PRESIDENT KRISTIN
SOURIS AND CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR YOU LIGHT
ORTIZ OAKLEY. SIGNED THE MASTER
AND- YOU FOR THE ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER OR AT T.
JUST A FEW MONTHS LATER THIRTY
OF OUR INSTITUTIONS BEGAN
ACCEPTING AT T. APPLICANTS TO
ARTICULATED PATHWAYS. AND AS OF
THIS PAST FALL THIRTY NINE
INSTITUTIONS ARE ACCEPTING- AT
T. TRANSFERS. WELL THESE
PATHWAYS ARE STILL RELATIVELY
NEW THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT IN
OUR REVIEW OF STUDENT MOVEMENT-
WE FIND THAT MANY STUDENTS ARE
APPLYING TO A ICC INSTITUTIONS
CLOSE TO THE COMMITTEE CALLED
FROM WHICH THEY RECEIVE THEIR
AT T. INDICATING THAT THE- P.
IS. WRITING REGIONAL ENTITIES
FORCED TO CAN YOU THE CRASH
TOWARDS ABOUT HIS DEGREE I AND
ONE OF THE HAVE NOTS IN YOUR
FOLDERS SHOWS THAT STICK
MOVEMENT FOR PRESENT PACIFIC
UNIVERSE THE- AT. PAPER FROM.
BEST PERSON. INSISTS THAT OUR
INSTITUTIONS. PER THEM IS AN
AFFORDABLE OUR INSTITUTIONS DO
A TREMENDOUS JOB OF PROVIDING
ROBUST AID I PROVIDING ON
AVERAGE OF OVER TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR AND
INSTITUTIONAL GRANT AID TO A
CAL GRANT RECIPIENT. PROVIDE
TIMELY POUTS HE'S OUT WITH 64%
OF CAL GRANT STUDENTS
GRADUATING IN FOUR YEARS AT A
RELATIVELY LOW COST TO THE
STATE. I AND I WOULD NOTE THAT
THE ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
AROUND CAL GRANT REFORM ARE
IMPORTANT AND MANY ASPECTS OF
THAT WAS- PROPOSALS BEING
CONSIDERED WOULD BOTH EXPAND
ACCESS. ADDITIONAL STUDENTS AND
INCREASE THE AMOUNT AID THEY
RECEIVED- FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
FURTHER LEVERAGING THE CAPACITY
AT OUR INSTITUTION THROUGHOUT
THE STATE REFER. POLICY IN IT
THE CALPERS FOR STUDENTS ATTEND
OUR INSTITUTIONS IS NOT SUBJECT
TO DISCUSS BUDGET THAT'S AN
ANTI AS IT IS THING LAW. I DID
THE STATE COULD FURTHER BUYS
THE REGIONAL CAPACITY OUR
INSTITUTIONS BY SIMPLIFYING
OTHER COMPONENTS OF THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM. TO SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES BE I WON THE STATE AS
OF LAST YEAR PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL ALL CAL GRANT
SUPPORT TO. AS STUDENTS WITH
DEPENDENT CHILDREN BUT ONLY IF
THEY ARE AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
YOU SEE YOUR CSU. I AND WE
BELIEVE THAT MAKING THAT
ADDITIONAL AID AVAILABLE TO CAL
RECIPIENTS AT OUR INSTITUTIONS
WHILE THEM. ACCESS THE
INSTITUTIONS IN THEIR REGION AS
THEY LOOK CAN YOU THEIR POWER.
DEGREE ALSO WHERE THERE IS
MENTION SUMMER CALGARY WE DO
HAVE A NUMBER OF A DEEPER
SUMMER. BUT LIKE THE STUDENT
PARENT ISSUE- THAT FUNDING WAS
ONLY MADE AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS
ATTENDING YOU SEE YOUR CSU. AND
WE BELIEVE THAT CAN HELP
INCREASE EFFICIENCIES HELP
STUDENTS GET TOWARD THEIR
DEGREE. MORE QUICKLY- WHICH THE
STATE ANY AN- ADDITIONAL SPACE
FOR ADDITIONAL STUDENTS. WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN OVER TO
JOE JONES PRESIDENT OF FRESNO
PACIFIC CARE AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF A I SEE
SEE- YOU MEMBERS- INSTITUTIONS
FRESNO PACIFIC UNIVERSITY IS
HERE TO REPRESENT THE STRESS OF
PUBLIC AND INDEPENDENT NON
PROFIT COLLEGE UNIVERSITIES
PARTNERSHIPS. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I UNDERSTAND ONCE
SAID THAT WE CANNOT SOLVE ALL
PROBLEMS WITH THE SAME THINKING
WE USE- WHEN WE CREATED THEM.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DECIDED
TO BUILD A EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM
THAT WOULD PROVIDE SOME OF THE
BEST EDUCATION IN THE WORLD.
THEY SUCCEEDED IN BEING E. UC'S
I SEE ISSUES AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM. IT'S NOT A FIRM
THE VALUE INDEPENDENT A
UNIVERSITIES AND- COLLEGE
SECTOR BUT DID NOT INCLUDE THEM
IN THE ORIGINAL PLAN OF A THREE
LIKE IT'S TO TESTING OF. ALL
ONLY THE PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES.
OFF I FIND THAT WE OFTEN FORGET
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE EIGHTY
FIVE. PLUS PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS
AS A MAJOR THREAT AND A
APPROACH TO EMPOWERING
CALIFORNIA. WE UNDERSTAND THAT
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT IT IS A
KEY ELEMENT IN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. BUT SELDOM
RECOGNIZE THAT THESE
INSTITUTIONS SERVE AS A FOURTH
LAKE TWO OF THIS TOO IN THIS
EDUCATIONAL STRATEGY FOR THE
STATE. WE SOME HOW FORGET THAT
THE INDEPENDENCE PRODUCED
TWENTY PERCENT. OF THE
BACHELORS DEGREES IN THE STATE
AND OVER 50% OF THE GRADUATE
DEGREES. AND A DISPLAY I
DESPITE PREVIOUS OR REDUCTIONS
IN CALGARY IT'S A FOR OUR
STUDENTS WHO CHOSE TO ATTEND
THESE INSTITUTIONS STILL
PROVIDE THE HIGHEST GRADUATION
RATES IT IN THE LAST STEP SOME
OF THE HIGHEST RATE GRAY
PATIENT RAKES IN STATE. OF
THESE A PRE PRODUCTION IN
ASSISTANT DID NOT KEEP US. DID
NOT PREVENT FROM OF. THEIR
SUCCESS. MY TODAY IF THE
BROUGHT THE STRAT FOR COME FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. THAT
REQUIRES SHIFTING OUR
PERSPECTIVE- AND IN TERMS OF
FUNDING JUST THE THREE LIKE
IT'S TOO BUT THINKING ABOUT I
FOR LAKE IT'S TOO. YOU HAVE
ENCOURAGED TO TD PARTNERSHIPS
WITH SCHOOL DISTRICT TO BETTER
PREPARE OUR FUTURE GENERATIONS
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION. WITHIN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE WE'RE
LOCATED. BEATS AIMS ARE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY. WHICH TODAY HAVE
RESULTED IN K. THROUGH A
SIXTEEN COLLABORATIONS AND
PARTNERSHIPS WITH FULL PUBLIC
PRIVATE. OCCASIONALLY S. SINCE.
OUR FOCUS MOVES BEYOND JUST
THINKING ABOUT THE IN VISUAL
INSTITUTIONS BUT OUR TARGET ON
THE NEEDS OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. CAL GRANT NOT- OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS IT IS A THAT
BROUGHT AND STAY OPTIONS FOR
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS. WE HAVE
CREATED GUIDED PATHWAYS TO HIGH
SCHOOL WITH A INTO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND FOUR YEAR SCHOOLS.
A IN THIS ECONOMICALLY
CHALLENGE YOU CAN REGION WE ARE
TURNING AWAY THOUSANDS OF
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS FROM FOUR
YEAR INSTITUTIONS BECAUSE WE
NOW LACK THE CAPACITY TO SERVE
THEM IN A TIMELY MANNER. SB YOU
FRESNO PACIFIC BILL PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR REGIONAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SEE ISSUES AND YOU SEE
MERCED. WE ESTABLISHED TRANSFER
PATHWAYS AROUND THE ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR A TRANSFER WITH THE
ELEVEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
VISITING MANY OF THOSE CAMPUSES
AND AN ENROLLMENT EXPRESS.
EVENT WHICH ALLOW STUDENTS TO-
INTERESTED IN TRANSFERRING TO
REGISTER FOR CLASS RECEIVE
FINANCIAL AID AND MEET WITH AN
AXE GIVE US ALL ALL IT SINGLE
AND- ONLY TAKING A COUPLE
HOURS. OF THE TWENTY ONE EVENTS
HI A LAST YEAR- WE ACTUALLY
HOSTED FEES THAT ELEVEN
DIFFERENT COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WHICH A TOTAL OF FOUR HUNDRED
AND ANY TRANSFER STUDENTS TO
OUR UNIVERSITY. WE ALSO
COLLABORATE WITH- FRESNO STATE
TO FIND WAYS TO COMMUNICATE
ADDITIONAL OPTIONS FOR LOCAL
RESIDENTS IN THE VALLEY WHO
WANTED A FOUR YEAR DEGREE- WHO
WERE ELIGIBLE FOR ACCEPTANCE
BUT TURNED AWAY BECAUSE OF DUE
TO IMPACTION. WE BUILD A
PARTNERSHIP WITH YOU SEE SAID
TO CREATE A STREAMLINED
XCELERATED PRO. TO TRANSITION
BEST STUDENTS INTO OUR TEACHER
CREDENTIALING PROGRAM. WE HAVE
SHARED SPACE WITH BAKERSFIELD
COPS AND FRESNO CITY COLLEGE TO
ACCOMMODATE THEIR GROWTH AND
SPACE NEEDS AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH REAL
COLLEGE. I TOO LOST BIG PATH
THAT'S WITH PROGRAM. CAMPUS
FIVE GREEN AS A WITH THE EIGHTY
T. VISIT NOT A CHEAP REPRESENT
THE QUALITY OF EDUCATION
AVAILABLE THROUGH A PRIVATE
INSTITUTION COMMITTED TO THE
WELL BEING OF STUDENTS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. AS I SUGGESTED
EARLIER IN QUOTING ALBERT
EINSTEIN WE CANNOT SOLVE OUR
PROBLEMS WITH THE SAME THINKING
WE USED WHEN WE CREATED THEM
THE FOR THE FOUR YEAR
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITY STILL. AN OPTION FOR.
IMPACTION ISSUE BUDGET AND CAL
GRANT IT NOT BE UP CUTTING ONE
LEG OF THIS AS WE HAVE IN THE
PAST. BUT TO ALL STUDENTS IF WE
SENT YOU INSTRUCTING THE WELL
BEING OF OUR COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. THANK YOU FOR GIVING
US TIME TO HEAR. QUESTIONS HAVE
A QUESTION I KNOW THAT WE'VE
SEEN YOU QUITE OFF THE LAST FEW
YEARS ON THE ON THE CAL GRANT
ISSUE AND- SEC THAT ISSUES.
CALM DOWN A LITTLE BIT TO YOUR
LIKING AS FAR AS THE MAXIMUM
AWARD FOR PRIVATE CITIZENS AND
WHAT DO YOU THINK NEEDS TO
HAPPEN FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE TO
ALLOW YOU TO FOCUS ON THAT 14%
CAPACITY. ABOUT MUCH OF THE
PERSON. YOU KNOW THE
OPPORTUNITY SIR FOURTEEN
THOUSAND MORE CALIFORNIANS. BUT
WHAT I THINK OF THE PRIVATE-
BASICALLY DO HAVE BUT-
OPPORTUNITY AND ABILITY TO IT-
TO EXPAND- ACT. AND I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS FOR OUR FOR US AS
WE LOOK IN TERMS OF SINCE WE'VE
A MOST OF US I CAN ACTUALLY DO
THIS- FAIRLY QUICKLY A REAL
CHALLENGE IS ACTUALLY A
COMMUNICATING THAT BUILDING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. HI AND OF
THE EXAMPLES I CAN GET IF YOU
WE HAVE THESE MEETINGS WITH
CHAPLAINS AND PRESIDENT CENTRAL
POINT ROUTE THE REASON WHY
WE'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN IN A
MIXED. AND ALL WELL I. TO THIS.
BECAUSE OF THAT AFTER WOULD
COST THE FOR TO THESE CA
COLLEGES IN THE STAFF TO
ACTUALLY GIVE WHAT WOULD AND
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO START AT
THE SAME MOMENT X. EXPRESS BUT
AS WE ARE ABLE TO OFFER GRANTS
WE EXPECT. A QUITE YET GET THAT
BUT WHAT WHAT ELSE DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING AS A STATE I KNOW THAT
ANYBODY CAN APPLY FOR CAL GRANT
AND THAT THEY CAN TAKE THAT
WHERE THEY WANT TO GO WHEN YOU
SEE A CSU OR OF YOU APPEAR IN
SAINT MARY'S COLLEGE I GET THAT
SO ANYTHING ELSE THAT. FROM QUE.
DAHLE FROM YOUR- WELL I. IF YOU
GET A CLEARLY THAT THE ARE AN
OPTION- AND A PART OF THE
STRATEGY TO PROVIDE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOSTER OUR
STUDENTS HOW DO WE ACTUALLY- AS
THE COMMUNITY AT THE AT THE
STATE LEGISLATING A- MARKET AND
COMMUNICATE THAT TO OUR
STUDENTS AND TO. A THE COMMERCE
IN WE ALL I'M KIND OF THE WHOLE
HOLD MY HAND UP IS HOLED UP
REMEMBER THE PRIVATES REMEMBER
THE PRIVATE. AND SO OUR
STUDENTS AREN'T GETTING THE
MESSAGE UNLESS WE ACTUALLY GET
OUT AND SO ON OUTSIDE THE
PROVINCE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
COMMUNICATE THAT I THINK ON THE
PUBLIC SIDE. OF THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE ALSO SOUGHT I THINK IS
A IT WOULD COME AT LEAST AB
TEASE BANDEAU. WHY CAN WE ARE
TO THE MA MORE. TEARS UP THE
OBVIOUS I. TO THIS OKAY THANK
YOU. I WOULD JUST I THINK YOU
KNOW THE EXAMPLE OF FRESNO
PACIFIC'S PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THEIR LOCAL PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
AS WELL AS THE PARTNERSHIP THE
REP. EARLIER BETWEEN UC
BERKELEY. AND MILLS CALL PAGE.
BOTH OF THOSE EFFORTS WERE
REALLY. I THINK FIRST AND
FOREMOST BORN OUT OF- JUST A
PARTNERSHIP ENTER. LEVEL
INSTITUTIONAL LEADERS BUT I
THINK THAT WHAT THOSE DO YOU
PROVIDE A GLIMPSE OF OUR PROP
PRACTICES THAT COULD BE
REPLICATED IN OTHER. REGIONS OF
THE STATE THAT I NEED AREAS
LIKE THE INLAND EMPIRE. AND
WILL CERTAINLY- IS PRIVATE.
INSTITUTIONS YOU CAN'T. RISK
WRECKED EIGHT. ARE FROM YOU
KNOW FOR SCALING THE UP THERE
ARE MY IS MY UNDERSTANDING
LEASE THERE ARE WAYS THROUGH
OPR AND OTHERS TO PER MAKE SOME
FUNDS AVAILABLE ON A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS
WHEREBY OUR INSTITUTIONS ARE
ELIGIBLE TO APPLY. TO REPLICATE
SUMMIT PROMISED PRACTICES MMHM.
OKAY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION. THAT
CONCLUDES THE- FIVE PANELS ARE
FOUR PANELS PLUS OUR- OUR OUR
KEYNOTE SPEAKER FROM THAT
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
FEATURES FOUNDATION SO WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS NOT SURE HOW
MANY PEOPLE WANT TO PARTICIPATE
PUBLIC COMMENT BUT PLEASE. TO
THE TO THE CENTER. DIRECT YOUR
COMMENTS THE MICROPHONE AND
PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO
ONE MINUTE OR LESS SIXTY
SECONDS OR LESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR SURELY ZERO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LIKE OF
CALIFORNIA THANKS FOR HOLDING
THE HEARING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON CAL GRANT
MODERNIZATION. COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AS YOU'RE HAVE THE
LARGEST PERCENT. AND THE
LARGEST NUMBER OF STE- LOW
INCOME AND STUDENTS OF COLOR WE
ALSO HAVE THE GREATEST
CAPACITY. WE KNOW THE ECONOMY
HAS CHANGED RADICALLY IN THE
LAST JUST FEW WEEKS. AS WE COME
TOWARD MAY WE WOULD ASK THAT
YOU WOULD REMEMBER THAT. IF YOU
HAVE DOLLARS WE WOULD ASK THAT
YOU REMEMBER THAT EVEN WITH THE
TWO POINT 29% COLA. A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MILLION IS TO
PENSION OBLIGATIONS OF THAT
HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN MILLION OUT
WE WOULD ALSO ASK THAT YOU TAKE
A GOOD LOOK AT SENATOR HILLS
BILL ON OUR OUR THE BACHELOR
DEGREE AND EXPAND ALSO WILL
EXPAND CAPACITY. I AND AT THE
END OF THE DAY IT'S THE
OPERATING DOLLARS SO THAT WE
CAN INVEST IN STUDENT SUCCESS
AND THE XIN THAT WILL BE THE
MOST. THANK YOU THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. CHERUB MCCARTY AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME SECOND THEY DON'T I'M
COULD YOU STERN AT AT UC
RIVERSIDE. I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE UC. ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT OF UC'S STATE PROGRAMS
WHICH ARE STUDENT ACADEMIC
PREPARATION AND EDUCATIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS. I STRONGLY URGE
THIS COMMITTEE THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR TO
SUPPORT FUNDING FOR THE-
STUDENT SERVICES IN THE STATE.
THIS YEAR. LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN
HAPPENING THE EXPANSION VERNAL
MATTHEW C. BUT A LACK OF
SUPPORT. FOR STATE PROGRAMS
PUTS UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENT
COMMUNITIES AT RISK OF CALL THE
ACCESSIBILITY THROUGH A YOU SEE
EDUCATION. FIRST GENERATION LOW
INCOME TRANSFERS AND SINCE THE
COLOR WILL CONTINUE TO BE LEFT
OUT OF YOU SAID MISSIONS
WITHOUT STRONG SUPPORT FROM THE
STATE FOR FUNDING STATE PET
PROGRAMS. WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT LEGISLATORS ARE CAN MANY
COMMITTED TO INCREASING ACCESS
FOR SEEING GROUPS WERE MOST
UNDERSERVED BY THE IS THE
CURRENT LACK OF INVESTMENT PER
STUDENT IN STATE OF. IS PROOF
THAT WE NEED TO VISIT OUR PRIOR
INCREASE AXE WHILE ALSO A-
PERCY GAPS. ON OUR PURPOSES.
YOU SEE IT IS IN OUR CULTURE
CAN HAVE ADVOCATE FOR THESE
CRITICAL AND SUPPORT FOR NEARLY
TWO YEARS WITH THE SUPPORT OF
YOUTH ALL IT OF. IN THE U. S.
BEHIND OUR- I. JUST EIGHTY THE
STATE AND GOT FOR TWENTY THREE
MILLION AN ONGOING FOR STATE A
PROGRAM TO IN. DIVER THAT WILL
REFLECT COLOR. POPULATION AND
OPEN ACCESS FOR RESIDENT
STUDENTS. TO ATTEND YOU SEE
THIS PROPOSAL IS ALSO PART OF A
LARGER COLLEGE BUT IN THIS
BLOCK GRANT ASKED THAT HAS THE
SUPPORT OF THE COLLEGE FOR ALL.
BULLISH EIGHTY CAUCUS. WE HOPE
TO COUNT ON YOUR SUPPORT AS
WELL THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
TIME RIGHT THERE BUT SAID KEEP
EVERYBODY ELSE FOR ONE MINUTE
OR LESS PLACE. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MCCARTHY AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TERRY
PARK AND I'M A STUDENT AT UC
RIVERSIDE I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION TO OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR FUNNY SAY PROPOSED
IN THE STATE BUDGET. SEVERAL
CONSIST OF FOURTEEN OF A VOTE
THE FOCUS ON RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION OF UNDER THE STARS
COMMUNITIES PARTICULARLY LOW
INCOME FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS OF COLOR FORTY MORE
STABLE CONTINUES TO BE THE
PRIMARY MEANS THAT. DO YOU
THINK THE RIVER AT. GEN. UNDER
DIDN'T. IT PEOPLE WHEN MAYES
THAT INDICATE TO TRY ALL JUST
SOME OF THE STATE PROGRAM THOSE
SO AFRICA AND INVESTING FOR ALL
ACT AS THE MANY OTHER USES
STUDENTS WELL FOCUS ON IN ON AT
UC SERVER FUNDING HAS REMAINED
FLAT TWENTY FIRST THE PER
STUDENT PRESIDENT OF THE
MOMENT. TAKE IT WOULD ISSUE THE
FUNNY FOR THE PROGRAM THERE IS
REAL OF SUPPORT DIVERSE
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC COLLEGES
SINCE PROPOSITION TWO OR NOT
ARE YOU NEVER THE POOR TO OVER
HALF A MINUTE A UT STUDENT
EVERY YEAR ON BEHALF OF THE UP
PRESENT. BUT IN THE COLOR. AND
OF COURSE USE. WE FORTY ACCESS
WOULD I POPULATION BYE BYE.
THREE MILLION ONGOING THE STATE
FOR THE AND FOR A RIP. SO THE
WAY WE CAN ALL OF US IS AT UC
TO THEIR STATE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. I'M GONNA FINING. I JUST
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE HAVE OUR
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN THREE
MINUTES SO WE'RE GONNA AROUND
BUT- WE'LL HAVE TO SHUT DOWN IF
WE KEEP TALKING FOR A MINUTE
AND A HALF SO SIXTY SECONDS OR
LESS PLEASE. OKAY I'M COULD NOT
CHAMBER GUARDIAN AS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ANY OTHER
WE GO AND I AM A STUDENT AT UC
RIVERSIDE. I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE UC'S TWENTY THREE
MILLION BUDGET REQUEST TO FUND
SUPPORT SERVICES TO STUDENT
ACADEMIC. PREPARATORY AND
ACADEMIC PERNICIOUS IS SAY PAT-
SINCE IT DOESN'T EIGHT ALONE
THE STATE BUDGET OF SAFE IT HAS
BEEN REDUCED BY OVER 21% AND
PERSON YOU SEE ENROLLMENT WHICH
INCREASED BY NEARLY 30% AND
OVER SIXTY. TO SIXTY FIVE
STUDENT. CLIENT SAVE UP MONEY
DIRECTLY. SEIZE THE SUPPLY
ADMISSION RATES THAT LIKE THE
ONLY TO ADDRESS THESE GAS AND
FOR MORE I TO OUR RESIDENTS
STUDENTS IS TO AND THAT WE
INVEST IN THESE LOCAL PROGRAMS
IRISH THE STATE TO CONSIDER
SUPPORTING THE UC'S.
ASSOCIATION THEY HAVE FUNDING
TO LEVELS BY PER STUDENT AND
INVEST AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
THREE MILLION AND ONGOING FUNDS
FOR SAFE OF PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU EXCELLENT GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ADAM HOW
TO FEE I'M A- UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS I'M HERE
BEING ON BOTH BEHALF OF BOTH
THE U. S. IN ASSOCIATION I WAS
ON A REGISTERED BODY- I WANNA
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF SAY
THAT BUT I WANTED REST
SOMETHING THAT CAME UP EARLIER.
REGARD ATTENTION IN STATE
STUDENTS. AND INCREASING AND
THE MOMENT NOW. OF THE UC'S
FUNDS ARE LIMITED IN ORDER TO
INCREASE IN STATE RIGHT AT
RECRUITMENT AN INCREASE IN IN
STATE ENROLLMENT- FUNDING
PROGRAMS LIKE SAY THAT- THAT
FOCUS ON RECRUITING AND
RETAINING. DIVERSE VERSED IN
STATE STUDENT BODY AS- OF STATE
STUDENTS AND- THE UC'S OF
FUNDING- THE PROPORTION OF YOU
SEE FUNDING THAT COMES FROM THE
STATE HAS DECREASED
DRAMATICALLY IN THE COURSE OF
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS. IF THE
UC'S IT INCREASES. VERSUS
ENROLLMENT THAT PROGRAMS LIKE
C. BUT HAVE TO BE FUND AND SO
I'D LIKE TO INCLUDE THAT IN THE
IN THE ASSEMBLY. BUDGET IN THE
UPCOMING BUDGET CYCLE THANK YOU.
HELLO MANY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE EDUCATION TRUST WEST-
ONE SUCH A FEW THINGS REGARDING
ENROLLMENT AT A HIGHER AT
SEGMENTS RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE EXPLAINED
ENROLLMENT SLOTS- FOR THE
GROWING NUMBER OF COLLEGE
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
STUDENTS. SPECIFICALLY FOR.
ALLOCATE THESE FUNDS VIA THE
BLOCK BASS RESOURCE GOVERNOR
OUTLINED IN THE IN ITS BUDGET
WE RECOMMEND THAT YOU PROVIDE
MORE TRACK PANTS ON HOW MANY-
HOW MUCH MONEY'S GOING TO THE
U. CCS ROAMING GROWTH ONLY
SLOTS THIS WILL FIND.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE LEGISLATURE
CLEAR THAT FOR THE USE AND-
CALVET RESIDENT STUDENTS AT
ISSUE THE YOU CAN CHECK CAN YOU
TO TREAT. CAMPUS WE'RE DO WHAT
WE AGREED WITH THE CALL FUTURE
FOUNDATION TAKE THIS THAT IT
THIS THE STRESS TO BETTER SERVE
AND MORE EFFICIENTLY SERVE
STUDENTS BUT WE NEED TO ADDRESS
THE INEQUITIES IN ACCESS AS
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE RECENT WILL
HOUSE REPORT WHICH TALK ABOUT-
UNDER REPRESENTATION BY
AMERICAN THAT NEXT I COULD
STUDENTS AND LASTLY WE SUPPORT
YOU AND REINVESTMENT OF READING
THIS BROUGHT BLOCK GROUP THAT
THE FUNDING SAPER OF STATE
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS EDWIN- I'M A UNDERGRADUATE
AT UC SANTA CRUZ. AND I'M WITH
THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION I
JUST WANNA AGAIN HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPORTANCE OF. STATE PROGRAMS
THANK YOU. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M SITTING HERE WITH THE
COUNTY SINICIZATION- WE
APPRECIATE THE NATIONAL
INVESTMENT FROM THE GOVERNOR
BUT THAT LEVEL FUNNY FAILS TO
MEET THAT MANDATORY COSTS OF
THIS OF THE INSTITUTION OF LET
ALONE HELP FUND STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICES. ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE
PARTNERED WITH THE UC INTRICACY
STUDENTS FOR THE SECOND YEAR IN
A ROW IN ASKING THE LEGISLATOR
GOVERNOR FOR COMPREHEND
FINANCIALLY REFORM WE ARE
EXCITED BY THE CAR FOR
CALIFORNIA C. STUDENT AID
COMMISSIONS PROPOSAL AND HOPE
TO SEE FUNDING ALLOCATED IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET FIX
FINANCIALLY. THANK YOU. HI MY
NAME'S. MARIN I GREW UP IN
SACRAMENTO ATTENDED TO HIM
BECAUSE SHE AND I AM NOW
SITTING AT UC BERKELEY AND I
WILL KEEP THIS SHORT- TODAY I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
EXPERIENCES OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
OR DO YOU TEND. THESE AND I'M
URGING THE COMMITTEE TO. A
SUPPORTER BUDGET ASK FOR TWENTY
THREE MILLION AN ONGOING
FUNDING FOR SAFER PROGRAMS.
SYSTEM BY. YOU SEE ALL. THE
NEWS THREE. I'M IN. AT HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE BOSS OF
DECREASING CALL. SIR STERN
COMMUNITY SO I JUST WANNA
HIGHLY THAT'S PET FUNDING AND
ESPECIALLY RETENTION EFFORTS
ARE COLLEGE CAMPUSES FOR
BLOCKING NEXT POPULATIONS ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. CHAIRMAN ARE THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ALICIA SIX SENATE AND
I'M A LONG CITED HICKMAN AND
WHERE MEMBERS OF UC SAN DIEGO
STUDENT GOVERNMENT. WE'RE HERE
TODAY TO DISCUSS ACCESS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION RATED
CALIFORNIA THE TARGETED WARDS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO WAS THE
WORK OF THE UC IS NOT
SURPRISING BUT I'D LIKE TO
REMIND YOU ALL. THAT INFO.
IMPROVEMENTS UC SYSTEM. I'M
FROM THE IT OF MONEY. THIS
SHOCK TO YOU THESE AND OTHER
ISSUE THAT HAS NOT BEEN BROUGHT
UP IN THIS COMMITTEE. AND IT
MAKES THE UC FEEL LIKE THE
AVERAGE FAMILY CANNOT SEND
THEIR CHILDREN INTO THE SYSTEM.
FURTHER CURRENT STUDENTS SEE
OVER IN ROME AND UNFUNDED
MANDATE ESPECIALLY UC SAN
DIEGO. AS A SLAP IN THE FACE WE
PAY FULL TUITION THE ANY OTHER
YOU SEE STUDENT PAYS. WE SEE NO
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS AND
SERVICE. THIS IS NOT A SOLUTION
BUT RATHER SHORT TERM FIX THAT
WE URGE YOU TO RE EVALUATE.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS THE NATURE CHO JAY AND
I'M A FIRST YEAR STUDENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY. THE LOCKER CRIMINAL
INTENT IN CENTER AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY IS A STUDENT INITIATED
PROGRAM. AND OUT OF THE
NUMEROUS A PET PROGRAMS THERE
MY OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE I'VE
SEEN HOW HELPFUL THIS PROGRAM
HAS BEEN FOR BUILDING A
COMMUNITY FOR MYSELF. OTHER
BLACKS IT'S ON A CAMPUS WHERE.
BLACK STUDENTS MAKE UP LESS
THAN 2% OF THE TOTAL ENROLLMENT
POPULATION. DENSITIES BAY AREA
COLLEGE TOUR WERE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO VISIT
AFFAIRS UNIVERSITIES IN THE BAY
AREA. HELP WANTED CREEK MEANT.
ARE WE- NEED TO FIND. BEST FOR
SUCH PROGRAMS IS REDUCED
ALTHOUGH THE- HELPFUL IT. WAS
SUITABLE. AS AND WE- AS A-
REFINED WE NEED TO PROPERLY
WORK. TEN BLACK STUDENTS. AND.
GOOD MORNING YOUR MCCARTY A
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ENDING WHEN I'M HERE TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE INCREASE
FUNDING OF SAFE I PROGRAMS. AS
AN INTERN FOR. Z. WHICH IS A
STUDENT. INITIATED A PROGRAM AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY THAT FOCUSES ON
RECRUITMENT AND- RETENTION OF
BLACK STUDENTS I'VE SEEN FIRST
HAND THE WORK THAT THEY DO FOR
THE COMMUNITY. PLAN IN WORK
OBSERVERS ENTREPRENEUR
WORKSHOPS TO SENIOR WEEKEND
WHICH IS BASICALLY JUST WENT.
ABOUT THEM BECAUSE IMPAIR AND
ALL OF. TYPICALLY FOR A WEEKEND
I'M REALLY HOT THIS HELPS IN
THE DIVERSITY OF SCHOOL I'M
BASICALLY I FEEL LIKE THIS IS
CREATES LIKE THE COMMUNITY THAT
IS NECESSARY BUT MOST OF THIS
IS STUFF AND THAT'S ALL ALREADY
SUPPOSED TO KEEP DOING THIS
PROGRAMS THAT ARE STILL HELP
FOR THE COMMUNITY IF THEY DON'T
GET IT FUNDING THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON HELLO MY NAME IS ON
THE CHARLIE I'M A THIRTY YEARS
STUDYING COMPUTER SCIENCE TO
MUSIC AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY AS WELL AS
AN ELECTED SOONER PRESENTED. TO
HAVE IN OUR UC'S BERKELEY
STUDENT GOVERNMENT. THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATORS YET
AGAIN FAILING TO SEE CSU AND
YOU SEE SYSTEMS. NOT ONLY IN A
LOCK FUNDING THAT'S- FOR THESE.
OPERATE I'M HERE FOR THE SET
AND LAST MONTH URGED. IT'S A
FUNDING THESE PROGRAMS I
SOMEONE IS PARTICIPATING
NUMEROUS A PET PROGRAMS FROM.
ILL PT EUROPEANS TO INITIATE
PROGRAMS LIKE THE BLACK
RECRUITMENT RETENTION CENTER. I
UNDERSTAND ON TOP OF THESE
PROGRAMS ARE FOR STUDENTS SEE.
PROGRAM PROVIDES YOU WITH THE
NECESSARY SKILLS AT THE KEY TO
TWELVE CATION. I SEE WERE BUT
THEY HAVE ALSO. AGE TO RETAIN
ME WE ASKED FOR AN INCREASE IN
FUNDING THESE PROGRAMS NOT AS A
SUPPLEMENT FOR STUDENTS
EDUCATION. PLAZA FONDATION FOR
LOW INCOME STUDENTS OF COLOR TO
BE PREPARED RECRUITED AND
RETAINED AT THESE INSTITUTIONS
OF HIGHER EDUCATION. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN PARTY AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR HOSTING THIS
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION. ABOUT
HIGHER EDUCATION ACCESSIBILITY
I THINK IT'S AN EXTREME CONCERN
FOR STUDENTS AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA. MY NAME'S VINSON
ROSS SO I AM A STUDENT AT UC
RIVERSIDE AND ALSO SERVICE OUR
UNDERGRADUATE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR. I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE UC STUDENT ASSIST
YOU IN SUPPORT OF OUR BY ASK.
THREE MILLION AND- STATE
FUNDING FOR. THESE BROWN'S OUR
STUDENTS ACTED. OPERATION
ENERGY. PARTNERSHIP AND THEY
SERVE THE PURPOSE OF EXPANDING
ACCESS TO YOU SEE EDUCATION FOR
UNDER REPRESENTED STUDENT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- THAT INCLUDES LOW
INCOME FIRST GENERATION
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRANSFERS.
UNDER AND MINORITY STUDENTS OF
COLOR. WE MUST TAKE MASSIVE
STEPS AND SUPPORTING OUR MOST
UNDERSERVED STUDENT GROUPS AND
AT. THREE INVESTING IN C. PAP
FOR YOU SEE STUDENTS TO SO WE
CAN BE SUCCESSFUL. IN OUR
EDUCATION FOR ANY. REFLECTED OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
UC CAMPUSES STATE. HI MY NAME
IS AMER BREEDS- I'M ORIGINALLY
FROM WEST SACRAMENTO AND I TEND
UC BERKELEY- I AM A PAR OF
UNIVERSE IF CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION- I'M ALSO FIRST
GENERATION LOAN CONSIDER OF
COLOR. AND STUDENTS WITH SOUNDS
LIKE MINE TAKE AVERAGE OF SIX
YEARS TO COMPLETE FOR YOUR
PROGRAMS BECAUSE THESE
INSTITUTIONS. WERE NOT DESIGNED
FOR SINCE I GOT UP HER. EIGHT
STUDENTS FOR MARSHALL IS
BACKGROUNDS NAVIGATE COLLEGE
THE VERY INSTITUTIONS OF STORE
COULD NOT COMMIT. THESE HAD IT
NOT BEEN FOR THESE PROGRAMS
MARCH. I MAY IN BEER I NOT
ADVOCATE DO FROM MY JOINT.
BRING A DROP OR MORE POPE
THANKS. PLEASE SAY PEPPER WITH
ARE DISAPPOINTED. OF A HIS
MARCH. THE YOU. HELLO MY NAME
IS MY GIPSON I'M A RECENT PHD
GRADUATE IN GENOMICS FROM UC
DAVIS AND FORMER OFFICER THE
pI'M HERE TO SUPPORT FOR
INCREASING THE GRADUATION RATES
OF UNDERGRADS WE ALSO YOU FOCUS
ON THE GRADUATE STUDENT
COMMUNITY WERE OFTEN THE FIRST
NINE. OF TEACHERS MEANT. THE
PEOPLE. WE SEE TODAY ESUPPORT
WE MAKE SURE OUR COMMUNITY IS
ALL DIVERSE. COME BACK. AND
DIVERSE COMMUTE BACK. MANY
SINCE. OR PEOPLE TO ARE ABLE TO
GRADUATE DEGREES BECAUSE OF HOW
EXPENSIVE AND LENGTHY THE
PROGRAM WAS FOR ME IT TOOK ME
SIX YEARS TO FINISH. PHD IN
GENOMICS AT USE. ARM AND I WAS
ABLE TO THAT WAS HAD TO TAKE
MULTIPLE SIDE JOBS AND RECEIVE
FINANCE SUPPORT FOR MY UPPER
CLASS PARENTS. ON FOR THOSE
FROM A LOWER AND- DON'T ASK
THEM TO WORK FOR FIVE. SIX OR
SEVEN YEARS. TWENTY THREE
DOLLARS. MONTH I IS VERY ON A
TABLE AND WHY WE HAVE PROFESS
ORIEL SET THAT'S FAR LESS
DIVERSE IN THE STATE. THANK YOU.
HI I AM DAVID GEYER A PHD
CANDIDATE IN THEORETICAL
PHYSICS AT UC DAVIS AND AN
OFFICER AND A GRADUATE STUDENT
WORKERS UNION. MY EXPERIENCE
TEACHING HOW TO UNDERGRADUATES.
INTRODUCTORY PHYSICS COURSES IS
THAT THE QUALITY OF EDUCATION
AND DIVERSE THE OF THE UC
SYSTEM. SUFFER GREATLY BECAUSE
OF THE FINANCIAL AND SECURITY
OF GRAD STUDENTS. DURING THE
ACADEMIC YEAR THE AVERAGE
BETWEEN A SYSTEM IT'S TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
MONTH COMPARE AND SPENDS HALF
OF THAT ON RENTS. PLEASE AT THE
MAJORITY OF YOU SEE KAY IS
THERE IS NO ON CAMPUS HOUSING
THAT WOULD EAT UP LESS THAN 50%
OF OUR PAY. IN THE SUMMER THE
SITUATION AND WORSE THERE ARE
CLOSE TO ENOUGH TEACHING
POSITIONS AVAILABLE FOR ALL OF
US. I TO THIS TWENTY THIRTY
MANY FRIENDS UP TO ON THE SIDE
TAKE A SKILLS. OF CALIFORNIA
AND UP PART TIME JOBS AND THIS
SPECIALLY HAS PEOPLE FROM LOW
INCOME BACKGROUNDS AND ALREADY
I. UNDER REPRESENT MINORITY
STUDENTS WHO HAVE A TOUGH TIME
I MAKE AN IN CROWD SCHOOL- AND
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THE GRADUATE
STUDENTS ARE HIGHLY SKILLED
LABOR AND WE LOVE TO THE- MAN
AND- THE TEACHING THE NEXT. FOR
LIVING WAY. AND EASY TO DO
THIS. TO AND THE NOT. WEAPONS
ARE. WHICH PRIEST THE AMOUNT OF
TWO. POSITIONS DURING THAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING TOM CAN SEE I ON BEHALF
OF YOU A W. TWENTY SIXTY FIVE
REPRESENTING NINETEEN THOUSAND
ACADEMIC STUDENT EMPLOYEES MANY
OF THEM UNDERGRADUATE TUTORS
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA-
OUR UNION SUPPORTING YOU SEE.
YOU CASF AND OTHERS BUDGET
REQUESTS- INCLUDING SAY PAP-
AND FUNDING TO EXPAND SUMMER
COURSES- SAY PEP IS A CRUCIAL
WAY THAT YOU SEE SPORTS
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF
UNDERPRIVILEGED STUDENTS
INCLUDING DOCTOR STUDENTS WHO
ARE UNDER THREAT THIS YEAR- AND
IN THE PAPER FOR THE STUDENTS
TO ENTER GRADUATE SCHOOL- AND
BECAME CAL. BEECHER IN WHAT.
INCREASED REDWOOD AND WORKING
2 DEGREES GAPS HOWEVER GRAD
STUDENTS ARE EXPERIENCING
ENORMOUS COST OF LIVING
PRESSURES NOW AS I'M SURE MANY
OF US HAVE SEEN IN THE NEWS-
RESULTING IN PROBLEMS WITH
RECRUITMENT AND- RETAINING
UNDER REPRESENTED- GRADUATE
STUDENTS- AND THIS IS. TO
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS ON OUR
CAMPUSES WHERE- GRADUATE
STUDENTS ARE SIX TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO FACE MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS- THAN MOST OTHER
POPULATIONS- THIS HIGHLIGHTS
THE NEED FOR INCREASING FUNDING
FOR GRADUATE STUDENTS- WHICH
WOULD IMPROVE COMPLETION RATES.
REDUCE DEBT THAT AN OLD REDUCE
TIME TO COMPLETION FOR
UNDERGRADS- FINALLY IN
PARTICULAR YOU KNOW WE BELIEVE
A SOLUTION. THAT WILL- HELP
IT'S AN IT'S DUE. I IS PLEASE.
THANK YOU. THE NAME MY NAME IS
RON GUARD ON THE- ARE FOR ABOUT
LOST IS PRETTY COLLEGE DISTRICT
ALSO HERE REPRESENTING THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA- EQUITY COALITION. WE
BRINGING TO LIGHT AG NECK
PRETTY GAP THAT EXISTS WITHIN
THE STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA THE SOURCE THIS EQUITY
GAP STEM WITH THE YOU OF
SUPPLEMENTAL THIS UP OVER AND
USE PROMISE GRANTS AND HELP. AS
PROXIES FOR IDENTIFYING LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. STATE DATA
EXISTS AND PORTS THAT USE OF
THESE MEASURES NOT ONLY CREATE
DISADVANTAGE. BERKELEY
DISADVANTAGED AND UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS. CALL HIGH COST LIVING
AREAS HOME BUT EVEN FURTHER NOW
THREATENS FUNDING FOR THOSE
INSTITUTIONS THATSERVE THESE-
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. FOR ASK
THREE THINGS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THE FOR. WITHIN
THE SUPPLEMENTAL ALLOCATION THE
SECOND ITEM- CONSIDER EXTENDING
THE HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION- BY
AN ADDITIONAL YEAR TO ALLOW
ADDITIONAL TIME TO STUDY THESE
EQUITY GAPS. THIRD I REFORM
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID-
STRUCTURES THAT TAKEN TO TAKE
IN CONSIDERATION ACOSTALIVING-
AND ALSO CONSIDERING- THE TOTAL
COST OF EDUCATION BEYOND JUST
TUITION AND FEES IT STATED ON
THAT WILL THANKS IN. AS OUR TOP.
THIS COLLEGE THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA POVERTY
MEASURE REVEALS THAT POVERTY
RATES ARE SIMILAR ACROSS THE
STATE RANGING BETWEEN FOURTEEN
AND TWENTY TWO PERCENT. YET IF
YOU LOOK AT THE FUNDING
FORMULAS DEFINITION OF THE
DISADVANTAGED STUDENT YOU WOULD
THINK THAT HIGH COST AREAS HAVE
VERY LITTLE POVERTY BECAUSE THE
FUNDING FOR THE MUSEUM. THING A
FRIEND AID AS THE DECADE OF
BEING ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED. FINANCIALLY DOES
THAT BY INCOME LEVEL ALONE COST
OF LIVING IS NOT A FACTOR WHICH
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST OUR
STUDENTS. COMPARING CONVICT
POVERTY RATES. IN EMPIRE FOR
EGGS ALL THE BAY AREA HAS A 50%
POVERTY RATE IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE A SEVENTEEN. BUT ONLY
32% OF STUDENTS IN THE BAY AREA
GET CALIFORNIA PROMISE GRANTS
COMPARED 60% OF THE IN MY
STUDENTS. SAID APPEARS THE IN
THE IN OUR HAS TWICE AS MUCH
POVERTY AS THE BAY AREA WHICH
IS SIMPLY NOT TRUE. IT DOES
MEAN HOWEVER THAT THE BAY AREA
WILL LOSE SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING AND WE ARE
ASKING YOU TO PLEASE RECTIFIED.
HI PERSONAL KIDDOS HERE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION I'M HERE TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL. FOR
ONE NINETY NINE MILLION IN NEW
AN ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE CSU
AND TO HIGHLIGHTS YOUR FACE TOP
THREE BUDGET PRIORITIES. WITH
MORE STUDENTS IS IN THE SYSTEM
THE CSU IS IN NEED. OF A STABLE
AND SECURE FACULTY AND THAT'S
WHY CFA IS REQUESTING FIFTY MEN
AND DEDICATED FUNDING. FOR THE
HIRING TENURE TRACK FACULTY. IN
REGARDS TO ENSURING OUR DIDN'T
STAY IN BUILDING TWO EIGHT. THE
CSU. YOUR PROFESSIONAL
COUNSELING WORKFORCE TO PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. AND
THAT'S WHY WE ARE ADVOCATING
FOR TWELVE BILLION. INDICATIVE
FUNDING HIGHER TEN YOUR- LOCAL.
WE ASK THERE IS NO IN. DUE TO
IT FEES WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THE
C. SHOULD BE AFFORDABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE FOR ALL QUALIFY
CALIFORNIA STUDENT THANK YOU.
THE GERMAN MCCARTY- MY NAME IS
ERICA WE'RE ON A I'M A STUDENT
AT SACRAMENTO STATE FROM
CENTRAL VALLEY I'M FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS- I WOULD
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO FURTHER
NEGOTIATE WITH THE UC SYSTEM.
GENERAL THE STUDENTS AT A
GREATER RATE RICK GREATER RATES
ARE MOST PRESTIGIOUS
UNIVERSITIES ACT AS GATEKEEPERS
TO GREAT OPPORTUNITIES IN. AND%
DO NOT REFLECT THE DIVERSE
HISPANIC AND AFRICAN AMERICAN
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIA.
ADDITIONALLY THE COMMENTS BY
TODAY HIGHLIGHT THE NECESSITY
FOR LONG TERM FUNDING FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. MORE
ISN'T THE LARGEST. FOR OUR- AND
HARD KEEP HIM FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES COME. FORMERLY
INCARCERATED STUDENTS ESTIMATES
OF COLOR FACE GREAT GREAT
CHARGES SIXTEEN AND CASUAL
INSTITUTIONS. THE STUDENTS WILL
BE ABLE TO SUCCEED AT GREATER
RATES ONLY THROUGH A GREATER
INVESTMENT IN OUR INSTITUTIONS.
THIS INVESTMENT CAN BE POSSIBLE
BY ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM EARLY
ON WE MUST CONTINUE TO INVEST
AND INCREASE OUT REACH FOR
DORA. THAN OPEN COURSES FOR OUR
STUDENTS THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON OF A MEMBER STATE
ASSEMBLIES- SUBCOMMITTEE
EDUCATION FINANCING THANK YOU
FOR HAVING US- MY NAME IS IMAN
MAHMOUD I'M SECOND YOUR STUDENT
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY AND A FROM THE
SOUTHEAST SAN DIEGO- JUST TO
BE- AND LIKE REAL- THE LITTLE
BLACK BOYS IN THE ANNEX BOYS IN
MY NEIGHBORHOOD AND GIRLS DO
NOT. DIVISIONS TO SEE BERKELEY.
IN A WEBER BERKELEY TO MY- IT
WAS THE BLACK WILL COMMIT
RETENTION CAME. DOWN DURING THE
ACADEMIC TERM AND ASKING US FOR
US TO APPLY. I APPLIED WITHOUT
HAVING MUCH CONFIDENCE AND I
WAS ADMITTED AND WHEN I WAS
ADMITTED THE BLACK WORKING WITH
SUCH AS CENTER HOSTED US DURING
SENIOR WEEKEND- MISSILES ON THE
CAMPUS. AND REALLY SHOWED US
WHAT USER BUT WAS ABOUT AND
TODAY. I'M I'M WAS COMPLETED MY
SECOND YEAR. FOURTH SEMESTER
AND I WANT THE SAME FOR
EVERYONE BUT I KNOW THE
STUDENTS ARE EXPLOITED AND
THEY'RE OVERWORKED- AND THEIR
HIGH UNDER AT THE UNIV. AND THE
STATE. SO WE REALLY WANT TO
SEE. I'MTWENTY THREE MILLION
TO. TWENTY. OKAY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SAAD NOR
AND I'M UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT
THE ORIGINALLY FROM SAN DIEGO.
I AM THE FIRST IN MY FAMILY TO
MAKE IT TO A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY AND A LIVING EXAMPLE
OF WORK THAT SAY PET PROGRAMS
YOU ON THE COMMUNITY LEVEL. A
MAJORITY OF THE STUDENTS MY
HIGH SCHOOL WERE FUNNELED RIGHT
AS THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE ACROSS
THE STREET AND NOW FOR STRESS
THE POSSIBILITY OF US MAKING IT
TO YOU SEE OR CSU. SETUP
PROGRAM AMERICAN EXPRESS
UNIVERSITY LIKE UC BERKELEY
DAYS. THEY WAVE BY FEES FOR AS
A TEASE- AND CRUCIAL EXAMS THAT
I WAS NOT ABLE TO AFFORD THEY
TOOK ME ON COLLEGE TAURUS AND-
THEY SHOW ME THAT I COULD. MAKE
IT AT AN INSTITUTION LIKE UC
BERKELEY. WHICH IS WHY I
STRONGLY URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER. SORRY FINING SAY
PROGRAM SO THAT MORE SLICE
STUDENTS LIKE ME CAN HAVE A
CHANCE AT HIGHER EDUCATION AND
ECONOMIC MOBILITY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
MCCARTY MY NAME IS LISA CHIU
WITH ASIAN AMERICANS ADANCING
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA AND ON
BEHALF OF THE COLLEGE FOR ALL
COALITION WE'D LIKE TO URGE
YOUR REINVESTMENT IN THE
COLLEGE READINESS BLOCK GRANT
THIS FUNDING GOES TO HIGH
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE STATE. WITH
75% OR MORE SO SINCE YOU ARE
LOW INCOME FOSTER USE. MORE
EIGHT LEARN. HALF OF THAT
COALITION URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON
THE AS WELL AS THE REPEAL PROP
TWO OH NINE THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MCCARTY- CHECK
FROM THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY WE APPRECIATE. THE
FOCUS OF TODAY'S HEARING AND
THE FRAMING ON THE NEED TO
SERVE MORE CALIFORNIANS
STUDENTS AS WELL AS THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S. LEADERSHIP AND
ADMINISTRATIVE COMMITMENT TO
MAKING OUR UNIVERSITIES MORE
ACCESSIBLE- MAKES IT AB IDEAL
DATA SHARE OUR BUDGET
PRIORITIES LIVE WITH YOU FOR
TWENTY TWO ONE. SAYS REALLY.
WORK CONCERT THE LACK OF. IT'S
AND MORE GROWTH BETTER
UNIVERSITIES WE'VE GOT SOME
GREAT SUCCESSES TO DO THE
ENGAGED OF THE- TURN AND STRAFE
IS IF. WE KNOW THAT CAN
PROGRESS TO THAT. AB AND AS-
FROM P. C. SHARED. PAST WE
KNOW. SERVICE FOR YOU BUT IN
ROME. ALSO THIS AUDIO DIVERSITY
IS MORE. OF OUR STATE. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT REPEAT PROMOTES
SO FROM A- IN A- DEVELOPMENT
FOR CAL. AND THE ADMIN. TO WORK
WITH YOU ALL THE. DID YOU.
THANK YOU. THE U. R. COSTA
ORGAN. I WE ENCOURAGE. THEM TO
THE CSU SPECIFICALLY ON TRACK
FOR FACULTY HIRING ACCESS FOR
STUDENTS WITHOUT INCREASING
TUITION AND ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELORS WE ALSO WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONTINUE TO HOLD. THIS YEAR
ACCOUNTABLE AS WE NEGOTIATE OUR
TRACKS AND DRESS STEPS THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT PUBLIC TESTIMONY
WITH THAT WE WILL ADJOURN.